good morning
i love you
this is the health human services and
elderly affairs
commission committee we're committed
right we're a committee
and um
we have round two of our meet and greet
with folks from the department people
who come here regularly to testify
so we're giving them a little while to
introduce themselves to us tell us what
they do
so that if we have any
questions
our constituents want answered we know
to whom we should go so
if john williams would please stand
introduce himself again and then
introduce the ones you've brought along
with you today
good morning um
pleased to be in front of you today
you should have a handout um that i'm
gonna use to yep okay
there
should be enough to cover everybody
i'm gonna send these around and extra
copies would like back to put
to set aside for those who aren't here
or aren't here yet
you may go sure um you'll see on the
cover
page of the handout
basically just some identifying
information of my
contact information
the
medicaid finance director who uh
all the numbers that you see uh uh
financially are prepared by her team and
also do the rate setting for the
department and then if you're looking at
budget documents uh provided the
references to to how you would uh find
those in your your budget looking at
that
um
was to introduce you to policy leads um
within the medicaid group and medicaid
team
among the
individuals that
were to be here this morning sarah
finney unfortunately on her way into the
lob took a hard fall on the ice on the
sidewalk and
had to go back to the office to
take care of herself
but
sarah
as you as the committee well knows
likely is our lead on working on the the
dental
bill that's uh just past the house uh hp
103 and we're really appreciative of the
work that this committee did to
to get that passed thank you
um also with me
this morning and if they could identify
themselves for a moment
behind me is rob berry who is medicaid
legal counsel
rob
on the team is is tracking all the bills
to make sure that we're responding to
the lsrs the fiscal notes and we're
track to make sure that we're being
responsive to
lba
don landry
who is our
policy administrator
don
does a lot of the
leg work in terms of our
state plan amendments that are necessary
to implement legislation that may be
passed
also um in terms of our waivers
she's kind of a lead interface on
eligibility policy
a key person and on our team and um last
but not least is peg clifford who is our
director of pharmacy
thank you peg
and obviously pharmacy items end up
often coming before this this committee
as well
the third page
just tied to uh the chairs opening
remarks
about uh what
we might uh uh either be in front of you
or that your constituents may want to
talk to you about in this session i try
to
um come up with a a list of some of the
things that i think will likely
you'll either hear from or will be
speaking to you on
right now the item one on that list is
the medicaid enrollment
our medicaid enrollment because of the
federal public health emergency and the
requirements of continuous eligibility
we're required to maintain people
enrolled as long as the federal public
health emergency
is ongoing and that
comes with the enhanced federal match
to take care of those individuals
you know today we have over 235 000
individuals that compares to about 178
000 in march of
20 when the public health emergency was
first declared
the medicaid
group called granite
advantage the medicaid expansion group
has grown by over 66 percent in that
time period
and
the overall program
has grown by about 23 percent so there's
also been growth in in our standard
program
we've already talked about
the adult benefit uh legislation but let
me um take you to page four where we
sort of put together some um
a little bit of a dashboard to
communicate to various stakeholders kind
of what's going on and kind of what the
challenge is and what you might hear
from constituents about
um
the
if you look at the upper left-hand uh
pie chart there there's a
section called current metrics
and um
what we're identifying on the right-hand
chart and
the right of the left-hand shot first is
86 038 people today
if the public health emergency were
at risk of losing
coverage
breaking that 86 000 individuals down
about
28 615 individuals
um we have information that would
suggest that um
barring any new information to us that
they would lose eligibility that they no
longer would continue to to qualify
and another 55 000 that are at risk
because of
um overdue redeterminations individuals
weren't required to do redeterminations
during the
aren't required to do redeterminations
during the public health emergency
and we've been doing
a variety of
outreach efforts which are kind of
outlined on the
bottom here and over on the right hand
side i won't go into all that unless you
have questions
subsequently but just suffice it to say
if
you have constituents that are reaching
out to you on this matter we're we are
here to help we want to make sure at the
end of the public health emergency that
all those who should remain on medicaid
who are eligible do so and to help those
who aren't able to
remain eligible for medicaid to look at
their options
going back to the third page
so other legislation that we expect to
to potentially talk to you about uh we
understand there's two bills
um
taking advantage of the american rescue
plan
to extend postpartum coverage from 60
days to 12 months
post a delivery of a baby and there i
think
again i won't get into this but there
are i think
interesting public health reasons as to
why that that might be a good thing to
do
we're also working on
implementing the
home and community based services
spending plan which was another feature
in the
american rescue plan which provided
enhanced one-time enhanced federal match
of 10 percent to support
services provided on in the hcbs setting
um
the fifth issue which i'm
you know particularly concerned about
and there's at least one or two bills
that address
this i think out there avoiding
the collapse of maternity care options
in the northern and western parts of new
hampshire
coming out of this committee a bill that
was passed from a policy standpoint but
funding has been suspended as the in and
out medicaid option i know
representative snow has been in contact
with me on that many times
of course medicaid rates inevitably
you'll hear about those in particular i
think for
for nursing facilities and home and
community based services
the commission to evaluate the
effectiveness and future of the new
hampshire granite advantage health care
program kicks off again this week
and um generally
waivers and state plan amendments two of
which we're working on right now
as a
a waiver is the inpatient psychiatric
imd waiver as an amendment to our sud1
substance use disorder and supportive
housing
okay okay just wrapping up briefly um
the uh
the fifth slide uh just gives an
overview of the key functions that the
medicaid division is involved in
um and we basically support other
divisions and their interactions with
the centers for medicaid and medicare
services and lastly is just a
summary organizational chart of
individuals who are on the team some of
which are here today and some
you might meet at some future occasion
and with that um i've gotten the
hook to let someone else go thank you so
much mr lipman always a pleasure we'll
see you soon same here thank you
hi good morning my name is ellen
lapointe and i am the chief operating
officer at new hampshire hospital
and good morning my name is joe curissi
i'm the chief financial officer for new
hampshire hospital i'm also the
legislative liaison for
our service so if you have any questions
please feel free to reach out and
look forward to working with all of you
on any potential legislation that
impacts the hope mr christie what is
your position there again uh chief
financial officer sorry
good morning everyone my name is heather
milkween i'm the ceo at new hampshire
hospital
so the team that you see in front of you
today really can answer any questions
that you have
any of us can go back to the facility
get you answers so um we're here for you
and and please don't hesitate to reach
out if you have questions are you
building a new facility yes we are we're
building a forensic hospital wonderful
thank you for coming we'll see you again
good morning mr chair members of the
committee can you hear me sorry good
morning mr members of the committee hi
nice to meet everyone my name is
meredith telus i'm the director of our
division of program quality and
integrity integrity for the department
and i'm joined by francesca hennessey
let her introduce herself
my name is francesca hennessey my role
at the department is
administrator in meredith's unit for
fraud waste and abuse
and the division of program quality and
integrity does a number of supportive
functions across the department for our
program areas program quality doing
performance metrics and data analytics
and program integrity doing a lot of
internal and external audit functions
audit coordination and program integrity
for medicaid and food stamp programs and
we did not bring a handout because we
know we're trying to be very brief but
if you have any questions you can always
reach us through john williams
thank you thank you for coming
i look at john williams as the one
through whom i can reach just about
everybody
next
good morning chairman and members of the
committee my name is sandy hunt i'm the
bureau chief at the bureau of
developmental services and with me today
is wendy altman
good morning everybody my name is wendy
altman i am the bureau chief for the
bureau of elderly and adult services
and just at a high level the
we are part of the division of long-term
supports and services
and um
thank you for your time
uh under you
under you comes also the developmentally
delayed people
that's under the bureau of developmental
services so just a quick overview um we
we are
housed under the division of long-term
supports and services so services that
are going to be with somebody for life
and
we
have broken those down by bureaus we
have the bureau of elderly and adult
services which is for people who have
disabilities or people who are aging and
wendy manages the cfi waiver which is
the choices for independence waiver
the bureau of developmental services
which is the bureau that i manage we we
oversee three home and community-based
care waivers one for children with
developmental disabilities
adults with developmental disabilities
and acquired brain disorder so those are
our three waivers that we manage at bds
and by waivers we mean that those are
operated in the community outside of the
new hampshire medicaid state plan
as you know that's an interest of mine
and we will be having a bill on that
subject coming up later
thank you for coming oh and if you could
come up with a wonderful chart
sure sure absolutely those things that'd
be great that's right and that's the
music
now begins we can transition to the next
persons
good morning mr chair and members of the
committee i am katya flax i am the
director of the division for behavioral
health
and within my division there is a policy
unit as well as our critical time
intervention
program we have three bureaus the bureau
of mental health services which
addresses the needs of adults
in need of those services we have
the
bureau of children's behavioral health
which addresses
children's behavioral health needs and
then we have the bureau of drug and
alcohol services
i have some of the representatives who
you will see
from our division who will be appearing
before you
one of the things that is important to
convey to this committee is
that we are guided by
a stakeholder process that developed
plans that really lay out our work so we
have the children's system of care
so
there's a ton of programs under that
there's a lot of implementation that's
going on
as well as our 10-year mental health
plan that again is our guide and you
will often hear us talk about it and
talk about how our initiatives tie into
those two plans
so with me this morning
i will have them stand and
so that you can recognize them i have
our brand new director of the bureau of
children's behavioral health she started
on friday she is not
she is not new to this committee to this
work to the legislature or to the state
however she is
new to this role so that's rebecca ross
i also have with me
within the policy unit
specifically addressing
substance misuse but she also is a jack
of all trades and chill of all trades
and she can cover just about anything
and she often does appear before you and
that's jenny
o'higgins in the bureau of mental health
services we are fortunate to have
the
services of legal counsel
and he also serves as our legislative
liaison
and that's philip bradley
and
finally
as the
director of the bureau of mental health
services we have julianne carbon
and if you of course if you have any
questions i'll say you can contact me
directly you don't have to go through
john williams but if you'd like to
you can
thank you
with 15 seconds to spare wow thank you
and thank you all for coming we know
we'll be seeing you again
all right where are we
yes uh before we uh open the first
hearing the clerk needs to know
who is pinch hitting for whom
so if you would give your name in your
replacement
yeah uh representative josh query and
i'm replacing uh representative nutter
uh sorry friend nutter upper
what else
and we know people will be coming and
going today because a lot of people from
here will be testifying in other places
open the hearing on house bill 1609
relative to the scope of the fetal
protection act
and
representative wolf would you present
your bill please
[Music]
thank you
good morning mr chairman and members of
the health human services and elderly
affairs committee
like most legislation after passage the
fetal protection act needs changes
hb 1609
makes those changes
this bill rectifies the inconsistencies
created by the fetal protection act
hb 1609
serves to protect women subject to the
unthinkable act of rape
incest or forcing a fetus to be
maintained with a fetal anomaly
incompatible with life
this act does not promote abortion
but respects the life of a mother who
has been placed in these rare
unfortunate circumstances through no
fault of her own
new hampshire's laws need to reflect the
daily realities that many granite
staters are facing
currently the field protection act does
not consider these rare and extenuating
circumstances
the fetal protection act places very
challenging restrictions upon young
girls and creates an undue burden
these are young girls whose fathers male
guardians or brothers may have raped
them
creating a very specific unusual
circumstance
these young girls may have struggled to
break free from their abuser and rapist
and may need to go to court for a waiver
the state of new hampshire should not
establish a timeline for girls to gain
the courage and resources to get away
from their abuser and rapist and safely
make their own decision
the field protection act i believe may
violate the u.s supreme court's undue
burden standard at least in the case of
preventing a rape girl from getting an
abortion
also
the act is quite possibly in violation
of article 2b
of the new hampshire constitution's bill
of rights
a young girl being raped by such as her
father or another family member is one
of the most horrific acts that we can
imagine
how would you react if that was your
daughter sister or even one of your best
friends
think about it and now put yourself in
that young girl's position
these girls often cannot get away from
their abuser and need our help
this abuser usually is a father or male
parental guardian
this makes accessing
medical procedures earlier in the
pregnancy nearly impossible
sometimes it can take months for victims
to break free from their abuses
should our laws punish people who cannot
be free from abuse to make their own
decisions
should the state of new hampshire be
mandating raped women carry a pregnancy
to term
under 1609 raped women are not given a
choice but must continue their pregnancy
1609 allows that choice
it is not requiring abortions but
allowing choice
the existing law requires ultrasounds to
be performed on a young woman
before any abortion
how much more are we going to make a
young girl suffer that has been raped or
incestually attacked by a relative
house bill 1609 removes this unnecessary
mandate
medical decisions like these after such
traumatic experiences are incredibly
personal decisions between a possibly
pregnant young girl and her doctor and
perhaps her clergy
i do not believe that this is a decision
for 424 volunteer
legislators of which
nearly none have the maternal and
dramatic health care expertise to make
this legislation is not pro-abortion
but it is supportive of rape and incest
victims and young girls dealing with
extreme trauma
we are protecting life by leaving the
existing abortion ban in place but we
are also considering the realities of
daily life in the granite state
i hope you'll listen to what i've said
and vote 1609 hard to pass
do you have written testimony to hand to
them i do i do have it thank you
anyone who is a committee chair we're
due on the third floor in a few minutes
i turn
over to my vice chair
thank you um are there any questions
from the committee members
thank you for your testimony thank you
very much
next we will have a representative from
the department of health and human
services
yes
yes yes
um
sorry the chairman had asked that we let
the let the department of health and
human services and then let then have
all the reps testify
yes thank you
good morning representative leon and
members of the committee my name is abby
rogers i'm the legislative liaison for
the division of public health services
good morning um uh for the for the
record my name is sai chiral i'm the
bureau chief for the population health
and community services
good morning
i'm jacques chawla i'm the bureau chief
of public health statistics informatics
uh we're here we are here to speak
specifically to section four of the bill
which requires the department to cut
collect up uh pregnancy termination
statistics so that's the scope of what
we're here to talk about today
uh thank you for giving us this
opportunity to speak about the reporting
piece uh we have ident there are two
pieces two big pieces identified in this
bill uh one is reporting from the
providers we don't have currently have
any system that allows the providers to
report directly to us so we would have
to create a new system to get that
information and this has to be hipaa
protected so that's a privacy and
liability those have to be built into
the system currently there is no
appropriation set for set forth for
creating that system that's one part of
it the other part is we also have to
have other data systems that has to be
in place that mr chavla will be talking
more in
[Music]
sorry i need to stretch my body
so currently the indicator of
termination of pregnancy after 24 weeks
gestational age is not currently
available in the dhhs data portal
formerly new hampshire health wisdom
system
in order to do so you will require
additional resource workforce for the
division to do the data analysis and
visualization to conduct statistical
reporting for this purpose
so i would like to give some
information from the bureau bureau of
health statistics currently staffing
limitation so the bureau of health
statistics provides data analysis and
epidemiological statistical support uh
as the health statistics center of new
hampshire
and um depending on the data
availability this type of report will
need to be customized
and
with the limited resource country the
bureau has
we don't have enough
staff to provide this type of customized
data modeling data virtualization and
data analysis currently the bureau only
has one full time data analyst as well
as the one full time system developed
developer in order to do the
virtualization on the online system
we are here to take any other questions
you might have from the committee
um representative folsom
um mine is a simple question i need your
names written out for me so i can put it
in the record thanks
um representative
uh thank you uh
madam chair and thank you for taking my
question uh on page two uh line of 32
refers to uh termination of
excuse me
determination of pregnancy does that
also in terms of what you would
understand as miscarriage
uh would that be included in this
database
that
um
what i understand is the termination
after 24 weeks
will be like elective so for this field
we are looking for elective termination
for the miscarriage um it will have a
different type of coding or
data analysis that will vote on the cms
so if i
continue
madam chair
yes yeah follow up uh thank you uh so
another if we added
uh voluntary
termination of pregnancy that would
clarify any
confusion about the miscarriage
we are talking about some medical terms
so it might be very different from
different things this is a data part of
it where the data collection or the
information comes from us from the
hospital so that's how the coding
happens we don't make those codes so it
can be different so we can expand the
course to look at but that's again that
comes back to the
underlying legislation what's required
okay thank you i think we'll discuss
that when we execute thank you
are there other questions from the
committee
i i have one question are you aware of
any cases where a
where a victim has been
raped especially an insane case where
they weren't able to receive this
service until after six months gestation
we we don't have that kind of
information as the department doesn't
collect that information that would be
there in other places but not in the
department of health and human services
okay thank you and do you know where we
might be able to find those
i wouldn't know that thank you thank you
any other questions
thank you very much
next we will call representative len
turcotte
thank you madam chair members of the
committee
my name is uh representative len
turcotte i represent stratford county
district four which is the town of
barrington i promise i'm going to be
very short and i will not take any
questions after
i sit on three different committees but
today i come to you
and sit before you as a representative
of the house majority office we in the
house majority office recommend that
this bill be found inexpedient to
legislate
last year's part of hb2 the house of
representatives passed an exceptional
fetal protection led
exceptional fetal protection legislation
and just two weeks ago
the house tabled another bill
and a possible amendment that would have
chipped away
at the hb2 legislation that we passed
just last year
this bill h.b 1609 is a further attempt
to roll back and infringe upon last
year's legislation
therefore house majority office strongly
recommends hpe 1609 be found in
expedient to legislate
thank you
next we will call representative david
love
thank you madam chair thank you members
of the committee my name is
representative david love i represent
rockingham six which is derry
and i come here in uh in opposition to
1609.
um
you know to rebut uh representative
wolf's um testimony
for uh
those that have been raped and incest up
until 20 24 weeks there is nothing that
stops them nothing in statute that stops
them from
from uh you know getting an abortion as
our current laws sit
and um you know it's only up until 24
weeks
stripping out the uh the ultrasound
requirements would be uh the equivalent
of asking a police officer to stand on
the side of the road pulling people over
uh writing them a speeding citation and
going to court and looking at the judge
and say i think they were doing 70.
you know uh
it it wouldn't stand uh and neither
would uh neither would
a question on the on the gestation of a
baby um you know we're talking uh
pain-capable
pain capable babies uh i've got a
a uh
an interview
by dr ben carson the world renowned
neuros uh pediatric neuroscience uh
neurosurgeon
and uh
it says uh that i've had the privilege
of being able to operate on little
babies that were 25 26 27 28 weeks
gestation
said the world famous neurosurgeon i can
guarantee you
they can feel pain
they can react
you have to give them the anesthesia if
you're going to cut them believe me said
carson who added
they can also respond to comfort and
warmth to somebody to say that that that
it's a meaningless bunch of cells
honestly said carson is totally is just
totally ignorant
carson said the act of aborting a child
is barbaric
and i tend to agree and especially in
this case uh
that and that for late term abortions
where the baby could live outside the
womb he used the term murder
the level of barbarianism that late term
abortion requires i quite frankly don't
know how people can do it said carson
once again you know this this is a a
world-renowned pediatrics uh
neurosurgeon that has operated and uh
you know i emailed the the committee a a
clip from the movie unplanned
and uh i did that this morning i emailed
a few others uh the other day but uh
it's it's only two or three minutes and
i i ask you to watch it you know uh you
know the the the doctor and the
assistant the assistant are certainly
paid actors but the baby in that
ultrasound is not
you know that that baby kicks it kicks
at the instrument that's that's going to
be you know tearing it from from limb uh
once again it just uh it shows the
barbarianism
of abortion
thank you
thank you representative any questions
from the committee
seeing none thank you thank you
next we'll call from far away
representative kanark
thank you
thank you very much madam chair
for the record i'm representative jerry
canuck and i'm representing
carroll county district 3 and for those
who don't already know i'm a retired
surgeon as well
so i'm here to testify in support of hb
1609 which removes some of the most
troublesome portions of the fetal life
protection act an act that legislates
the practice of medicine which we don't
do
compromises patient-centered
evidence-based care and criminalizes a
standard of medical practice
abortions after 24 weeks gestational age
are really very rare
and they're usually done in major
medical centers nearly exclusively
because of the discovery of a severe
fetal anomaly which is incompatible with
survival
or when the pregnancy presents a severe
risk to the mother's health
now importantly what 1609 does is it
adds an exception for severe fetal
anomalies which wasn't in the original
these are anomalies that are not
compatible with life
and there those are also rare but there
are a number of different anomalies for
example anencephaly when a child is
going to be born without any portion of
the head or brain and there are other
ones many of them are neurologic where
there is simply no brain whatsoever just
a bag of fluid
these are
these are infants which will not survive
after birth or if they do it's for a few
days or only with heroic efforts
this uh the issue is that
you kind of wonder why 24 weeks
well it's important to realize that
although we may know there's an anomaly
early sometimes the severity can't be
determined until after 24 weeks as you
look at it with further ultrasound and
given our large population of uninsured
and uninsured underinsured uh people uh
it's important to realize that some
women may not even obtain prenatal natal
care before 24 weeks
and in a case of rape or incest
the comment was made a moment ago she's
got 24 weeks but some may be too
traumatized to even go seek care
and the other is sometimes a woman
doesn't know she's pregnant i know you
may find that a little weird i was not
no byn i was a spine surgeon but i had
this happen once
i had a woman about 17 come walking in
to be seen for back pain
i had a medical resident shadowing me
that day after we took the history and
we walked out i looked at her because
she was changing her clothes i said does
she look pregnant to you
she said kind of does
so i hadn't done an examination of the
abdomen for the size of the uterus for
quite some years but i could remember
how to do it and found her uterus and it
turns out she was about seven months
pregnant she had received zero prenatal
care she was clueless that she was
pregnant so it can happen
the bottom line is it's really
devastating for a mother and a father to
be confronted with a severe fetal
anomaly
the accepted medical choices available
to patients
to parents i should say
are either termination of the pregnancy
or to carry the pregnancy to term and
provide comfort care until the baby dies
this difficult decision should be made
by the parents
and the provider
not legislators
the fetal life protection act by
prohibiting the choice of termination
forces the mother to carry the baby to
term and go through labor and delivery
only to watch the infant die
i do have one concern about this bill
though it though it improves the current
law it does fail to remove the sections
which expose the provider to civil and
criminal liability sections 329-46
and 3-2 sorry 3-9-2 colon 46 and
3-9-2-47
should be repealed as well even with the
exceptions allowing termination of
pregnancy for severe fetal anomaly which
is added
or in the case of life of the health of
the pregnant woman the exposure of a
physician to criminal and civil
liability with up to a hundred thousand
dollar fine in years of prison
is very troubling
we're we're used to civil liability
because we've got malpractice
cases we have to face
but the criminalization
of the wrong decision
wrong in quotes
places an extra burden on the physician
because the decisions that we face as
physicians are often complicated
with serious consequences and a lot of
gray areas there's been massive
documentation that on any number of
relatively common disorders when you
when the story is presented to a panel
of physicians that they'll disagree on
what the decision would make it would be
and it's justifiable so different
providers can make justifiably different
decisions even replaced with the same
problem
so place yourself in the shoes of a
physician who must make a decision when
faced with a seriously ill pregnant
woman
perhaps blood pressure 220 over 180 and
they've got to do something about it or
a fatal fetal anomaly no longer can they
make the best decision for the mother
they got to watch over their shoulder
and wonder whether some court will later
decide that that fetal anomaly
or
that seriously ill pregnant woman wasn't
quite severe enough to justify
the termination
that's what happens in male practice
we're only facing civil penalties
they need to wonder whether this court
will later decide that it wasn't serious
enough and sends them off instead to
prison
this is really going to make it hard for
us to be able to recruit
ob gyn practitioners to this state and
particularly anybody who wishes to work
in high-risk obstetrics
thank you i'll take questions if they're
already
yes representative thank you
microphone
your microphone please yes
thank you madam chairman thank you
representative take my question it's a
very quick question
um
i'm not clear from your testimony do you
intend to submit an amendment to this
bill
i would think it would be a reasonable
thing to do um
because again i think it should be it
would be wise to remove at least the
criminal penalty if not the civil
penalty as well so that i think should
be considered as weak as we consider the
bill thank you thank you very much
other questions from the committee
i have one uh thank you very much for
taking the question is there anything in
the law that prohibits a doctor with a
patient with preeclampsia as you
mentioned or any other of these
challenges from simply delivering the
baby early either through induction or
through a cesarean
actually no that that's an option and i
have a very good friend who had a
28-week gestational age baby who had
preeclampsia and did have her delivery
and i know this child quite well and
she's had a lot of problems but she's
been doing fine so that's fine but that
that is a so that can be an option
um sometimes and i think you know again
in the heat of the battle
you may not be able to to move on to
that one well and so i think again the
question is should legislators with no
training
distant
at some point in time make a decision
that influences the decision made by
the surgeon the ob gyn
at that moment
anybody who's been in
faced with the patient who is looking
like they're going to die right in front
of you doesn't want to take a lot of
time thinking about whether they could
go to jail for making what's going to be
an appropriate decision
so yes they could do that but that's the
thing
it's a choice
not a mandate
and just as a follow-up is there any
time when the mother's health is
protected by
terminating that child before that early
delivery or would that waste those
precious seconds
i
i might defer to the any ob gyns that
might be coming up i don't know for sure
but i would presume that that could be
because it probably takes a little
longer to organize for an actual
delivery which would usually have to be
a cesarean um actually they're both
operations so i don't know for sure i
will have i better not go any further
because i know not to speak when i don't
know
thank you very much any other questions
thank you very much for your testimony
thank you very much
next we will call representative kurt
welper
and as we have a very long list
we will start going to the time limits
as well we've been doing a pretty good
job with that and i'll just start
watching it more closely thank you
thank you madam chair members of
committee for the record
my name is kurt walper i represent
stratfor district 3 the towns of
new durham and stratford
but today i come to you as the vice
president of new hampshire right to life
we are
the
largest and most focused pro-life group
in the state with thousands of
supporters
we
were involved in the development of the
fetal life protection act and i just
want to very briefly you have written
testimony already so i'm just briefly
going to cover a couple quick points
then we don't need any changes to the
flpa the family uh
vietnam protection act it was carefully
constructed to avoid the challenges that
we hear about today the undue burden
statute
one is just one there are several other
constitutional issues that could have
come up
over this bill but it was conduct it was
constructed specifically to avoid all of
those
so there's that
here i want to talk as you just asked
about about the delivery and the
abortion business right
delivery is faster
you can get delivery done in i don't
know 12 hours or 20 hours an abortion at
this stage of pregnancy takes days
so it's faster and safer
for the woman to have an early delivery
and of course way safer for the baby
but that delivery has other benefits
that abortion
negates
and that is the child actually gets born
the mother
the parents
can relate to the child they can love
that child no matter how short its life
might be and there's testimony of
thousands of mothers
about the few minutes that they have
with their
child
as it expires
and the value that that provides
everybody's uh
sympathetic
empathetic with rape and incest victims
but six months is a long time
and at some point
we have to say you've had enough time
and
it's time we we need to protect that
that human being that was recognized way
back in roe versus wade
right so there's that
and the fetal anomaly issue is similar
right it's
we should just choose life
it's just so much easier one more thing
rape victims
actual studies of rape victims
the mothers
testify that the baby helps them heal
gives them a reason to continue living
and
look to the future
and abortees
represent the abortion as a second grade
with that you have my written testimony
and in introduced time i won't take any
questions
thank you very much
next we have representative john graham
oh he's in the chairs meeting i
apologize that's why it was stacked that
way
um thank you then um
next we have lori stafford from health
and human cert oh sorry we have laurie
safford sorry i'm trying not to not
trying to give you a job at the
department i apologize thank you
good morning um thank you for listening
to my testimony
um so
the fetal life protection act is a
moderate common sense law that should
stand as as is
most granite staters like me believe in
these protections
for third trimester babies
i'm also a widow and a mom of two adult
sons with duchenne muscular dystrophy
although they couldn't be here today
you may remember them testifying in the
past in their power wheelchairs
um
ben and sam asked me to share with you
today
that although they have a
life-threatening condition due to a
genetic defect at birth
that they have lived full productive
rich lives
not that it has been easy
i lost my husband their father over 10
years ago but ben has a social work
degree
he works for a nonprofit helping others
with disabilities
sam is a musician
and a motivational speaker
so i'm here to ask you today
not to deny this same chance for life
to others who may
have a fetal anonymous
anomaly
um and i also wanted to
tell you really quickly about my friend
who i met when she was seven months
pregnant
and her doctor told her that her baby
would not survive birth her name is
rosalie stafford she was from salem new
hampshire
and and we prayed and
she decided not to have an abortion
and that child is now 21 years old
so the doctors can be wrong when they
say that a child is incompatible with
life
and so i think we should always err on
the on the side of life
i'm happy to take any questions
thank you very much for your testimony
any questions from the committee
representative
would you believe that my
daughter-in-law had the same problems
she had anomalies with two of her babies
in separate pregnancies both times the
doctors were adamant
about saving her life and that the
babies would not survive one had a
kidney
malady and the other
had
fluid up the spine and right into the
encephalitis yes
cranial cavity and it and it was severe
and there oh he's not going to live
they're not going to have productive
lives they're going to this child is
going to die at birth if not before and
she chose life and both of those boys
are
brilliant
doing there's no there's no
they're perfect yeah there was no
problem with them at all even though the
doctors
two times suggested suggested um
actually we're very adamant about that
representative delemus i'm sorry i'm
sorry it should be a question that
became i know it ran on a bit long but
but we appreciate that it's been a while
since being in committee
so thank you thank you thank you thank
you
thank you very much
next we have the honorable linda ray
kamerada
thank you chairwoman and committee
members
so
thank you for giving me the opportunity
to testify today
i come before you today as a registered
nurse asking you to oppose
hb1609
in preparation for today's meeting
and testimony
i did some research and i learned a few
things relative to this issue
let me share a few bullets with you
number one abortion providers
believe it or not require a transvaginal
ultrasound to be performed during
early stages of pregnancy but
new hampshire's new law does not even
mention this procedure and i bring that
to your attention because
i always watch what our legislators are
doing i'm always interested in
different viewpoints and what i saw over
the last several months maybe six months
is disinformation out there so i wanted
to clarify
that the fetal protection fetal life
protection law has nothing to do with
trans
vaginal ultrasounds
the new fetal life protection law does
not require
any ultrasounds
for early pregnancy
as some have claimed and that's
disinformation that i have seen over the
months
so
the
law as written
requires
an abdominal ultrasound or an obstetric
ultrasound
for
to help the physician
or healthcare provider
find objective information
to determine the gestational um age of
the infant the fetus
so
if i were the young woman
pregnant not knowing i have irregular
menstrual periods
and i have no idea
whether i'm close to 24 weeks my
physician or provider doesn't have a
sense of it either
then the ultrasound is required
in this
in this instance if termination of the
pregnancy is being considered
to
give objective evidence as to the life
of the
fetus
so i think that that's a good point i
think it protects the physician
because
the physician wants to make sure that
they're working within the parameters of
the law
um according to the new fetal life
protection law an ultrasound shall be
performed when there is substantial risk
that the child could be 24 weeks or more
the obstetric ultrasound requirement for
advanced pregnancies in a sense again
provides the provider
my last bullet is the current fetal life
protection act is not extreme as claimed
by many and that's my opinion
a six-month fetus is viable
the fetus if born given the opportunity
to be born
is viable and can live outside
especially with all our medical
advancements over the last decades
there's no reason to believe that we
could not support life until full full
um gestation and that's just been just
over three minutes so if you have one
last thing to wrap it up um and i'll
leave you with the supreme court
decision in casey planned parenthood
versus casey in quote in some broad
sense it might be said that a woman who
fails to act
before viability has consented to the
state's intervention on behalf of the
developing child and we are talking
about the developing child
thank you
um
identity and questions if there are any
any questions from the committee
thank you very much i'll hand the gavel
back thank you sorry
the chair recognizes matthew hood to
speak
from it says dartmouth hitchcock
thank you mr chair members of the
committee yes my name is matthew hood
i'm the vice president for government
relations at dartmouth-hitchcock
dartmouth hitchcock opposed the fetal
protection act last year for several
reasons some of which would be addressed
in this bill
and for other reasons that this bill
does not address as such we offer our
support for some of the provisions of
1609 but do not feel that this bill goes
far enough
the parts of the bill
that we support
add back important exceptions including
fatal fetal anomalies since while
they're rare some are only detected
after 24 weeks
the law as it stands now not only
intrudes upon a painful decision point
for a pregnant woman but also takes away
her choice
now should a pregnant woman make the
decision to terminate her pregnancy in
this situation
either our providers would be
criminalized
she would have to go out of state for
care
or she would be forced to carry a
non-viable fetus to term
and so while i don't think that this
bill goes far enough as representative
connor indicated in the discussion about
criminalization of providers and the
chilling effect that that would have it
does provide an important exception
as as our chair of ob testified last
year
and others the threat of criminalization
will have negative impacts on our
ability as a major medical center to
recruit providers including neo-data
specialists
not only at dartmouth-hitchcock but to
serve the region
we also support the repeal of the
ultrasound requirement since requiring
across the board
not only adds a barrier to women seeking
care but it also removes the discretion
from a provider who's trained with
respect to when necessary and
appropriate to provide ultrasound
and finally i would just add a note
hhs talked about the reporting
requirement
challenges
what's not clear to me uh about the new
reporting requirement is providers and
facilities are required under the
current law
to report if an abortion is provided
after 25 weeks due to the risk to a
woman's life so i as i read it the data
that's being sought now
is also post 24 weeks so i'm not sure
how that is
different or necessary to be compiled
thank you mr chair
any questions
from the committee yes representative
leon uh thank you mr chairman and thank
you for coming uh to testify today um i
will ask you the same question that i
asked of representative kanark are there
any times when um the mother would would
be able to deliver that baby early
either through an induced labor or a
cesarean where she would be better
served by terminating that child before
delivering them either through an
induced abortion or through a surgical
abortion thank you for the question uh
representative leon um i'm the vice
president for government relations not a
clinician's at dartmouth-hitchcock so i
can't answer that question but i'd be
happy to talk to our ob providers
thank you any further questions from mr
hood yes representative cushman
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question um were physicians
deterred from working in massachusetts
when abortions after six months were
banned prior to december 2020.
so i can't speak to the physician
conduct in
or reaction to laws in massachusetts but
my understanding is that exceptions
exist in the massachusetts law that do
not in the new hampshire law
thank you
thank you for your testimony thank you
very much
chair recognizes representative jess
edwards
uh thank you mr chair uh i i'm uh
representative jess edwards representing
auburn chester and sandown
i
was involved during the community
conference uh as this law passed into
hb2 so i'm a little bit familiar with
the the background into the thinking
and i just i just want to remind people
because there has been so much
intentional misinformation about what
this bill
what this legislation did it did i
to emphasize that there has been
representative don't use the word
intentional please
um there has been
a lot of information out in the public
domain
that i don't think was meant to
elucidate the facts about the bill
for example
um
it said that 24 weeks is an extreme
position
24 weeks is uh extremely well accepted
uh in society in
western civilization we were the 43rd
state to say that 24 weeks is where we
begin to recognize life and start to
treat the uh the baby the yet to be born
baby as a human entitled to human rights
also every european nation recognizes
that by the 24th week they're dealing
with an uh with a human being
so
um i think it whatever we do to this
bill it should be done from the
perspective of
at 24 weeks we're dealing with human
life with human rights
on the rape and incest issue
it may sound crude but it's so obvious
that a woman knows at moment zero
if she's a victim of rape or incest
there are 24 weeks for for the woman her
physician
hopefully the father of the child to
come to a conclusion about what the
right thing to do is whether or not they
want to
bring that
that that that baby to full term 24
weeks is a long time
i checked at west virginia university
where i used to be a
radiology administrator and i talked to
the academic physician that teaches
ultrasound practice for that university
and one of the things he mentioned to me
that i think is relevant
due to some of the scare tactics over
transvaginal uh ultrasound a term that
is not in our law it's obstetric
ultrasound but what was mentioned to me
is
after an abortion in order to make sure
that a woman is completely free of any
biowaste from the uh the procedure they
it's normal to do a transvaginal
ultrasound to make sure that the woman
is clean and if and if and if all the
bile waste hasn't been removed she's at
severe risk of um incurring sepsis which
can be deadly
so um so i hope as we debate this we can
debate it in honest ways
taking a look at how valuable life is to
each of us
and with that i'm done if you have
questions
any questions for representative edwards
seeing none thank you sir thank you
and representative john graham he has uh
given me testimony which
i will attempt to pass out
uh thank you mr chairman
my apologies for being late but i was at
that same meeting with you
um
for the record uh mr chairman and
members of the committee i'm
representative john graham and i
represent hillsborough district 7
which is the town of bedford
this bill is introduced correctly what
in my mind a couple of grievous errors
in what we passed last june in house
bill 2. that is not to say
that i am supportive of late-term
abortions
because i am not but there are elements
of the so-called fetal protection act
that need to be changed in my mind
first is the absolute requirement for an
ultrasound prior to having any abortion
performed regardless of the stage of the
pregnancy
you'll hear that this is always not not
always non-invasive
procedure but i can tell you that
categorically it is during the first
couple months
as many of you know my wife and i had a
baby daughter last november
as part of our routine checkups during
the pregnancy were ultrasounds to
measure
the gestational progress of the fetus
i can tell you haven't been in the room
while they were conducted
that these ultrasound
sounds done during the first three
months were done vaginally
think of what that may mean in other
circumstances remember in what we pass
there is no exemptions for rape
therefore a victim of rape who wishes to
terminate a pregnancy that results from
that violent act must endure an invasive
procedure
is this really what we want to do to a
young woman who has had that um
act perpetrated upon her
i don't think so second while in current
law we are concerned with the life of
the month mother we are largely silent
on the health of the mother i realize
that there are some factors in there
but this bill corrects part of that
omission and it does talk about the
health of the mother
likewise the current law is silent on
the viability of the fetus if it is
brought to term
a full anatomy scan a level two
ultrasound is routinely given between
the 18th and 22nd months
weeks of the pregnancy it is at this
point that many physical issues
that deal with viability
after birth are noted
note that i said as late as the 22nd
week
if something is found at that point and
the parents opt for some discussion
prayer second opinion before making a
decision we could easily hit the
arbitrary 24th week i think that we need
to reconsider
what that means about viability
and and the 24th week
window that we've established
thank you and as a co-sponsor of hb 1609
i urge that you find this critical
health care bill ought to pass
will the representative take questions
do i have a choice
i know i don't i'll try
any questions
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
um so the criminal penalty section of
the law says that a provider is only
punished for violation if they're
conscious of a substantial risk that the
fetus is
greater than 24 weeks old so
um in your understanding
what what criminal penalties would you
think would be applied this this bill
does not
address that um provision of law with
the criminal penalties that stays
so
um
i'm not going to address it
thank you
um
well the understanding is that if a
fetus is not approximating
or there's no risk that the fetus is
approximating 24 weeks that an
ultrasound won't be done do you
understand that 12 weeks the time when a
transvaginal ultrasound would be
utilized at latest that that's nowhere
near that and it's unlikely that that
would ever be necessary
um
i i still think that that requiring the
ultrasounds especially during the first
three months
is unnecessary once you get to the
fourth or fifth month
and when it is done
outside of the body
perhaps um it could be used uh that way
to try to determine gestational
age but i'll tell you
my wife and i knew the exact date
because it was by in virtual
feudalization
during these ultrasounds we got
variations of up to a week
um
with the ultrasounds
so you know just using that
is not
an absolute way to determine whether
it's 12 14 or 25 weeks
that's my opinion and that's having just
gone through it over the last year
anyone else
representative representative folsom
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um i think i just
want to clarify one of the issues and a
couple of people have spoken to this and
so
do you is it your understanding of the
bill that
um
ultrasounds would be required at any
stage during the pregnancy if there was
going to be an abortion that is the way
i read what was in house bill 2 yes
if that was clarified
with an amendment where it was made
perfectly clear
that we that an
ultrasound is not required until 24
weeks
would that be acceptable to you
perhaps i'd have to see the language and
i would also like to try to figure out
how would you how would you know that it
was 24 weeks you would probably have to
specify it at some point
earlier
wouldn't that be something that the
doctor
and the mother could approximate and say
uh i'm not sure if it's 24 weeks we're
close maybe we should do the ultrasound
to make sure is that something that
would be i i would again i would have to
see the exact language and how it would
be applied okay thank you very much
representative king
thank you chair
mr chairman for taking my question and
thank you representative um
my question is mainly one of
clarification i i'm um
i went through six pregnancies two that
we lost one was a natural miscarriage
well this and this both of them were
natural second one was an
ectopic and
i um i don't ever remember
being in a sonogram with my wife where
it was evasive so can you clarify why
why because my wife wanted me in the
room while it was done it was that
simple i mean why it was evasive
the basis is that she was as they said a
geriatric pregnancy
um
then she had had miscarriages in in the
past um so they wanted to make sure that
the fetus was developing normally but it
is not uncommon to to do that in the
first couple of months to measure the
growth
and to see if there are any anomalies
that are showing up at that point
thank you
representative cofoult
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for taking my question
can you point to anywhere in the in the
existing law that refers to transvaginal
ultrasound
it says ultrasound and in the first
in my
experience and understanding in the
first three months they are not done
over the the stomach they are done
internally
so that's where
that's where it is
thank you
i should have taken you up on walking
out of here
anyone else
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
one last question
would you believe that i've had three
pregnancies and the only time i had a
transvaginal ultrasound was when we were
trying to determine if a surprise
pregnancy was a topic or not because it
was thought to be a belief and that all
of my other ones after that even eight
weeks ten weeks were all trans abdominal
i would believe that that is your
experience yes
you're free to go and congratulations on
this uh
and by the way i i hope most people do
that but
by the way i am a cigar smoker and i'm
still waiting
i gave up smoking years ago i didn't so
i'll take yours thank you sir
it is the custom in committee hearings
to call on
representatives first because often they
have to go to other meetings in the
building the chair recognizes
representative matthew simon
thank you mr chair and thank you members
of the committee my name is matthew
simon i'm representative from grafton
district 14. i reside in littleton new
hampshire i'm here today to speak in
opposition to hb 1609.
i
think at the moment it would be most
helpful for me to clarify this issue
regarding the ultrasound which seems to
have come to the forefront of the
conversation and explain why the fetal
life protection act doesn't require an
ultrasound prior to the 24 week period
representative cushman was alluding to
it in her questioning i'd just like to
make it as clear as i possibly can so
the fetal life protection act has
several different
elements to it separate sections to them
the first one
rsa 329 colon 44 deals with the
ultrasound requirement if you take that
particular part of the fetal life
protection act in isolation and you read
it
removed from the rest of the law i can
completely see why you would come to the
conclusion that an ultrasound would be
required
throughout pregnancy regardless of the
time
but if you go down two more sections to
rsa
344-46 i think
346. uh you'll see the criminal criminal
penalties section and in that section
i'll actually read it for you because
it'll be helpful
it explicitly states that the only thing
that the state is concerned with is um
ultrasounds at the 24 week period so 329
46 criminal penalties any health care
provider who knowingly performs or
induces an abortion in violation of this
subdivision and knows that the fetus has
a gestational age of at least 24 weeks
or consciously disregards a substantial
risk that the fetus has a gestational
age of at least 24 weeks shall be guilty
of a class b felony and in addition to
any other penalties the court may impose
be fined not less than 10 000 and not
more than a hundred thousand dollars
so when taken within the context of the
whole law the state only has a legal
interest in whether or not um
the provider had uh was provided an
ultrasound uh at a time where there's a
question of whether there's a
substantial risk that they're at the 24
week mark or they've actually reached 24
weeks that's the only thing that the law
is concerned with so that even if a
provider gives an ultrasound earlier in
the pregnancy because the doctor is
concerned well i don't want to be on the
hook for this i want to have an
ultrasound taken just so that i can
watch my back uh the only thing that
he's trying to determine is whether or
not that fetus is at 24 weeks you don't
need a transvaginal ultrasound to
determine whether an eight-week-old baby
is 24 weeks uh an external ultrasound
will do that just fine you can put some
jelly on the belly and take a picture
and you can tell perfectly well
we don't need to know if the child is
eight weeks we don't need to know if the
child is ten weeks we don't need to know
if the child is 12 weeks we only need to
know that the child is not 24 weeks and
that's
easily observable through
an external ultrasound uh so
the bill itself the law i apologize at
this point the field life protection act
uh does not require that it does not
even infer that it was not the intent of
the bill um and for folsom's point uh
just
to clarify for everybody i was bringing
forward a floor amendment to our last
session that got tabled that would bring
the language from the criminal penalty
section
forward into the ultrasone
section so that that was clarified and
there was no longer any any question
for the sake of time i won't touch on
any of the other parts of the bill which
i oppose but i'm happy to take any
questions any questions for the
representative
seeing none thank you so much thank you
very much
chair recognizes
karen sweeting
representing herself
thank you mr chairman there we go
thank you committee members for allowing
me to share my story my name is karen
sweeting my husband and i live up in the
lakes region of new hampshire
and i'm here to oppose this bill for
1609 i'm not to get this bill i actually
regretfully
had a reproductive loss myself in 1993
and six years later almost took my life
so with really recognizing the sanctity
of life and the importance of life
there was a mention of the movie
unplanned earlier i work with robia
scott
she was actually the woman that played
the face of planned parent in the movie
unplanned
she would actually was actually a backup
singer for prince before she actually
ended up getting into full-time ministry
with her husband
but she now runs an organization that
deals with counterfeit comforts and it's
people turning to
drugs or alcohol or any other type of
counterfeit comfort because of the pain
and shame of terminating a pregnancy so
as far as this bill goes i really hope
and pray that the decisions being made
will be opposing this because at any
time i mean
we are a bible-believing
god-fearing nation last time i checked
and uh the founding fathers were god
fearing bible-believing men
and i just hope and pray that there will
be opposition to this bill
because it terrifies me that the thought
of life is just so flippant and so
flippantly taken um it was mentioned
also about the case of rape
how does murdering a child then make a
rape a solution to a horrific
interaction between a man and a woman to
then take the life of a child
which only then perpetuates even more
pain and shame
so um i don't know
you know
all the ins and outs of this bill i
actually was not even here for this bill
i was here for another purpose but i
have a
funny feeling that god has a way of
working all things together for good
so
if there's any questions about my story
or how i if i will tell you
i was playing professional basketball
after i graduated from uc davis and when
i came back to the states i found myself
with this unplanned pregnancy and
however
the ultrasound if i had had an
ultrasound and saw the life of that
child inside me i guarantee you my
daughter joy
would be here today
so
um for that if there's any questions i'd
be happy to provide any answers to any
of your questions that you might have
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you sir
chair recognizes margaret
dry
and you have written testimony
thank you mr chairman committee
for the record i'm margaret dry from
plainfield new hampshire i'm a
registered emergency medical technician
and i oppose house bill 1609
today is day 18 for the fetal life
protection act though it's been on the
books only
less than three weeks it's already
attempted to be changed actually not
changed not tweaked
not fine-tuned and not clarified but
gutted
by introducing the word health
into every reference to the life of the
pregnant woman in this bill section
three
this bill takes the criteria for a
medical emergency from the very
objective physical realm of
life-threatening physical conditions to
the very subjective realm of health
roe v wade used the united nations
definition of health as a state of
complete physical mental and social
well-being not simply the absence of
illness or disease
its companion ruling dovie bolton
adopted a rarely a very broad definition
of health it said all factors relevant
to the well-being of the patient
including physical emotional
psychological familial and even the
women's age
familial factors are not medical
emergencies
what are they doing in this special
section defining medical emergencies
this new statute deals with abortions
after 24 weeks the purpose of the
ultrasound is to determine
gestational age the language of the new
state statute only requires a healthcare
provider to conduct an obstetric
ultrasound it doesn't have to be
invasive
in all cases non-invasive abdominal
obstructive ultrasound
can be used to determine whether or not
a woman is less than 24 weeks pregnant
and it is the most reliable method to do
so
these ultrasounds are available for free
at pregnancy centers across the state
west lebanon manchester plymouth nashua
rochester just to name a few
in addition to determining gestational
age
ultrasounds are used to verify pregnancy
determine twins or multiple births
and
very often to rule out an ectopic
pregnancy which is a true medical
emergency
these are all things that any pregnant
woman should hope would be taken into
account before any kind of medical
procedure
what's the rush
this statute was voted on
by a majority last session and it just
hit the books
give it more than 10 business days
uh i'm happy to answer any questions
are there any questions dr woods
representative woods
uh thank you mr chair and uh thank you
for taking my question
um relative to the free i mean that's uh
certainly a big benefit uh will that
continue uh with the current uh
uh emil you in which we find the
defunding of many of these centers yes
most of these segments centers that
offer free ultrasounds are privately
funded
any further questions
thank you so much for your testimony
thank you
the chair recognizes dr richard johnson
of dunbarton
mr chairman and members of the committee
thank you for taking my testimony i'm
here to speak against house bill 1609
excuse me basically for the reasons that
you have already heard so i will be very
uh succinct in this
uh in a matter of for saving time
one uh removing the ultrasound
is requirement is not necessary most
women receive two ultrasounds during
pregnancy the first in the first
trimester to confirm the due date and
the second around as has already been
said 18 to 22 weeks to confirm normal
anatomy of the developing baby
the fetal protection act never mentions
the use of a transvaginal ulcer sound
that would not even be thought of at 24
weeks of gestation
secondly if a woman has been assaulted
by rape or incest she has several months
during which she should be encouraged to
seek medical attention to document if
she is pregnant and if she desires to at
that time seek an abortion
thirdly the use as has just been
eloquently said the use of the word
quote health in paragraph 3 line 23 and
24 is very open-ended and has the
potential to completely nullify any
protection of the unborn baby let me
explain
according to the world health
organization health is a state of
complete physical mental and social
well-being and not merely the absence of
disease or infirmity
and enjoyment of health is one of the
fundamental rights of every human being
our own cdc
states that hedonic well-being meaning
focusing on one's feelings
or happiness
is important and that you demonic
well-being which focuses on the thinking
component of well-being means how
fulfilled do you feel
at this time
finally in to 1973 supreme court case of
doe vs bolton stated that quote medical
judgment may be exercised in the light
of all factors physical emotional
psychological familial and the woman's
age
relevant to the well-being of the
patient
all these factors may relate to health
end quote
using these subjective guidelines it
would be virtually impossible to
disagree with a woman about her state of
quote health
and therefore her desire for an abortion
hence
no protection for the unborn baby
fourthly rather than trying to unravel
the fetal protection act we should be
supporting it because it is good medical
practice as it protects
the life of some of our most vulnerable
citizens
those who are about to be full term
babies
thank you very much
thank you doc thank you doctor would you
take any questions certainly
any questions
representative folsom
thank you mr chair and thank you doctor
for taking our questions um
my question involves the ultrasound and
i'm assuming that you do not perform
abortions however if you were a doctor
and someone wanted to do have an
abortion and you provided that
would an ultrasound actually help
protect the woman
who is about to have that procedure
would it give the doctor more guidance
as to the procedure
it's a great question
since i do not perform abortions i would
never ask for an ultrasound to do one i
don't know the answer to the question i
can suspect
as a physician i'm a retired surgeon
the more information i have the better i
am able to treat the patient correctly
and so i would suspect but it's a
suspect that if i were an abortion
provider again the more information i
had the better i could treat that
patient safely because obviously i
wanted the woman to be safe
any further questions for dr johnson
seeing none thank you sir and would you
mind giving your script to the clerk for
our file please
and that being
not only does the clerk get one
we all get one
i cannot divide 21 evenly
the chair recognizes laura l
azeem and my apologies if i have the
name mispronounced but educate me that's
okay thank you very much it's laura
al-assam and i'm from londonderry
i'm here to ask that uh well thank you
for listening to me i'm here to ask that
you oppose hb 1609 and any other
efforts to weaken the fetal life
protection act
um i have five children some of whom we
adopted uh from the new hampshire foster
care system
and we found that many of the kids who
wind up in foster care have very very
difficult life stories
some are so tragic that they're even
used to justify
abortion as a remedy
and i invite you to see the foster care
system as i do as
a canary in a coal mine
warning us of the perils of
state-sanctioned violence an abortion
most starkly late term abortion
is exactly that
it's raw killing power inflicted on the
very weakest and most vulnerable
undercover of law
when we accept the destruction of fully
formed live and kicking babies in the
womb as legitimate
even for the greater good
it only follows that newborns and young
children will also suffer
it is not the developmental age of the
child
but the attitude of adults that makes a
difference
there can be no justice in a society
where every mother who holds her
helpless newborn says in effect i love
you
yesterday i had the power to slaughter
you but i chose not to
this is tyranny
and it's an especially insidious variety
because it attacks first and foremost
the natural essential bond between
parent and child that is the very
building block of a humane society
we are all every one of us affected
and so as a society we have got to stop
rethink
uphold the dignity and worth of babies
in the womb
or we can expect more cruelty inflicted
on little daughters and sons
we will see more children disappearing
and we will witness more appalling
images
like last week's video of a new mexico
mother tossing her brand new baby boy in
a dumpster to die
all of you have the power to defend the
powerless before and after birth
and i ask that you please preserve the
field life protection act as it is
written
thank you would you take any questions
if you have any
well let me try one
have you observed
that since abortion has become much more
widespread
and even legal
there's a slippery slope
partial birth
abortion abortion as the child is being
born
the putting of a child
over there somewhere
so as to die
legal in a few places maybe soon more
and
societally
it's now okay to toss a child in a
dumpster have you observed a slippery
slope
mr chairman it's a very
small step
from
killing a child fully formed in the womb
that we can all see
looks just like the baby that comes out
a day later it's very small step from
that to mistreating the newborn child
and that
that attitude that
small defenseless children
totally dependent on adults
are disposable
it bleeds all through our society
and it makes some very tragic
differences in the lives of small
children
anyone else with a question
thank you for your testimony thank you
very much
the chair recognizes deborah bishop from
where
good morning
i guess i'm on
um
thank you for i'm i'm here to read my
testimony to oppose this bill
i
have resided in ware for 36 years
when i discovered i was pregnant at 22
and unmarried i immediately set a date
for an abortion at the recommendation of
my doctor
the insurance at my job at the time
would even cover all expenses
after a few days of wrestling with my
decision i decided to cancel the
appointment and moved instead in the
direction of adoption
my daughter was born in may of 1982 and
she became the sheer joy of a couple who
were unable to conceive
three years later my husband and i
discovered we were pregnant with a baby
boy
and we were overjoyed however after some
testing and an amniocentesis
it was determined that
quote the possibility of fetal anomalies
is significant
impending intrauterine fetal demise or
severe intrauterine growth retardation
are also possibilities
another possibility is congenital
nephrosis
although so some infants can survive for
a short time it appears that congenital
nephrosis is inevitably fatal
this fetus is at extremely high risk for
having some other type of fetal
abnormality or impending fetal demise
if the pregnancy continues to viability
etc etc
as you can imagine we were devastated at
this news but rejected the
recommendation of the doctor to end the
life of our baby boy in the womb rather
than choose life
adam wesley was born in june of 1985 and
was whisked away from us immediately
upon delivery to be inspected for any
abnormalities
he was brought back to us a short time
later and told
you have a perfectly healthy
baby boy
20 years and 10 months later during the
mother's day floods here in new
hampshire in 2006
his life did come to an end
when his car veered off the road and he
was killed instantly while driving home
from liberty university
trying to make it home to me
on mother's day to surprise me
little did i know 24 years before that i
would be i it would be the daughter i
had given up for adoption
who would be the balm my broken heart
needed while grieving the death of my
second child
she had come to find us just 20 months
before adam's death
she calls me mom
she phones me at least once a day
and it is as if we were never separated
i often think of the loss i would have
faced if i had decided on abortion for
either of these people
i would have missed out on 21 years of
my son's life
and now to have both my daughters to
help bear the burden of losing him
has been healing
he filled my empty arms when i chose
adoption and she has helped to mend my
broken heart after his death
we don't know what the future holds for
us but we as mothers do hold the future
of our children in our hands
i'm asking you to help women make the
best informed decisions for these people
in their wounds by opposing this bill
and help protect the beating heart of a
child
thank you so much for sharing your story
would you take any questions
sure
seeing none thank you so much would you
hand in your testimony to the clerk we
keep
wow that's good you already have given
it
wow
i could leave again you know
the chair recognizes
catherine boyle
she says representing herself and
jeffrey williamson
good morning and thank you for having me
to share jeffrey and i's testimony
my name is catherine boyle
and jeffrey and i live together in
manchester
new hampshire i've been with jeff for
14 years
and we are opposed to bill 1609
this is a picture of jeffrey i'd be
happy to pass it around so you could get
a good look
and here's another one of him
and uh
as they say one picture two pictures can
tell a thousand words so i would really
is that appropriate to
pass it around now or leave that okay
thank you
i discussed this bill with jeff at home
he is non-verbal he's in a wheelchair he
has one strong arm that he relies on
to do just about everything that he can
do
i help him with everything else
and it has been just a sheer
joy
and a great privilege
to to have done that
and to to serve him
in that way
i just want to say that we oppose this
because um
when jeff was
born
the doctor said he wouldn't live six
months just take him home to die
and of course these parents had no clue
at that point he's 50 years old
so he
at that time they didn't have those tech
technologies to to forewarn as much as
they do now
so they were terrified they went home
expecting their baby boy to die and
you know he's now 50.
and his mother was advised to
not have any more children or if she did
have children to have them aborted
and so they were so scared they waited
eight years to have another baby
and then they did have two
beautiful healthy perfect
baby boys as well
but jeff is the big brother
and i think they would even tell you
that he has been
truly a big brother in their lives
in the courage in the fortitude in the
fight that he has
to live
as normal a life as he does in fact
you know we call these people disabled
but
they're really a lot more able in so
many ways than we are and they share
that with us when we give them the
chance if we recognize them and we we
look at them as more than what they
appear to be because you would never
know that jeff was even in there when
you look at him and
he almost died until he was able to
speak through an ipad which he learned
at 20 because he nobody saw him but he's
brilliant
and he is a lover of god and he's a
lover of man
and he has inspired so many people that
we come across that have known him over
his years
of being in the community his mother and
father advocated for him to do
everything as normal as possible he's
held jobs
and he's he's a responsible he votes
he's a he's a responsible citizen
and a great inspiration
and so
i've gotten to to um
to understand so much about the human
nature of people with disabilities that
are such unique gifts to us so can we
really make that judgment call by
formulating bills to to take away the
life of somebody in the womb that we
cannot even calculate the value of and i
want to say also that i can't imagine
that i would be sitting here to give
this testimony to you today as a woman
who actually had an abortion when i was
in my early twenties and was pressured
to do so under the circumstances but was
not my choice
so i will never know the potential of
that human being that i lost
and i didn't even know how deeply buried
that was in me because i never talked
about it and i can't imagine i'm telling
you all about this now but i'm compelled
to do that because the sanctity and the
value of human life that i lost i found
in living in relationship with jeff
and serving him so i just it's both of
our testimonies combined
and i thank you very much for for having
me
thank you very much would you accept any
questions sure anyone have a question
thank you so much for your testimony
thank you
because we have still a number of pink
cards
i'm going to call samantha and sarah
marku up together
and
i'm going to ask that you keep your
testimony combined to no more than four
minutes
good morning and um
thank you for hearing our testimony this
morning
my name is sarah marku
i live in northfield and i oppose this
bill
when i was 24 weeks pregnant with my
daughter samantha
i was sent in for genetic testing
because of abnormalities that were found
in her ultrasound
they determined that she had
microcephaly
a host of genetic diseases a hole in her
heart
and they said that if she survived being
born at all that she would never walk or
talk
we were told that the only humane thing
to do would be to abort her
humane as if she was an animal
i declined and another doctor
immediately came into the room to
express how imperative it was that i
take care of this her exact words
because
i was 24 weeks pregnant and at 25 they
would be required to resuscitate her and
at that point the choice would be too
late
again i declined
it was never a choice for me because i'm
a firm believer in the sanctity of life
but i've often wondered about those who
waver
those who don't have a strong moral
compass or those who are just plain
scared and confused
you see i also know what it's like to be
a teenager
and find out that there's a baby on the
way
had i given in to the pressure because
of my age i would have robbed this world
of an amazing young man
and later if i'd given in to the
pressure of those in the medical field
who were so insistent
the world would miss an incredible young
woman
if you take the time to listen to your
constituents there is a moral outcry
from the people that is being drowned
out by corporations with an agenda and
seemingly endless money to throw at
their cause
without even bringing into the
discussion the lack of constitutional
merit the massive human rights issue the
emotional trauma that post-abortive
family members live with or the physical
trauma and increased cancer rates that
post-abortive mothers face
it's time to take every possible step
toward halting abortion simply because
it's the right thing to do
if it means allowing an ultrasound
requirement
in this case then so be it
it's time that we stop encouraging the
slaughter of innocent people on the
altar of convenience
it's time to stop allowing doctors to
push their own prejudices and ideas onto
the very vulnerable patients at the
expense of human life
we are better than this and it's time
my name is samantha marcou and i'm 17
years old excuse me could you speak a
little more closely into the mic
my name is samantha marcou and i'm 17
years old
i'm from northfield new hampshire and i
oppose this bill
knowing i could have been aborted based
off of a diagnosis that wasn't even
correct
makes it honestly surprising to me that
i'm even standing here today
especially considering the fact that so
many others are not as lucky
no medical test could say that i love
reading and writing or show that i like
doing puzzles
no one could tell my family and my
friends that i'm creative or that i like
agriculture
they could not say who i am as a person
everything i have ever done and ever
will do i got the opportunity to do
because i was not aborted
that is an opportunity that everyone
should have but unfortunately not
everyone does
if allowing mothers to see their
children gives them that opportunity
then shouldn't both mother and baby
be allowed that
the fetal protection act should stand as
is
thank you so much appreciate that
anyone have any questions
representative folsom
i'm going to make a statement but i'm
going to say would you believe careful
thank you so much for coming um
and your personal testimony i really
appreciate it it takes a lot
uh to sit in that chair and you're
probably the youngest one we've had
today so thank you so much for coming
and doing that i believe that
thank you
chair recognizes
ian hewitt esquire
good morning mr chair and members of the
committee can you hear me all right
ian hewitt on behalf of cornerstone i'd
like to first say something about this
bill which we oppose and then to say
something about the amendment introduced
by representative beth folsom which we
strongly support
first of all this bill
has been over complicated and is much
simpler than it seems
it purports to introduce a variety of
changes but most of those changes have
no actual content or function
fundamentally this bill does one thing
which is to entirely nullify our current
law and it does that actually in either
of two ways but i'll just focus on one
which is that it completely removes the
ultrasound requirement
now our law uses a numerical line to
prohibit abortion 24 weeks or six months
and as you heard from representative
love when you have an enforceable
numerical line you need a compulsory
numerical measurement to use the example
representative love gave if the speed
limit is 65 miles per hour that's only
enforceable because you're subject to
the compulsory measurement of being
clocked with a speed gun if anyone who
wanted could opt out of being clocked
with a speed gun we would in fact have
no speed limit whatever the sign said
so in this case there's no reason for us
to debate about whether we need to add a
rape exception when you've known that
you're pregnant for four months because
the fact is that whether or not any of
these exceptions apply the bill causes
the law to have no effect and to be
unenforceable in every situation
secondly we strongly support
representative folsom's proposed
amendment
because it will help to protect the
fetal life protection act by further
clarifying what the law already says
rsa 329 46 already cabins the ultrasound
requirement to situations where the
abortion provider is conscious of a
substantial risk that the fetus is 24
weeks gestational age or older or six
months a representative folsom has
proposed to simply take this language
and add it to the end of 44 1.
so those who support the law as written
should support the folsom amendment
because it simply uses language already
present in the law and it will remove
the ability of opponents to quote 44 1
out of context
and moreover if there is any legislator
who is open to the idea of a late term
abortion ban but is simply in good faith
concerned that the ultrasound
requirement here is too onerous
representative folsom's proposed
amendment should more than address those
concerns
however we think that representative
folsom's amendment will likely be
revealing in that even if it is enacted
into law many of the same people will
still in all likelihood be attempting to
repeal or gut the law and we'd submit
that's because this debate is not really
about ultrasounds or any particular
exception but about a multi-million
dollar lobby and its desire to maintain
unlimited abortion up to birth
i'm happy to entertain any questions
about my testimony or any legal
questions about the law of the bill
representative folsom's proposed
amendment or indeed massachusetts law
well we can't look at representative
folsom's amendment just yet but we will
i may have misheard you i thought i
heard you say in reference
to this uh pregnant up to four months
wouldn't 24 weeks be six months
the reason i mentioned four months is
because
a woman in all likelihood has known uh
if she's been raped that she's been
pregnant for at least four months
so
extremely all of the data that i've been
able to find in published uh you know
peer-reviewed medical journals shows
that extremely late pregnancy awareness
is 10 weeks
so if you were on the extreme end of the
curve in terms of pregnancy awareness
you would have three and a half months
to obtain an abortion before the
six-month limit kicks in i appreciate
that thank you i get it now any
questions
uh representative folsom
uh yes um thank you thank you mr chair
and thank you um ian for taking our our
questions
could you clarify what was asked before
about the massachusetts law um and
i certainly could um the response from
the
person who uh representative cushman
asked the question of was was quite
correct as to massachusetts current law
massachusetts current law contains many
exceptions that ours does not indeed it
contains so many exceptions that
abortion is legal for any reason at any
time in massachusetts and there are no
criminal penalties in massachusetts law
however this only became the case in
december of 2020. in december of 2020
massachusetts passed something called
the roe act when you cash it out
effectively what it says is that
abortion's legal for any reason up to 24
weeks and after 24 weeks abortion's
legal only if the woman and her doctor
so choose so they've maintained a
nominal 24 week limit while legalizing
abortion up to birth for any reason and
they've stripped out the criminal
penalties section and replaced them with
nothing
however as representative cushman
correctly pointed out prior to december
of 2020 massachusetts had a felony
six-month abortion ban
and it did not have broad open-ended
exceptions indeed it had no fetal
anomalies exception
and i think the relevance to
representative cushman's question is
that massachusetts has for many years
been ranked as having the best or the
second best medical care in the country
so evidently physicians were not fleeing
in terror from massachusetts when it had
a felony six-month abortion ban there's
no reason to expect physicians to flee
from new hampshire either
representative
shapiro thank you mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question
can i be heard i can hear you okay thank
you
um
yes in your testimony you seem to be
very much in favor of the fetal
protection act as well as the
similar bill in massachusetts
so i'm wondering if
you and your organization
would be
against
further limiting abortion to an earlier
gestation period
when you say bill in massachusetts just
to clarify i take it you're talking
about the
previous law in massachusetts before it
was repealed in december of 2020 yes
which is much better than what
massachusetts has now certainly i'm a
little uncomfortable with this as the
chair because i am under the impression
a committee hearing is to debate the
bill
not the personal beliefs of one giving
testimony on a related subject but not
the bill itself
with you with your leave mr chair i'd be
happy to answer the question okay uh all
right within cornerstone and and among
our supporters i think people would give
different answers to that question which
is why i can't give you a single answer
right now but what i can tell you is
that we don't expect it's politically
realistic in new hampshire to enact for
example something like what we see in
mississippi we think the debate in new
hampshire in the foreseeable future is
simply not going to be about whether we
can enact a 15-week abortion limit for
example
the debate now and likely will
unfortunately continue to be
whether we should have any limitation on
abortion whatsoever or allow abortion up
to birth and so that's what we're
weighing in on
thank you very much i appreciate that
answer
any further questions
thank you for your testimony
representative cushman
just quickly does the
fetal protect fetal life protection act
require transvaginal ultrasound
no it certainly does not um i'm glad you
got the name correct it is the fetal
life protection act i think ols forgot
that in this case but the term
transvaginal ultrasound appears nowhere
in the legislation it refers to an
obstetric ultrasound which is just
another way of referring to an
ultrasound performed during pregnancy
the law was intentionally framed in
consultation with legal scholars around
the country not to place any limitation
on abortion substantially in advance of
24 weeks had the law actually done that
in all likelihood it already would have
been challenged and probably enjoined by
the first circuit court of appeals which
has made its position clear on these
sorts of of issues
instead the law was framed so that under
329 46
these provisions only kick in if the
abortion provider knows that the fetus
has a gestational age of six months or
more or is conscious of a substantial
risk that the fetus has a gestational
age of six months or more that's a very
common legal test in the law known as
recklessness it appears throughout our
criminal code and in our civil law in
new hampshire so it's easy for courts to
enforce
um representative folsom's amendment of
course would take that limiting language
and simply reiterate it once again at
the end of 44.1
making it even clearer and making it
impossible for 44.1 to be quoted out of
context
and hopefully resolving the good faith
concerns of any legislators who
mistakenly believe that there is an
onerous universal ultrasound requirement
in this law
any further questions representative
folsom thank you mr chair thank you ian
um
my other question has to do with
something i had asked earlier of the
doctor um
with regards to is it safer for a woman
uh the the
the provider to perform the ultrasound
um
in reading several things i have read
back and forth that oh it's it's
standard care practice to do an
ultrasound before
an abortion and sometimes i've heard
well sometimes yes sometimes no
can you add any clarity to that
well i can tell you we don't know what
the standard procedure in new hampshire
is and i can tell you that confidently
because what we have heard from abortion
clinics around the state has changed
numerous times month to month and
sometimes week to week
as recently as june 22nd of last year
the new hampshire public radio reported
that they contacted multiple abortion
clinics around the state and they
reported after speaking to them that
pre-abortion ultrasounds were already
standard medical practice
then later a week later june 28 the
union leader did an article where they
reported abortion clinics were telling
them that pre-abortion ultrasounds are
actually rare
then december 16th i i heard something
i'd never heard before and and was hurt
hearing for the first time on december
16th equality health center told the
union leader that in fact for the past
two years they've never done a single
pre-abortion ultrasound so the story
from abortion clinics has dramatically
changed many times and i think as a
result of that we have no clue
what standard practice in new hampshire
is with respect to abortion clinics
we simply have to take their word for it
and their word has changed a number of
times
any further questions
thank you very much
if you have written testimony we'd like
to have it thank you mr chair i do not
have a physical copy but i can provide
electronics that would be a good idea
and that's also to anyone else who
has read off their phones
if
those people could
provide the clerk eventually a written
copy
chair recognizes representative timothy
horrigan
thank you very much mr chair i'm after
timothy oregon from stratfor county
district six the towns of durham and
madbury
i just wanted to chime in on the narrow
issue of the sentence about the
obstetric ultrasound and of course the
bill
as introduced actually strikes that
sentence so that um
so if you were to um if you're past that
it would be uh
that whole debate would be moved over
whether or not it's a transgenic or
ultrasound or what a trans vaginal
ultrasound or regular one is or is not
um
i've uh
i miss what they call cis male so i
would it wouldn't be physically possible
for me to even have
such an ultrasound i have had an
external ultrasound and even that was a
fairly uh you know difficult procedure
it's fairly
fairly expensive it's not something you
want to make people
it's not necessarily something to be
appropriate to do in
um
in a situation like uh counseling
someone on a on an abortion and it was
uh
i was part of this we had a bill that
came through judiciary committee which
we uh adopted to
actually just strike that one sentence
from the bill and that
almost made it to the floor there was uh
the speaker ruled that it was a
non-germane amendment and he
for whatever reason he said he had just
done a few days before even though he
was actually
in the room
when we took the vote on the amendment
um that the amendment had been
publicized in every major media outlet
in the state and
i'm sorry
um and
actually the cornerstone family research
even used that in a uh several emails
because they were
basically
urging the speaker to remove two
republicans from the committee who had
voted to delete the object which
ultrasound so even mr hewitt's
organization sent out
emails uh saying that so it did seem odd
that the speaker
speaker must have known about the amount
i would now uh say to the representative
please confine it to this bill yes so
that so i'm opposed to the bill in
general but uh if you had a bill that
just did that that would actually have
bipartisan support if you did just
strike the obstetric ultrasound thing
because that's uh
that's a very very questionable thing to
make any woman go through especially in
many cases uh
women who
are pregnant through
rape or incest so like making uh even
it's not clear whether or not they need
the invasive ultrasound but if it
certainly is invasive ultrasound that's
something in many cases uh not
not an appropriate procedure to force
someone to have so thank you for your
testimony will you take questions um i
suppose i may not be able to answer them
but that's all right yeah
sometimes uh chair recognizes
representative leon yeah thank you mr
chairman and thank you representative
for taking the question um i'm curious
about your statement that the speaker
ruled on the germanness of the amendment
um i i did not hear any ruling or see
any ruling okay well i'm not sure i was
already interrupted by the chairman not
to my surprise but that was
that was my understanding of the
floor maneuvers that happened
obviously those were two long days but
that was
that was what i thought i heard and
anybody any of us can go back and look
at the video to see what it was he
actually said but um i
that was
that was my understanding of what
happened and certainly uh with a
bipartisan majority voted through a bill
that um he refused to let us vote on
but anyway
that's that's zen this is now open
thanks
thank you representative
the chair calls on robert and catherine
lacoste i have a blue pink card from two
of you would you please come up together
and uh
speak to us
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee um
my name is catherine lacoste and um
i am here to speak in opposition to
house bill 1609
i'm a wife
a mother of three a grandmother of three
i've been in health care for over 40
years of my life
we have cheered and i am here on behalf
of life
we have
cheered
the scientific advances that research
has provided
why would we not want the benefit of an
ultrasound there's been a lot of talk
about ultrasounds today as being very
invasive which some may be but i think
in the context of this not so much
the only thing that i can come up with
is that
what we find is that
women who are contemplating abortion
once they have had an ultrasound
often choose life
and i think that that's something that
you need to keep in mind
in my work i have seen
people at their best and at their worst
i've worked in
critical care i've given anesthesia i've
done pretty much everything with the
exception of
pediatrics and psych although when you
work in the emergency room you do a lot
of psych then too
[Music]
so
i've seen the devastation of poor
choices we all want to talk about choice
versus life
and i've seen the devastation of poor
choices from addiction to suicide and
depression
and i've also seen the true blessings of
choosing life
the fetal life protection act
that has been discussed today
and what is going to be corrected
by this bill
we can all agree that rape
is a horrific act
abortion doesn't fix
the violation
but adds a further victimization to two
people
and in closing i would just like to say
do
do all
residents of new hampshire
not have the right
to live free
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee my name is robert lacoste
i'm a resident we're a resident of
stratton new hampshire
i am 74 years old
again we have three children three
grandchildren
i'm
i have a bachelor of science of nursing
i have a diploma as a nurse anesthetist
i practice as a nurse anesthetist for 29
and a half years i've been retired for
seven years now
i'm a retired lieutenant colonel from
the united states army seven and a half
years active duty another 13 and a half
years in active reserve another six
years
in the inactive reserve
i'm a graduate of the u.s army
commanding general staff college
i during my years on active duty in the
army i was the quality improvement
officer for the anesthesia department
for an army medical center
and for a general a general hospital
army general hospital
during my years doing anesthesia i did
roughly two to three hundred obstetric
cases
i did approximately
i guesstimate 1 000 to 2 000 gyn cases
i did a total of
15 to 30 000 total anesthetics
during the course of my practice i never
heard once
anybody dispute the fact that life
begins at conception
the sperm fertilizes the egg
and at that fertilization that egg
or that zygote has all the dna
that each and every one of us has in
this room as we mature through our
gestation period
to birth
to life
as
as functioning human needs outside of
the womb
two years ago my wife and i had the
opportunity to attend the march for life
and as we walked down the street
thousands and thousands of people there
were many posters on the side of the
road this is my child
he's disabled she's disabled i'm very
glad i had him
on a personal note i had prostate cancer
four and a half years ago and i had to
undergo an invasive
ultrasound for the diagnosis
it was very uncomfortable i can
appreciate what a young woman would have
to go through for an ultrasound
a vaginal ultrasound
i'm sure it's very uncomfortable and
traumatic in the state of her
early pregnancy um
i would refer you each and every one of
you to the
writings of bernard nathan nathanson
he's uh he's deceased now
he was an abortionist he
said he did
around ten thousand abortions
and when uh
ultrasounds became available
he quit
when he saw the reaction
to the
fetus
to the probe but the uh
ultrasound attacking
on a personal note
before my wife and i were married
i was married once before
after six years my wife and i separated
we continued to date after the
separation
she became
pregnant she called me told me she was
going to she was pregnant she was going
to have an abortion
at that time i was not in health care i
did not appreciate
anything about life other than
where i was as a 20 26 year old
excuse me
individual going through a tough time in
my life
and my response to her was do you need
me to go with you
and she said no
she had the abortion
and to this day
i regret
not saying something different to her
i live with this every day
we have three healthy children three
beautiful grandchildren but i made a big
mistake
and i'm very very sorry about that and i
think
that as my wife pointed out
that when you
give the person the chance to understand
that it's a human life
that they will choose life
no i would say one more thing 95
statistics say 95 of all abortions are
done for birth control and not for any
other situation like rape incest
whatever
thank you for listening
and if i may add
one
addendum to that
his
former wife
shortly after we welcomed our third
child into the world
committed suicide and i truly believe
that
the devastation of what she had done in
taking another life
was definitely a factor in her ending
her own life
so these things
are not
without the their downside
thank you for your testimony both of you
the chair now calls upon valerie
prescott from concord
and you've asked for two minutes
thank you and thank you for letting me
speak
my name is valerie prescott i live in
concord and i oppose this bill
um i have a daughter that came to me
well actually i was going to visit her
so um
that's what it was i went to visit her
and she came to me
and just burst into tears and said mom i
had an abortion
she burst into tears
because she had an abortion
she felt terrible i had no
doubt in my mind it was regret over the
abortion
it wasn't until
about ten years later
um
i found out she had been raped because
and that's part of the reason why she
had an
[Music]
abortion but she regretted it
she regretted it and that's all i wanted
to say thank you thank you no questions
thank you so much
the final pink card
chair calls upon shannon mcginley
hello committee my name is shannon
mcginley and i live in bedford and i'm
speaking on behalf of myself this
morning this afternoon
i speak in opposition to hb 1609
i feel like that this bill is a death by
a thousand cuts
the sponsors seem to put language in
that completely blows up this law
and tries to distract us by invoking
emotion by putting in
other tangential carve outs and even
attempts to sweeten the pot by adding
something that they know
might
provoke support for the law amongst
those that support the fetal life
protection act
i'm going to go through some of those
points
the first thing is the ultrasound
requirement we've heard many times
before that this would make the law
completely unenforceable rendering the
law meaningless which i would argue is
worse than having nothing on the books
at all
i've been pregnant six times
i have never
the only time that i had a transvaginal
ultrasound was when i had a miscarriage
and when i was at the emergency room at
cmc during the miscarriage at 11 weeks
they did that ultrasound in order to
determine that whether i had expelled
everything
and for my you know
to prevent infection
and
i have a letter from a physician in ob
gyn at cmc that i'm going to email all
of you
where he talks about the use of a
transvaginal ultrasound versus an
abdominal ultrasound
and he talks about the it's dr damian
olson he's in the practice that i go to
and he talks about the use of the
transvaginal ultrasound being in
situations where there's a question
about the integrity of the cervix if
there's a compromise question of you
know that the cervix is compromised or a
placenta previa
um
and that transvaginal ultrasound is not
used later in the pregnancy around the
time of the 24 weeks that we're talking
about in our current law
i would also add representative john
graham earlier spoke about the
transvaginal ultrasound earlier on in
pregnancy that it was perhaps because
his wife was considered to be
[Music]
a
geriatric pregnancy i too was considered
to be a geriatric pregnancy with my last
pregnancy as i was 45 at the time and i
did not experience transvaginal
ultrasounds throughout that pregnancy
um the second thing is is that the the
bill does add this additional health
exception and doesn't define it and like
what's been mentioned here before this
morning i am concerned about that health
of the mother exception being
an open door for any abortion reason
whatsoever emotional familial um and and
for age
thirdly rape and incest exceptions
certainly this vote invokes a great deal
of emotion there is an exception for
rape and incest and law in this law by
virtue of it being 24 weeks why like
what's been said earlier in testimony
the mother has known for months that
she's pregnant and although there are
those very rare circumstances when um a
woman may not know that she is pregnant
we cannot have um we can't rule by law
by exceptions that's not a healthy way
we
we we don't generally rule by exceptions
in the law across the board
fourthly fetal anomaly um has been added
and there's there's no reason to kill an
innocent preborn child because the child
might die
i think that representative
leon made a very good point earlier
when she asked the question about
whether or not the child could just be
delivered prematurely if you if you have
a questionable situation where there's
perhaps even a risk to the mother's life
generally the physician the the
ob gyn would look at the situation say
i've got two patients here and i've got
to do whatever i can to to save them
both and if that means to go ahead and
deliver the child early earlier then
that's certainly
a preferable option
and then lastly
it talks about in the in the in this
particular bill about abortion
statistics and i just want to point out
that although that could be tempting
because certainly
pro-lifers in the state and others that
are not necessarily even pro-life have
been advocating and trying to pass
legislation to require abortion
statistics because we are one of only
three states in the country
that um does not collect that
information and i would think that it
would be difficult to make public policy
surrounding pregnancy and whatnot when
we don't know what those statistics are
in new hampshire but i would point out
that the language that's in this
particular law is not um the anywhere
near the kinds of abortion statistic
language that we're looking for because
the language represents that it's
optional there has been a lot of talk
about the fetal anomaly and i i wasn't
intending to to get into this in this
particular hearing
but it just seems like there's such a
focus on this idea that we need to be
able to have third trimester abortions
because of potential fetal anomalies
and
abort i would also just throw out that
doctors make mistakes and in that that
that fifth pregnancy or sixth pregnancy
that i had um
when i was 45 i received a prenatal
diagnosis from a local hospital here in
new hampshire that was not what any
mother wants to hear and it was
advocated by that attending physician at
the level 2 ultrasound again an
abdominal ultrasound even at that case
at 20 weeks i was probably about 19
weeks actually
that
that i choose to terminate because of
that diagnosis and although it wasn't
life-threatening it was going to involve
continual treatments
throughout their life and that also that
the child would have
would have
fetal or outward anomalies and just just
um can't you think what i'm looking for
but um
would not appear normal let's say
um and so my husband and i chose to get
a second opinion at boston children's
hospital where i underwent another
ultrasound down there and an mri and
several tests with a team of physicians
over the course an entire day we we went
through testing from eight in the
morning until five o'clock at night and
met at six o'clock that night with a
team and they said we believe that you
have a completely normal and healthy son
and we don't know why you received this
diagnosis from the hospital in new
hampshire
and so not knowing you know you got
which one are you going to believe you
don't really know obviously and i can
say that my little aiden was born at
catholic medical center in 2016 and was
totally healthy and had none of the
things that he had been diagnosed and i
often wonder if i had not been the
person that i am that questions
authority and gets a second opinion and
is passionate about life that my other
four sons would be deprived of an
adorable baby brother
would you take questions i would yes any
questions
representative folsom
thank you mr chair and thank you uh ms
mckinley
for taking my questions um
i i wish we had had a couple more
doctors here because i have a lot of
medical questions so you may or may not
be able to answer answer this
um
if a woman is raped which is just
horrendous and she's being seen
in the er or by a private physician
would she
in normal practice or is it usual for
her to be offered right there on the
spot
what would what was commonly referred to
as a morning after pill
based on i am not a physician but based
on my experience in dealing with these
life kinds of issues and certainly rape
and incest is a part of that discussion
it is it is my understanding that the
morning after pill is consistently
offered to sexual assault individuals
when they are in a clinical setting yes
thank you so much for your testimony
and with that i now close the hearing on
house bill 1609
was your hand up before the loud noise
and i now open the executive session on
house bill 1609 and the chair recognizes
representative folsom with that
aforementioned amendment to this bill
point of order
chairman point of order
who is asking upon the voter
representative
yes
why why when we are one hour behind
on our hearings
and this is not i know that it's noticed
that executive session may occur at any
time
but there are a lot of important
stakeholders who are not
maybe in the room because they didn't
expect an executive session on a
controversial bill to be done
immediately
and
people have not had a chance to prepare
amendments that they may wish to bring
forward
because we've just heard about the bill
today
you heard about this bill today well we
have heard the testimony which sometimes
drives us in terms of thinking how we
might craft an amendment
and the members of the public will not
be aware to be present
for
stating their comments or listening to
the executive session
why
are we moving to an executive session
particularly again when we are an hour
behind already
well the person who is the prime sponsor
of the 11 o'clock bill
me
chooses to wave it off
until and
this is
the right of the chair to do it and i'm
exercising that right
i disagree respectfully
thank you representative soloway uh
thank you mr chairman um and do i
understand
that a representative folsom has an
amendment which we haven't seen
previously we're trying to get it around
and that representative knurk
indicated that he will be submitting an
amendment is that correct sir
i have one amendment presented to me
i also have alerted several days before
the ranking member that i would be doing
this
and
what she has alerted her members to i do
not know
but as a courtesy it was not a necessity
but as a courtesy
i let the ranking member know several
days ago that i would be moving right
into an exact session
representative folsom do you have a
motion
thank you mr chair i have an emotion to
uh pass
amendment
i i move
to pass amendment uh to uh hb 1609 fn
the amendment number is 2022-0048
h
and we will give everyone
a good chance to read through this
several times
and then you can defend your amendment
and i'll second that if it needs a
second it does
thank you
at the same time you are reading this i
will pass around a letter
that
has come to us
as you know there are three equal
branches of government
and we being one of them and this letter
comes to us
from the governor
i hope we have enough if not let us know
and we will get
a copy made for you
they're coming around
they're all of which
of which
okay take a governor's letter and find a
photograph here and how many do we need
how many governor's letters it looks
like about
that
okay
and one over there does everyone have a
copy of the folsom amendment that's
well we're supposed to have had
20-something
i'm gonna make about four five
thank you
i think
are there more
i think we have the amendment
foreign
point of order who raised the point of
order i do who is i uh i'm sorry i know
i represent can never forget a forehead
all right
yes sir
uh
with the the democrats would actually
again because we've had no chance to
actually think about the democrats would
like to have a caucus since we've not
had a chance to have any conversation
about this um
amendment would that be appropriate uh i
don't know whether it's appropriate or
not but i think that's an appropriate
idea to me
so yes you may if you wish can we
probably we should try to limit to more
than maybe five minutes because we are
far far behind right now
well
take a reasonable amount of time
but i mean to let everybody know so we
get back in the room quickly
all right should we say be back by
1208.
it gives you about 10. that's only four
minutes but i'll take 12. no no no no it
doesn't
don't worry about it let's say 12 10.
all right
sure go ahead guys
mr
thank you
yes
he's over there
um
hmm
cheers
right
this
i am
how
but i think
foreign
challenged
reasons
yes
oh
[Music]
okay
mr chair we have returned thank you very
much
anybody who has not signed in
any representative who has not signed in
betty gay have you signed betty
betty gay
that way you get your mileage
we can prove it now
it is it has been moved by
representative folsom and seconded by
representative leon
amendment 2022-0048
h to house bill 1609 representative
folsom you may present your amendment
thank you chairman um is there a way to
it did lock on thank you good
um for those on the committee that might
not know
um i was the sponsor of the fetal
protection act so
this is near and dear to my heart
and this is something that my
constituents
have very near and dear to their hearts
and so i was thrilled with all the work
that went into the bill
so that i mean we ran it past judges and
lawyers and all of that and we thought
we had it down
but just like law in history has
happened it all started with
the ten commandments and do not murder
and then the judges got involved and
pretty soon there were
you know
well what if it's self-defense and what
if it's this and so the law just kept
getting more and more and more and more
complicated
and so we have to fine-tune our laws
more and more and more because
of what happened with this bill is a
perfect example
when i
put the bill out i got a lot of emails
mostly in support but you can imagine
that i got some that weren't all that
nice
what i found consistently
is that no one of those people ever
talked about
the rape situation the incest
or anything like that it was all
surrounding the ultrasound portion of
the bill
they thought
by reading it and we've heard today that
someone you know a legislator thought by
reading it it meant an ultrasound would
be required all through pregnancy which
was
not what was meant by the bill
um we also had people who uh assumed it
was
um
a transvaginal ultrasound that was
required
that was never intended in the bill
um and so all the the confusion
surrounded
the ultrasound
of all the the uh mail phone calls and
emails that i got on this that were not
happy
so my thought was let's
fix the misunderstanding
so that it's
clarified and that's what this amendment
does
it just clarifies it so there can be
no
wrong conclusions drawn that they have
to do the ultrasound before
every abortion
and that was the most important thing
that i felt and that they don't it's
just an abdominal
abortion done in that last trimester
and
so it just clears up that confusion over
what kind of ultrasound is done and when
it's done because that is what i heard
the most about
i'll allow questions to the sponsor and
i'd like to alternate um democrat and
republican uh until
one side is finished to having questions
and then we'll finish up with whatever
is left over so any questions from your
side for the sponsor representative
knurk
uh not so much a question so it doesn't
have to be a question
thank you i'd like to speak to the
amendment i think it is certainly an
improvement over the fetal life
protection act
but it doesn't go far enough and we did
hear testimony on both sides today
including from me
as to why the changes that are proposed
by the sponsor to
through bill 1609 are quite reasonable
in fact i again i wanted to go just a
little bit further
we also do see this letter from the
governor who is supporting this
and 1609 that is
and not
the amendment
you probably didn't see that but in any
case it is a supporting 1609
so given the fact that the amendment
does not go far enough
um i would vote i i personally will be
voting against this amendment
thank you
anyone from
this is remember a discussion as
the representative rightly reminded me
anyone on
republican side of the playground wish
to weigh in
again you may um thank you mr chairman i
didn't want to monopolize this
microphone um i think that this is a
very nice fine-tuning of what has just
been passed into law and and what took
enactment 18 days ago this makes clear
that the ultrasound's not required early
on and this
really at this point there's a reason
why 24 weeks is what people look at in
the western world at that point the
child has an over 50 chance of survival
assuming that they have a normal
development um you can never guarantee
survival even if you reach full time
either what this does is it makes it
clear that the ultrasound's required at
24 weeks the bill does not prohibit an
early delivery
so an early delivery is still a
possibility in the case of fetal
abnormalities and it can give those
moments of closure without another 16
weeks of gestation
so
so this is something that i think really
helps fine-tune it gets away from some
of the other problems and honestly some
of the questions the issues that were
raised about the rape and incest not
seeking care until that point um i think
that if we as a health and human
services committee think that simply
allowing them to abort after that that
point solves the problem we're missing
the bigger problem if there are girls
and women who are not getting care
earlier in case of rape and incest that
needs to be addressed entirely
separately and
and i think that the pregnancy part of
that should have should have very little
to do with her rights and the protection
that she needs so i believe that this
addresses the problems that that really
have been discussed about the fetal life
protection act and i think that this is
a very nice way to neatly sum things up
and then see the way that this law
evolves because
you know there's future legislatures as
well if if down the road people believe
there needs to be another change
thank you
representative merchant
thank you mr chairman
for my own
understanding the way i read this not
been on the house long as some of you
folks
this amendment fundamentally replaces
the underlying bill completely is that
correct
that is correct thank you sir
anyone else wish to add something say
something representative shapiro
off
okay hopefully that's on
i don't see a light it's
on now you're good
um
once again i i fully appreciate um
representative folsom's um
amendment um i think it does clarify
something that was
obviously intelligent people on both
sides had a disagreement of how it read
and um
that amendment fully clarifies
the part about an ultrasound
and i appreciate that but
i will vote against this because of what
the amendment doesn't include and i
think that
one of the things that i think is really
important
there's been a lot of talk about it
already but about
rape and incest and i think people are
underestimating the difficulty
of a young person who has been raped or
has been an incestuous relationship
people have been underestimating the
difficulties of what it takes to get
themselves out of that situation
and rise to the occasion where they can
really speak up for themselves
and
you know and in some cases that will
come after 24 weeks and um there is no
exception for that so i won't be voting
for this
amendment
thank you sir representative folsom
thank you um
representative shapiro
i've never told anybody this in public
okay
i do
understand what someone goes through
when they've been raped
and i have had to make some decisions
it's not easy
but that's the counseling i got was not
to abort or not abort a baby
the counseling that helped me
move forward in my life
was counseling surrounding the rape
and that's where i agree with
representative leon
that's if you are concerned about rape
and incest
that is where you need to put
your work into helping the women at that
point
with what what they're going through
thank you
representative kanark may i just respond
um
i feel saying is i can walk and chew gum
at the same time i think we can deal
with the problem of inadequate health
care
poor mental health care for women of
sexual who've been submitted to sexual
violence and still offer them the
protections of 1609
representative folsom
um
i think we all know there's several more
bills coming down the pike
and i think if people want to add some
other amendments to those we can
actually debate those issues
with those amendments at that time
and so that that is you know this isn't
the last chance to fix other things in
the bill
that we might want to add to something
later on
representative leon
thank you
one point that we don't want to miss is
that when a woman who's been in one of
those situations with rape or incest who
doesn't seek care until 24 weeks
we also need to appreciate the potential
mental health issues from having a
forced decision at that point so i agree
with representative folsom that should
be a larger separate discussion for one
of the other candidates coming down the
pipe later this simply addresses the
largest contention in the current law
and i think will give give a lot of
comfort to people who are in this
unfortunate situation
are we ready for the question
the question before us is the amendment
2022-0048h
[Music]
to house bill 1609 fn
moved by representative folsom
seconded by representative leon
would the clerk please
call the roll
representative leon
yes
representative mcmahon
representative acton
representative gay
representative cushman
yes representative folsom yes
representative kelsey yes representative
king
yes representative cofolt yes
representative delemus
yes
representative
i'm sorry um
i didn't
put the right names on here can you say
your name instead of
representative weber
okay
no
yes yeah
sorry about that
representative mccain
representative snow
representative knurk
no
representative soloway
i have not had time to consider i must
vote no
representative cannon no
representative query
no
representative shapiro
representative woods no
representative merchant no
representative pearson yes it's 11 to 12
to 10. the motion carries on the
amendment
the chair will now entertain a motion on
the bill as amended
representative leon um i thank you mr
chairman i would like to move out to
pass is amended with amendment uh
two zero two two
zero zero four eight h
moved the bill as amended second
representative cushman
we are allowed to have further
discussion i'm not sure we need it but
it's allowed if anyone wishes to say
anything
representative
unfortunately i will vote no even though
i do think this improves the fetal
protection act fetal life protection act
the
removal of all of the other good
improvements that
hb1609 would bring forward
forces me to vote no on the ought to
pass with amendment thank you
thank you doctor
anyone else
representative acton
thank you mr chair and thank you for
your time
i've been a um
kind of a libertarian on this issue for
many years
and um
i deeply believe in the woman's right to
discuss with their doctor and make
difficult decisions early on without
government intervention
i've also opposed the um
the extreme
parties on uh
my side of the aisle who want to ban and
criminalize abortion altogether
i find what we're working on here
um moving towards
a
common sense solution to a vexing
problem that we've been dealing with
for decades
the the bottom line is that
we're addressing the rights
of the baby and that's something that we
haven't done much of and that's always
been
what i've wondered about was when do we
when do we set the point where the baby
actually has rights someone actually
advocates for that that child and
you know my wife and i were married for
18 years before we had our first baby we
tried for years and never happened we
got married in 94 we had our first child
in 2011.
um so this is near and dear to my heart
we couldn't have a kid and suddenly we
have this this beautiful
uh miracle in our lives
and um
you know at the time i was i was my
career was flourishing my wife was busy
uh we could have made that decision to
terminate the pregnancy and and we
didn't but that was our decision to make
in that period i wouldn't want the
government to step in
um we're basically
we're moving in the right direction as
far as what i feel is coming to a common
sense solution
both sides are giving up
some core beliefs but that's what
politics is about is coming to
an agreement in
somewhere in the middle and figuring it
out so that i will be voting for this
and i do look forward to other
amendments down the road that which may
address some of the issues that are in
1609 that are being taken out from this
but i will be voting yes for this thank
you
representative snow
thank you mr chairman
i must say representative i do think
that
even though i voted against the
amendment i do think the amendment
clears up some things that were quite
troubling to me
but it doesn't address one of the issues
that's very troubling to me is somebody
that worked for 50 years in the
healthcare field and that is leaving in
the criminal and civil
penance yeah you know what i mean
and that that i am very concerned
because we're desperately trying to
recruit more healthcare professionals in
all fields to come to new hampshire
right now
in the mental health field but in all
the other fields too and i think this is
a disincentive
for people that want to set that up
and it'll really be a problem for people
that are in obstetrics and gynecology to
want to set up a practice here in new
hampshire so
if
if your amendment had included that i
would have felt much more comfortable
voting for it but
that's the only reason but i do
compliment you on your the thought and
reasoning that went into making this
improvement thank you
thank you representative
representative
mckay
you know one seems to be do it let me
just say very loud i agreed with
representative snow
i was very concerned that there was so
little
testimony on
the other side
i won't say our side but the other side
and
i
i was aware that the chairman was going
to bring this up but i think other
members were not and probably
part of the public was unaware of the
fact
that this was going to be dealt with
today
so that i think it was a
mistake to
not hear in depth
what we heard on the one side and not
the other so i'm going to vote
now representative merchant
thank you mr chair
i think the underlying
bill itself when it was first passed is
a fatal flaw in it
what i'm trying to get to is we talk
about the rights of a child we talk
about the rights of the parents and
rights of
the mother and the parents
what we don't talk about
as a society
by denying that choice for a mother when
you have a
child that has
fetal abdominality
what we don't talk about
we haven't talked about
is the fact that we
don't take the time or the resources
support that family financially
we talked about the financial burden
placed upon the parents
but at the same time don't talk about
how we support that burden
so therefore
even though
essence the law has some merits to it
it doesn't have the other side of the
coin it's how to support that family and
that child or their life
financially take away the burden
therefore because of that i will not
support the bill
thank you representative representative
shapiro
you know i want to say one thing
after representative
talked i thought
i really appreciated him talking about
the
the value of his love of having children
and i want to say that's something we
can probably agree with from both sides
here um
certainly having my two daughters
is the best thing that's happened to me
in my life
and having two grandchildren is um
close second maybe first actually
so i think we can all agree about that
wherever we come out on this particular
law
i think for me um
we just heard about a fatal flaw and i
look for the fatal flaw as the fact that
this
act originally was passed through the
budget process instead of getting the
kind of
hearing and work on it
that
we're trying to do right now
and
as the governor
articulated so well
he said he chose to sign this into law
because it was part of the budget but he
always thought we'd have the opportunity
to come back and fix things
and i'm just wondering
why we're choosing to fix one thing and
not fix the other things and
i think we're missing an opportunity
um
why not have
the proposed amendment that we already
passed with some of these other things
so because we're choosing all to fix
only one small piece and not the others
that i think are really important i'm
gonna vote no
i would repeat that
although i do not believe i'm required
to do so i did inform the democrat
ranking member
several days ago
that i would be executing this bill
right after the hearing
people could have found out
representative mckay did
and other amendments could have been
put together and brought forward they
were not
other people
could have come to testify i mean i like
like most committee chairs to alternate
one side and the other when i'm going
through the pink cards
that was not possible
so
there we are but
i have a very strong feeling and i think
you'll all agree that we haven't heard
the last of the question about abortion
here
anyone else
are we ready for the question
the question before us is
the bill
1609 as amended
by amendment 2022-048-h
with the clerk as moved by
representative leon and seconded by
representative cushman with the clerk
please call the roll
representative leon yes
representative mcmahon
representative acton yes representative
gay
representative cushman yes
representative folsom yes representative
kelsey yes representative king yes
representative cofoult yes
representative delemus yes
representative
i'm sorry walner no
representative mckay
representative snow no
representative
no
representative soloway no
representative cannon no
representative query
no
representative shapiro
representative woods no representative
merchant no
representative pearson yes 11 to 10.
it is 11 to 10 the bill
has passed
i'm going to make a scheduled change
we start at 1 o'clock
and we will start with 1327.
there's reasons for that
then we'll try to sneak in 1345
and then continue the schedule as
printed with my build 1045
at the end
we are adjourned now until one o'clock
so we're starting with 3 13 27
yeah right here
okay yeah i got it 13 27
okay
yeah there's another one we probably
could exactly i think everyone's going
to vote for but
oh
i have no
idea um
i'm
went ahead
well i
think yes
uh
it's not our persons that disagree it's
we disagree on how to get the best
so
yeah
is
you're saying you want it just in case
i have extrusions
let me get my wallet
give me a second
uh
ratios
okay
that's me tipping my
hands yeah
um
you're not going to present you're going
to testify
um
that's right
watch what others are doing yeah
you're all new to me thank you sir
okay we're all over the map on the
schedule here
i know 11 30 is going on a little bit
later
so
11 39
10 22. oh probably about 2 30. but who
knows
wow that made a mess even for me
even though i know we're gathering
everybody
why are all the
you don't have to get my permission to
go deeper
well i think i'm gonna
go one minute
i was not planning on saying what i said
but it just it came out and i think it
was the holy spirit just said
let me say this
so
we
[Music]
okay
here's a 10 22
11 39
11 39.
couple things
a couple things is this on
should be on
how about now
they said they weren't going to
your mic isn't lighting work nope mine's
not working either
i've got a couple of things i have to do
according to parliamentary procedure
i'm opening the hearing on house bill
and i am now postponing it till the end
of the schedule for the day
i open this hearing on house bill 1345
and move it to
[Music]
after 1327.
i now open the hearing on house bill
including diabetes in the conditions
listed for eligibility
for a service animal
and would the
sponsor please
present it to us thank you
representative short
thank you mr chairman
members of health and human services can
you hear me all right
it says that it's on
is that any better yes well maybe
i think if i put the mask back on it'll
be okay now can you hear me okay
all right thank you
uh for the record i am uh representative
diane schuett i represent merrimack 20
the towns of pembroke and chichester
and the first thing i would like to do
is
give a shout out to one of my
co-sponsors representative kathy rogers
who would be here to testify today but i
think you're all aware of her health
issues i think she's probably streaming
at home
so little shout out to kathy
and wishing her the best
thank you now
this bill is a pretty simple bill
it just asks to include diabetes as a
specific reason to use a service animal
new hampshire law defines service animal
as specifically dogs that are
individually trained to perform services
or tasks
you should each have a copy of the rsa
167d
colon one
and that definition is down under roman
numeral four
my constituent stacy patterson ghanian
who is here with her dog sawyer
asked me to file this bill because she
did encounter some difficulties
trying to bring her dog into the
workplace
she asked me to
introduce the bill in hopes that it
would help her and a lot of other people
who use these dogs for diabetes
she'll testify shortly and describe her
experiences
in addition to stacy
our own u.s senator jeanne shaheen's
granddaughter ellie and her mom
stephanie
are here to tell you about their
wonderful dog coach and how he helped
ellie learn to deal with diabetes
you may be familiar with the book
stephanie wrote about their journey
ellie and coach
and she has told me that she will
provide copies of the book for all
members of the committee who are
interested in reading it
i've also provided you with a partial
printout from the governor's council on
disabilities
taken from their frequently asked
questions
which explains the difference between
comfort animals and genuine service
animals
you'll note on that handout in section 3
it states one of the services performed
would be alerting to low blood sugar and
further down in section 7 it refers to
the kinds of service dogs
and notes assisting with diabetic
disabilities
and yet diabetes is not specified in our
statute
mr saya from the governor's council is
here to answer any questions you may
have about these articles
the next item i provided for you is for
eminem island cruises
that may seem kind of an oddity
but as you look at their mission
statement you will see that the owner
operator mr kevin morris
started these boat cruises with the idea
to use some of the proceeds to provide
service dogs for children with diabetes
this was done in memory of his daughter
mandy who has passed from diabetes
but whose last years of life were made
more livable by use of her service dog
mr morris could not make it today but i
have enclosed a letter he has written
about their experience
his contact to provide dogs is
guilford's golden guardians
and carla weston was going to come today
but she could not make it you also
should have a letter from her
providing some information about how
they provide the dogs and provide for
training
i understand that there's often a
concern that adding one more item
to lists of things that we authorize in
the rsas opens the floodgates for others
to be brought forward
however i think the crime determinant
language
that's listed in rsa 162-2
roman 2
just under our proposed edition
that quotes emotional support
well-being
comfort or companionship
would not allow more frivolous reasons
to be added
i would also say to those that question
that dogs have been found to be capable
of amazing sensibilities in recent years
even alerting to types of cancer
cardiac arrhythmias
i would hope that this committee would
be open to some of those possibilities
in the future
when that
particular
trait has been proven
but i also trust your wisdom to
determine the worth of any new proposals
i hope that you will agree that these
diabetes alert dogs do perform a
valuable service
and deserve to be recognized in statute
for their work
in closing i'll tell you that there are
approximately 97 000 diagnosed cases of
diabetes in new hampshire
and we feel that using an alert dog
would help many of them deal with their
disease more easily and accurately
and just one more very
unscientific reason
to use one of these dogs
we're all aware that one of the major
recommendations by health professionals
for diabetics is to get regular exercise
well you have to walk a dog a monitor
does not make those demands
thank you
would you take some questions i
certainly would if i can
anyone with a question for the
representative
represent representative woods
thank you mr chair and uh thank you
representative for taking my question
uh is there any sense of level
of
aberrant glucose levels that the dogs
can sense i mean
being a physician
ketoacidosis is one level
but most of the damage in physiologic
damage is done when it's just over
uh but not out of control
is there any
information about what level they're
able to sense i'm not sure that i have
the expertise to answer but we have
three people who use the dogs
plus one lady who provides dogs and i
think they can probably address that
question better
i think we should introduce our canine
guests
we have
of course coach
sawyer
saco as
if from maine
there was a question about whether they
should be allowed here um i asked
the powers that be if each could be
given a day pass
and i want to make sure that the water
bowls have been delivered and treats and
all that okay i mean good
any further questions for representative
schuett
seeing none chair recognizes
stephanie and is it ellie or l
ellie ellie
shaheen
wish my grandchildren were that
well-behaved
well thank you members of the committee
it's an honor to be before you today to
testify on behalf of this bill
special thanks to representative schuett
and representative rogers at home
for bringing this before you
as we've said this is coach and my
eldest daughter ellie ellie lives with
type 1 diabetes
and she's been living with this
diagnosis since she was just 8 years old
coach came to our family when she had
been
about 5 years in into progression of the
disease for those of you who don't know
type 1 diabetes and type 2 diabetes are
different
type 1 is an autoimmune disease it means
your body does not produce any insulin
so you have no ability to regulate high
and low blood sugars
for all of us who don't have the
challenge of living with diabetes our
pancreas does that work for us so as
you're thinking about digesting lunch
your pancreas is doing all that work for
you without any decision making at all
on your part unfortunately because ellie
has to live with
continuous dosing of insulin she's
making constant decisions about whether
she needs more sugar or more insulin or
more food and how to handle activity
and for a growing young person it's
quite a challenge to handle all of those
variables
coach is a medical alert dog he was
trained in a correctional facility in
kansas
and brought to our family through a
non-profit organization called cares
uh he's actually
been by the time we received him in our
family he was about 18 months old and he
had already had 2 000 hours of training
he had been on a plane five times before
we even met him
does he fly coach
yes
always
he can make himself very small you'd be
amazed
and in order for ellie and coach to be a
team a training team they actually went
through a week-long training together
and had to be certified through a public
access test process
so that
the trainers and the handlers could be
assured that she had the capacity to
manage him on her own
he's
joined our family when she was in eighth
grade he's seen her through high school
and college she just graduated college
and she'll she'll share her own words
about that experience but as her mother
what i can share with you is that
managing type 1 diabetes is a constant
chronic challenge
and
as you heard one of your fellow members
of the committee ask
you're constantly trying to achieve a
blood glucose range that's healthy and
in ellie's case it's somewhere between
no lower than a blood sugar of 70 and no
higher than about 150.
so coach is trained to alert when he can
detect her blood sugar levels dropping
below 70 or above 150. he alerts in a
bunch of different ways
he often will pot her lap if she were
in a class right now at school and
not feeling well high or low he would
stand up he would circle her chair or he
would pot her lap to get her attention
so she would test her blood sugar
he's done that for her now for
eight years
and
the difference has really been
extraordinary i mean i can tell you i
was i was very cynical about whether
these dogs could actually work
i'm a technical person i like to see
data i'm a business person
and
in the first week i was awoken in the
middle of the night with paws on my
chest
doesn't wake up with low blood sugars
which is another risk to her safety
and
i i felt the dog on my chest and i was
still a little disoriented he was still
new to our family and i thought
maybe he needs to go out or maybe he's
you know bothered by some noise he heard
in the house and sure enough you know i
went into her bedroom and
and her blood sugar was very low and i
didn't know it and she was sound asleep
and the dog was alerting us to that
reality um he really has
in terms of thinking about her safety
living independently in college she was
in a single dorm you can imagine with
kovid
the isolation that all students were
feeling and to have her be alone all the
time without that added support
really would just have been an
unbearable burden for her and and worry
for our family so
we're very much in favor of this bill
we believe that anyone who wants to
handle the responsibility of a dog and
have the added benefit of the support
these animals can provide to people who
are living with chronic disease should
should be able to access them
we've seen firsthand he's gone in
restaurants he's gone to movie theaters
he's gone on airplanes he's been in the
hospital with her when she's been in the
hospital for complications he lived with
her in her dorm room in college
and it's a seamless part of their
day-to-day life and he's provided the
added benefit and security of knowing
there's one other
person energy animal in the mix to help
support her
so with that i'll turn it over to you al
hi hello my name is ellie shaheen
um
i'll just say a few words after my mom
but um coach has been with me since i
was 13 years old he's been with me for
some of the most formative years of my
life through high school and through all
of college
and i know for me and for my mom he's
helped me navigate living on my own for
the first time and making sure that my
safety was
assured especially during the night time
like my mom said
when we first got him i know that my mom
couldn't
see a reality in which i could go to
college on my own because i didn't wake
up in the middle of the night
with a low blood sugar or a high blood
sugar alert um so
understanding that we could have coach
in my life and that he could alert me
if i were to live with somebody or not
and that i could be okay without my mom
or my other family members being there
has been a literal lifesaver more than
once
and just reiterating what my mom said
anyone who would want the responsibility
of living with a service dog should be
able to
access them in whatever capacity
would you take a question ellie
yes did you have a glucose monitor
before coach showed up yesterday
and contrast for us sure um
there's really no comparing contrast
between the dogs and the technology
there's no way to
um
tell if they're any different uh
i'm i'm not sure if i'm being very
eloquent with this apologies but um
that you're not using one over the other
necessarily um i know any other diabetic
that uses a dog is also using technology
alongside it
the dog is just an aide and a support
to help
you not just emotionally but also like i
said alerting
in the night time the technology is also
never a hundred percent right
um so the dog helps in in that capacity
as well
does the dog help you screen out
potential boyfriends yeah yeah
yes we actually have some pretty funny
stories about some field trips that he
got himself in the middle of her with
some other boys he's featured in many
you know many yearbooks i i the
technology question is one i just also
want to elaborate on because it comes up
all the time and when coach first
arrived the technology was more
rudimentary this you know was over eight
years ago and that she's now using
technology that's that's very different
that's
better more accurate more effective
that said you know it's really worth
reinforcing that for some people the
technology is not optimal it's it's a
lot of beeping it's you're attached
constantly she wears a continuous
glucose monitor and an insulin pump all
the time attached to her body 24 7. she
also has alarm fatigue because she's so
accustomed to hearing the alarms that
the alarms actually don't wake her up
so you know we actually have a as a
backup to coach and to her existing
alarms we have another series of alarms
that i can alert remotely if she's away
and has to have that happen so um you
know that
we would never say one over the other
it's a combination of of whatever
sources you can access to best support
you and keep you safe
any further questions
for mother and daughter
yes representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you both
for being here and answering questions i
actually was a medical device analyst
covering diabetes technology companies
since before your diagnosis
and i appreciate those challenges and
um i do understand that you're in that
area where it's a lot harder to manage
it with just technology but my question
is
seeing that you have both a pump and a
sensor are you able to move closer to
that integration because your dog will
let you know if that balance between the
pump and the sensor go awry
can you sorry can you trust your
technology more since you have you have
coach to back you up oh yeah yeah i mean
it's funny i've there been times when
all he's alerting this actually happened
two nights ago at dinner ellie would
normally uh be back in new york now
because she just graduated from college
but because of the omicron surge she's
taking a little more time closer to home
but she was home for dinner and
he was alerting
and her
phone wasn't alarming and
we have share capabilities so my phone
alarms also
backup
and
we said well he's alerting
oma my phone's not alarming but he's
alerting and then you look at at the
trend and the arrows headed up so he's
catching it as it's on its way up before
the technology necessarily registers it
um and i say
because she's seen so many evolutions of
different devices
before we got coach she tried a glucose
monitor and the technology was so tough
then that it was alarming her every
other minute in class and it was very
disruptive and distracting
it's gotten much much better now
but i think as you point out the
combination of the dog reinforcing the
messaging she's getting from the
technology is helpful and then also just
i mean this is a
personal note as her mother
before coach
i was all it was always about diabetes
and i was her nurse it was always you
know are you high are you low have you
tested did you take enough insulin for
that what what's your number
and it created friction and frustration
on her part you know there's so much
emphasis on the diabetes when coach
arrived it became about her relationship
to him
and so when he was alarming her or
alerting her
she wanted to reward him if he was right
and it was about him it wasn't about the
diabetes and i do think that's a
powerful part of this dynamic that has
made her the quality of her life better
because it's about her relationship to
him more so than it's about the diabetes
demanding that she do something or the
mom who's now feeling like the nurse
causing friction and frustration
any further questions
for mother daughter and dog sheen
seeing none stephanie when you back up
careful you have a dog right yes okay
thank you thank you very much for your
consideration we appreciate it
chair recognizes kurt ehrenberg from rye
from the humane society of the u.s in
support of the bill
thank you i'll be extremely brief i'm
kurt aronberg i'm the state director of
the humane society of the united states
and uh
i'm here to wholeheartedly endorse this
bill
we support it it's good for the animals
it's good for the people um
see no reason why anyone would oppose
this at this time
happy to take any questions no need
thank you thank you
caitlyn gagnol
or gagnon
who's your friend this is sacco
um
so full disclosure he is my service
animal i do not have type 1 diabetes
he's actually my ptsd service dog okay
um i just want to thank you guys for
letting us speak today um like i said i
don't require diabetic alert dog but i
do have a service animal
um so i understand how difficult it is
to be living you know with a medical
device a living medical device around
people that don't really you know
understand why they're necessary or what
exactly they can do
i am however the spouse of a type one
diabetic um who has a service dog
she's the reason i'm here today
she suffers from something called low
unawareness
this means she doesn't feel when her
blood sugar's dropping anymore
this can be dangerous it can cause her
to seize have permanent nerve damage
you know she can die if a low blood
sugar is left untreated
uh i've spent years watching her try to
mitigate this disease with insulin and
diet and you know in her glucose
monitors the problem is that technology
is imperfect
and it's often wrong or
too slow to react to her rapidly
dropping blood sugars
so one day her endocrinologist said it
was time to get a service dog and after
years of worrying about her glucose
levels dropping when she was alone it it
was a relief for us to discover that
there was a solution to this and that
being a diabetic alert dog
so she spent months researching trainers
and programs we interviewed with
trainers from all around new england she
met different dogs until we found the
right fit
and we were lucky enough to match
her with sawyer
mary from granite state service dogs
and since matching
her with sawyer we've extensively worked
on scent training and public access
training with him
and she's now able to go about her day
with the comfort of knowing that even if
she doesn't feel herself dropping or if
her technology doesn't catch it in time
sawyer's almost always able to notify
her before the situation gets dangerous
so we're asking that you guys add
diabetes to the state statute as an
additional protection for people like my
wife
i understand it's already covered by the
americans with disabilities act but
federal laws can be changed so the more
protections that we have to protect our
citizens rights that actually need these
dogs you know i i can't see that that's
going to be bad
additionally employers in the state are
not always aware of ada regulations it's
been very difficult for my wife to
actually have sawyer with her when when
she you know starts a new job
so the more protection information we
have the better it is for people in her
position you know she's often been told
well so-and-so has diabetes and they
don't have a service dog so you don't
need one either
and that's that's just not acceptable um
and not
really legal so the more information you
guys can get out you know the more
appreciative
um so i'm just asking that you
respectfully consider adding diabetes to
the service dog statute and thanks for
letting us come here and talk to you
guys about it but either you or sawyer
take a question
i mean i don't know that sacco can
answer it but i'm sorry yeah all right
yeah any question anybody mark twice if
you agree
um folsom i'm only asking you a question
because you have a corgi yeah um
sorry
um
my question real question sorry yes
thank you chairman thank you for taking
my question um are there enough service
dogs available that are trained
to fill the need um and the requests
from people coming in for a service dog
for diabetes so what i can tell you is
that we're actually in a training
program so
you know coach was trained for two years
before he made it to ella
and we actually are actively still in
the process of training sawyer we have
classes um as a group once a week for
people with various disabilities
training their dogs and then we also
have one-on-one time with our trainer um
and she breeds specifically um with
service work in mind so she you know
she's definitely and she has different
breeds of dogs available for people um
depending on their needs
so i think as long as you know you have
the means or you are capable of doing
the training yourself i know for a fact
i was not which is why we went through a
training program you know there's
there's definitely you know the
availability out there i think you know
with diabetic alert dogs especially it's
important that you you know you're
finding a dog that has the ability to
scent train saco does not care about
scent training not his jam
at all but sawyer took to it no problem
so it just really depends on what your
needs are and you know
looking in the right place like i said
we interviewed with several trainers in
the new england area before we found one
so
any other questions
representative woods
trying to do two things at once um uh
thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking my question i heard from the
previous speaker that the dog was more
sensitive
um in the sense that they could detect
it going up before the alarm went off
uh is have you found the same experience
that the dog is actually
keeps the glucose at a
out of the danger range better yes so
sawyer is trained for low blood sugars
um that's primarily the issue my wife
has um
so he definitely has been able to find
it
a lot faster than the technology
he just smells it sooner you know what i
mean it might the technology tests her
every five minutes and if she's dropping
rapidly before the next time it tests
her
she could go from you know 90 to 50 and
thank you yeah
thank you and the chairs uh called stacy
patterson gagnon and we've got
a written document coming around from
you
come here
let's go
sorry i just want to get them settled
first of all i just want to say good
afternoon and thank you so much for
letting us be today i'm not going to be
anywhere near as polished as jeans
um
thank you so much for coming now really
appreciate it um so my name as he
mentioned is stacy patterson gaddon i'm
a resident of pembroke new hampshire
uh about eight years ago i wasn't
feeling too well my vision was blurry i
was constantly fatigued always thirsty
good friend of mine was like maybe have
diabetes and i'm like yeah no
um she tested my blood sugar and my
blood sugar was 370.
for those of us who don't know what that
means it's supposed to be between 80 and
120.
that was my um
introduction to the world of diabetes
i was diagnosed at 37 years old
um
i can't imagine being diagnosed at eight
you're my hero i don't know how you did
it
um
the thing with type one and it was it is
type one it's not type two or anything
like that is it's a really misunderstood
disease
so it's kind of different for everybody
who experience it
by that i mean
elle and i can eat a cupcake we're not
gonna dose the same amount of insulin
and we're gonna have different results
but it sounds good doesn't it
um about three years ago i was at my
endocrinologist's office and i was
telling him you know that i really
couldn't stay
sorry is very curious about
coach he kind of just wants to play with
him
um but i was at my endo's office and i
was letting him know i said you know i'm
just i'm dropping just like this
and at the time i was still what's
called honeymooning so i was just kind
of up and down
i'm at a very long honeymoon it wasn't
anywhere near as enjoyable as a regular
honeymoon just wanted to put that out
there
um but
while most of people think diabetes you
think you know high blood sugar you're
constantly treating with insulin for
that
also very curious about coach
um
we also have to treat for lows and the
lows can be very very dangerous because
they can happen very very quickly
um
i do wear a cgm
um and i do wear an insulin pump
just like um alex said we wear two
totally different systems
um the good thing about technology is
yes it's grown and it's wonderful and it
has gotten so much better since my first
cgm
but there's a lot of moving parts to
these things there's sensors there's
transmitters
the pump itself has about three
different parts
this technology can stop working
altogether
or one piece can be off throwing the
entire system off
i guess that's
the biggest thing for me because i was
like oh cgm like continuous glucose
monitor i won't need a dog
it turns out you know if you don't know
you're dropping and the cgm is not
working you put yourself in a very very
precarious position
so
i mean luckily i have good insurance and
i can you know go on this this system
and the cgm and it's wonderful not a lot
of people get that opportunity
but
there are currently four different kinds
of cgms two only work really well
um
so the whole system that i have is
basically like a working pancreas like
it will if i'm dropping it will stop
insulin if i'm going high
it will administer just a little bit of
insulin to keep me kind of even
what i wanted to do in getting sawyer
and you know finally matching up with
him and we had gone through
like my wife had said we had interviewed
different trainers we interviewed
different programs things like that um
is
not only did i want a dog to work but i
wanted to work the dog i wanted to make
sure that if something had happened
you know i i didn't want just you know
like i don't really know what to do
so we found you know granite state
service dogs and mary finn layson has
been amazing
she's a very hands-on approach we have a
very hands-on approach started with a
lot of public access
and then we go to scent training
and he's got about an 85
accuracy rate when i'm dropping
he's supposed to spin
he does not
um
as any trainer will tell you sometimes
you teach him one thing but they do
another um so he actually just gets up
and pushes me
very very easy to know exactly what he's
talking about
so he's very very good at that
so once i had had him to the point where
scent training was was going really well
i went to my employer at the time and i
said i really like to bring my service
dog to work and she said a flat no
and i asked why and she said
it's they're not allowed here
to which case
i did get a whole bunch of pieces of
information and email her and let her
know that that was the case
so she was a little upset that i had
pushed that on her so she asked for a
letter from my doctor a letter from my
trainer an intestinal parasite test
for those of you who don't know what
that is if a
person came into where i was working and
tried to eat whatever came out of him
that that would be why that test was
administered don't know what
um videos and pictures of sawyer
training
and full disclosure of my entire health
history
yes i know
i know right yeah so it took me by
surprise as they could ask for all of
that
so there's really no procedure there's
there just isn't
i didn't like that i brought him to work
and everything was fine but there was
just a lot of
you know we found dog hair in the
bathroom and i'm like it's gonna happen
he's a service dog
so they just kind of started to kind of
grind me down i decided to leave went to
another practice ran into the same
situation
where they told me to disclose my entire
health history
to just have my service dog at work
so i run into this a lot
i do work part time in an animal
hospital they have no problem
they didn't ask for anything they were
like bring them in
let's do this
um having type 1 so late in life
is
it's first of all it's incredibly hard
to manage both physically and mentally
you know you have um
the type one people and then you have
the type one parents
i cannot imagine
having to wake up at twelve
two
four
and six to test your child to make sure
that their blood sugar is okay
steph i don't know how you do it i don't
know how you do it at all
but
you know type one and we i mentioned
type one and i've mentioned it many
times in this testimony because it's not
just diabetes people think diabetes
right they think it's a punchline
that's not type 1 definitely not it's an
autoimmune disease
my body is attacking itself this is why
this happened
so
you know that's just something that you
can't control it's something that you
can't
really manage and you can do the same
thing the exact same way every day and
you're going to get different results
so just
there's something to be said about
explaining it but there's something even
more about experiencing it we just deal
with a lot of
myth and stuff like that
so
to add it to this to the state that
would be wonderful at least we get some
recognition and say hey you know what
this is important
and that's going to hopefully encourage
other type ones to maybe look into
getting service dogs or maybe feel a
little bit more protected
because i know it would make me feel
that way
thank you so much for your testimony
we're going to need to move on now and
the chair calls mary finley
okay
my name is mary finlayson i own a
finlayson's pet care and granite state
service dogs obviously i support
adding
diabetes to
this
bill um
i met stacy oh i think it was
close to almost two years ago
when she was looking for some type of
service dog for her diabetes now
i had been doing service dogs for quite
some time i
had not done a diabetic service dog at
that point but i wanted to you just have
to have the client to start with
and um i work with corgis i also work
with english setters
and
i've recently started with some labs
and you know they had come to me and
we did some meetings and sat down with
some of the different dogs that i had
and talked about you know what they were
looking for and of course stacy her lows
are her most important um
uh her her biggest risk is her lows um
and we had talked for a while we we had
a good relationship with each other we
felt very comfortable
they got to meet some of the dogs at
that time
sawyer was
just coming up on six months a little
over six months
and
i knew that sawyer had a very strong
nose there was lots of things that led
to that in my observations with him um i
felt that
um
he would be
definitely a good candidate for
um
you know this project of doing a
diabetic alert dog um and
uh
they took a liking to him as well and
they said yeah well you know stacy says
yeah
i really like sawyer so we started the
process of um training him
for her disability um we did mouth swabs
when she had homework you got to do your
mouth swabs when your sugar's low and
and um
and she had to start doing that and it
had to be when she hadn't eaten for at
least a half an hour and we were
freezing the swabs and then we were
training the dog to detect that and um
you know
rather it was it was amazing because
very quickly he did pick up on it and it
was within months that they were telling
me he's waking me up at night they had
stories of like
wow i i didn't i didn't hear any alarms
you know i was fast asleep and he jumped
on me and he woke me up and
and he said ma
something's going on i can smell that
smell and um it was fantastic i was
really impressed how quickly um he did
pick up on that and then going forward
um
you know we did a lot of public access
testing and we do a lot of stuff out in
public to make sure the dogs are well
behaved um they're holding their
commands they're um you know polite in
public and um as they say you know
sometimes invisible um
and
you know as we're going along and the
dog is ready now it's time to okay let's
add the dog into your your work space
because it's not just night it's daytime
that she also needs this dog and
there were some difficulties there and i
have helped other clients with dogs
going into workplaces um
and had to write letters and of course i
was really shocked with how some of the
employers handled the request and all
the questions they had to ask me and
drilling me like who was i and
um you know does she really have a
disability or why can't she you know
you know just have the dog at home why
does she have to have it at work and
um yadia and as said previously
people will say well so-and-so has
diabetes well i have diabetes i have
type 2 diabetes but i don't necessarily
feel at this time in my life i need a
dog um
there are people with type 1 diabetes i
think they really do need a dog so i
think there are
people who
who may have a need for a dog
more than others and stacy is definitely
one of them and um
so anyhow
you know trying to to get the dog
into the workplace was quite difficult i
had like i said lots of questions stacey
had lots of questions and i had told
them i said you know
i
this is stuff that you shouldn't really
be asking you know um
you know the way i was training and all
of that i said she could technically
train the dog herself
but she has chosen to go through a
trainer but you know i felt if it made
them happier so we could get the dog in
i'll give them what they need
but it was a lengthy process in long
phone calls and lots of emails sometimes
um just to explain stuff and they would
always go back to their insurance
companies needed this
this is what their insurance that's what
they all say but anyways um
and the two workplaces stacy did have
the dog in i supported her fully you
know if there's any issues first getting
the dog into the workplace just let me
know because we can work on stuff if
there's little things is he settling you
know because he's got to spend a whole
day with her um kind of hanging out it's
not play time it's just hanging out and
relaxing and being with with mom
and um
i also
another thing i had to work with
or educate a little bit the employers
who said okay well she can bring the dog
but it's got to be in a room by itself
and she so she can be out front and i
said well what's the purpose of having
the dog if it's going to be in a back
room locked up
and it has no access to her and they
didn't get that they were like oh well
she wants to bring her dog so keep it in
the back room i said no the dog has to
have access to her but anyhow so neither
place did the dog ever have an issue
neither employer ever contacted me and
said we have an issue
with this service dog or the dog is
barking or the dog is misbehaved or
there's an issue
the dog was always fine
but it's been lacy and we're going to
have to wrap this up because we're way
behind schedule and
no problem
that's it thank you you're welcome
finally
from chuck saya the executive director
of the governor's
commission on disability welcome
and mr chairman honorable members of uh
this committee my name is chuck sayer
for the record last name spelling is s
like sam a i a and i am the executive
director of the governor's commission on
disability
at the request of representative diane
schuett i did have the opportunity to
speak to the representative last week
and look at the bill before you
at the end of the day when you look at
the amer the governor's commission on
disability we're governed by obviously
state law
and the americans with disabilities act
so we
serve as a source of information and
referral um among other things when it
deals with the um ada
according to the americans with
disabilities act and
state law is consistent with that a
service animal is a dog so that's number
one service animals are only dogs and
they're specifically trained to perform
a task for an individual with a
disability all of the testimony you've
heard before me
squarely
supplements that and speaks to the dogs
in this room these are based upon what
we've heard these are all service dogs
because they are essentially they are
performing a task
that is directly related uh to a
person's disability having said that
when we look at the ada and we look at
state law as enunciated in rsa 167
um 167d the proposal before this
honorable committee is consistent with
state law and is consistent with the ada
and quite honestly from a
just a basic life perspective it'll make
life a lot easier for individuals
when we look at the amount of calls that
come into the governor's commission on
disability
the vast majority of calls at the end of
any month
circle around service animals
uh what is a service animal what is an
emotional support animal what's a
therapy animal is a therapy animal a um
a service animal um and unfortunately i
don't believe i'm telling this is
nothing new
there are a lot of abuses
in the system and that is not
just new hampshire it truly is a
national concern when i sit in on
national calls when i sit on calls
with my new england counterparts
service animals is a is a big issue and
many people obviously um have to you
know handle those questions so they
direct them to the governor's commission
on disability but the individuals here
today have have
said it squarely and poignantly
this will make life easier for
individuals who have diabetes because
the dog is performing a task it's
alerting the individual that there's
something occurring um with a blood
level um change so with that um we have
a very robust website um the honorable
representative um shut referenced it we
have
much literature on there many brochures
we perform many presentations to both
private and public sector individuals
who are dealing with the issues with
service animals so with that this uh
proposal and this bill would be a good
thing for the community so thank you how
do you take questions absolutely any
questions
saying none thank you okay thank you mr
chair and thank you members
and this concludes the hearing on bill
1327 i wish to thank our guests
human and canine
i'm hoping the next level of training
will be if the dog has a question put a
paw up and
a gesture in a certain way
thank you
i'm looking forward to seeing
a dog coming in to testify
thank you
yeah
now we open the hearing as
was previously announced on bill
1345 originally scheduled for this
morning at 11 30 relative to the release
of a teenager's medical records to a
parent or guardian
and thank you representative cofoult for
pinch hitting i think betty must have
set the record today of bills in which
she was prime sponsor
one here and six in another committee
[Music]
thank you mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee as as noted by
the chairman i am presenting this bill
on behalf of representative gay who is
the primary sponsor i know we're behind
schedule so i will try to move along
quickly
um rsa 463 section one
recognizes the vital role that parents
play in in raising their children and
looking after the interest of their
children
specifically it says the interests of a
minor are generally best promoted in the
minor zone home
section 12 of that statute acknowledges
the roles and responsibilities of a
parent or guardian
which includes giving any necessary
consent or approval to enable the minor
to receive medical or other professional
care council treatment or service
having said that there is some ambiguity
as to the rights of parents to access
their children's medical records
rsa
141c18 makes an explicit exception in
the case of minor children 14 years of
age or older who are seeking medical
attention for the diagnosis or treatment
of sexually transmitted diseases
as the bill is currently drafted
that would not change
uh this bill furthermore allows for
exceptions in cases where a health care
provider has
reason to believe in their professional
judgment that the child has been
subjected to domestic violence abuse or
neglect
or if the release of those records could
potentially endanger the child
so as it stands today
numerous healthcare providers including
major hospitals in new hampshire have
established a cutoff at 14 years
and i
i'm aware of several uh parents who were
quite surprised to receive a letter from
a health care provider stating that if
they wanted continued access to their
child's health care records after the
age of 14
that they would need to get the child's
permission to do that
um
in light of the current language in the
rsa that recognizes the important role
of of parents including the
the responsibility for giving consent to
medical procedures it seems somewhat odd
that the same parent called upon to give
that incent
must do so potentially without access to
the very medical records that would
inform that decision
so i hope i have done justice to
representative gay's bill in this
process i'll do my best to answer any
questions that members of the committee
may have
any questions for representative kofol
pinshooting for representative gay
representative shapiro thank you mr
chairman
i'm not sure that you'll be able to
answer if this is not your bill but
i'll answer and maybe there's someone
else that coming after you then
so
[Music]
first question is
um
in crafting this bill has any thought
been
given to
consideration for exempting
substance use disorder treatment which
under current rsa is um
someone can consent to at age 12.
so i can't answer as to the thought
process in in formulating this i will
say that
hipaa
hipaa generally
creates some some governing structure
that that sits over top state statute
and hipaa tends to defer to
state law
um however there are certain exceptions
to that and one exception would be that
if the minor is allowed by state law to
give consent
what and whether or not they have asked
for
their parent to be
representing them as a medical
representative
if they have not explicitly asked the
parent to be a medical representative in
that case
i believe those are the circumstances in
which hippa would regard those records
to be confidential records excluded from
being shared with the parent
i think i think this
follow up
i think this is also alluded to in
federal law
um
the right to consent to treatment for
substance use disorder treatment so i
will i will pass that on to the sponsor
of the bill correct i mean i i have a
document which i can share with the
committee um that that has a a table of
those
those categories of treatment for which
a minor
may consent to
medical treatment or may consent with
limitations so for emergency situations
for example emergency treatment a minor
may consent but there are some
limitations to that for others having to
do with stds and and
mental health and some other issues
there are
broader um allowances for minors to give
consent without the participation of a
parent
further
further follow-up yes
so this is it really a different
question
um
in section roman numeral two
where it talks about another exception
being
that the health care provider reasonably
believes in his or her
professional judgment
and then it goes on to
create another exception
you know in my experience working in my
career as a mental health clinician this
issue
of parents seeing a
minor's record would not come up
unless there was some kind of
contentious issue and
so given
that i'm wondering if this is um clear
enough
that the health care provider reasonably
believes i'm i'm wondering how that will
actually
what's the criteria for deciding that
and once again i realize it's not your
bill but i i wonder if that could be
clarified i think that's that's good
feedback and i would encourage you to
share it with representative gay
um i will comment that in my research
for uh presenting this bill i did come
across a case in which a seven in new
hampshire in which a 17 year old
um
his father was
seeking his mental health records uh
because there was a contentious divorce
going on and he wanted to understand
what the son had been saying about
the the wife in this case
um
in that case the court upheld the
privacy of his medical records and
denied the father the the access to
those records
nevertheless i i think that
what you bring up is is a very good
point and
um again i would encourage you to offer
that feedback to representative gay as
well i
any further questions
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman
uh thank you for taking my question
representative cofoul uh would you agree
or would you believe that a parent
would
seek access
to their children's medical record
not only when there's a contentious
issue but also
to be an active participant in their
child's health and well-being
um
yes and what's what's quite surprising
is the
this the default position that many
healthcare providers and healthcare
organizations in the state seem to have
taken
is that
age 14
is sort of the blanket cut off at which
records should no longer be accessible
to parents by default in other words
they're not managing that as an
exception they're managing it as the
rule
and i think that's what this bill is
primarily intended to address
um
you know i i know that there are also
some differences as to how
medical records are handled under ferpa
versus under hipaa so if medical care
takes place in the context of a school
it is not protected by hipaa and many of
the hipaa rules don't apply so it can
get to be a very complex issue
i think the concern is that the the law
new hampshire law is is currently
quite ambiguous with respect to
access to medical records by parents and
i think that that is probably a
disservice to
many of the medical organizations who
have to grapple with this issue and find
their own way
and i think it's certainly a disservice
to parents who are taking an active
interest in their in their children's
well-being
seeing no further questions thank you so
much thank you the chair recognizes
shannon mcginley to speak in favor of
the bill
hello committee my name is shannon
mcginley and i am
the executive director volunteer
executive director of cornerstone action
here in new hampshire i live in bedford
and i am in support of this bill um
because i interestingly when i heard
about the bill i had a personal story
with it and i'll i'm gonna email you all
this letter that i received back
actually in 2012 from
elliott hospital physicians network
notifying me it was my pediatrician's
office notifying me that
i would no longer have access to my
children's records with the exception of
a couple things like immunization
records and i was obviously very upset
by receiving this letter and a number of
my friends were also in the same
practice and we were like what you know
what is this all about and it does make
reference in the letter um that the um
that these restrictions are being put in
place by the elliott health system um
widely wide policy which has been set in
accordance with new hampshire state law
and um and it has on there a chart that
you might find interesting and you know
i realize that this is from 2012 this
letter but you know there could have
been some modifications to how this law
is being interpreted but it has a chart
on the second page of the letter where
it lays out what my what i will have
access to versus what my child will have
access to in their or online portal
and i have to tell you so some of you
know that i have five sons and it's
comical to me to think in this letter
talks about 12 to 18 year olds that my
12 13 14 15 even 16 and 17 year old
would be able to navigate this online
portal with their healthcare information
and that i would be blocked out from
that and um
so i just i think that we need to
reevaluate this new hampshire state law
that is blocking parents out from them
having access to what i believe to be
critical information in order to
determine what's best for their health
care i'm happy to take any questions i
have a question does this sound like to
you yet
another example
of
the man
wanting to run our kids and not the
parents
well i definitely feel that over the
years i have children five to 25 i feel
like there's been a continual erosion of
my rights as a parent in their lives and
that i feel sometimes like a traffic cop
standing at a five-way intersection you
know trying to
trying to protect them because i feel
like that it's just a constant attack um
you know on our family's privacy and our
decisions of what we feel is best for
our family and my follow-up is and yet
you still are responsible for them
financially yes that is correct and
there was a great example of that most
recently um with one of my sons that you
know something happened
and i didn't know anything about it
until i got the bill
and um
and so i was like
do you want to talk about this what is
this all about
you know and i just i just i find there
to be such an unbelievable disconnect
with the way our system works yes
they you know in a number of different
scenarios they could be having side
effects from medication or a procedure
perhaps that they underwent and they
could be upstairs in their bedroom or
their bathroom
bleeding or dealing with whatever side
effect may come from it and i have no
idea what's going on
any further questions for the rep for
here for um
ms mcginley
yes please representative merchant
thank you mr chairman
a question about the um access to the
medical record of the child
was that something the child requested
or is that something the medical center
or the physicians practice automatically
put into place
the practice automatically put in place
per new hampshire state law if i want to
be able to get access to those other
records then my child has to give
permission which in my situation is not
an issue to be able to talk to my child
to get my 12 year old to give me
permission to their medical records
follow
up want to be clear i understand this
name is more towards the
fault whether it's prime sponsor but
when you're looking for the
record access
the child does not have to
opt in or opt opt-out of providing
access is automatically granted to the
child
it's otherwise the child is not saying i
don't want my parents to have access to
the record the facilities automatically
making that judgment call yes that's
correct i think i'm tracking with you
i'm kind of having a difficult time
understanding sorry about that i just
want to be sure that i understand it
correctly that it wasn't the child who
requested the medical record access to
be blocked it was being done because of
interpretation of the law that is
correct yes
any further questions yes representative
shapiro
just
thank you mr chairman just a quick
question uh
what age was your child when you got
that letter from the pediatrician's
office was that at age 12 or 14 or
well i have multiple children i have
five so i don't know if you want me to
go through the list probably not but um
it it i mean i'd have to do the math of
like what each one of them were because
at that time i had five in that practice
that were mine i guess i'm just
wondering at what age um what currently
do you lose
well well this letter said 12.
and and i i'm gonna take a picture of
this and or scan it and send it to you
all so you can see it yeah
thank you thank you for your testimony
the chair recognizes paula minihan from
the new hampshire host new hampshire
hospital association and you have
received her written testimony it was
just passed out
good afternoon
mr chairman members of the committee for
your for the record my name is paula
minihan senior vice president state
government relations for the new
hampshire hospital association
representing all our community hospitals
as well as our specialty hospitals we
have concerns with house bill
1345 relative to the release of
teenagers medical records to a parent or
guardian we do not believe that this
bill is necessary as
hipaa as previously stated already
covers when a minor's medical records
can be released in addition we believe
house bill 1345 as drafted is missing a
critical component of what is available
or allowable i should say under hipaa
the critical component that is missing
is called confidential communications we
know that adolescent health care
providers rely heavily on the provision
to have important conversations with
their adolescent parent patients excuse
me that may be stifled if not permitted
there is an agreement between the
provider the patient and the personal
representative that the conversation
will remain between the provider and the
adolescent parent patient
which the provider documents in the
chart and it is then noted in the
patient's
electronic medical record that it cannot
be shared
i attached an faq from the um in the
back of my testimony on the um from the
us hhs website describing how hipaa
manages access to miners medical records
this is how all health care providers in
new hampshire currently manage these
situations in support of a minor the
parents guardians and the health care
provider
in addition this bill only refers to one
section of new hampshire law pertaining
to sexually transmitted disease
treatments for adolescents
aged 14 or older there are other
statutes that afford minors as young as
12 years of age the ability to consent
to treatments without the knowledge or
consent of a parent or guardian
therefore this bill is only limited in
scope and would create more uncertainty
for when and how minors can consent
to release of medical records for these
reasons we are not supportive of this
bill um and we i thank you for allowing
me to make my comments would you take
questions yes questions
thank you uh chairman pearson and thank
you for taking my question um do you
ever have situations where
um the child is seeking a test or
treatment for something especially if
they're going to be given a drug of any
kind
and they didn't have the wherewithal to
remember all the medications they
currently are taking
and
have possible side effects from other
issues
i am not a health information management
director but we consulted our hymns
directors um in in crafting this
testimony they um provided us and i can
submit it to the
committee a chart of when um what what
laws they do follow um relative to when
they provide information um and allowed
to provide information um so i will
forward that along
so i can't specifically answer your
question sorry representative but i will
follow up with you
any additional questions
representative leon thank you mr
chairman and thank you for taking the
question my question comes to these
confidential communications are those
simply confidential to the parent or are
those also
also confidential to anybody else
inquiring about the child's medical
record
it indicates in the medical record that
it cannot be shared and that was my last
um
the last statement in that paragraph so
it cannot be shared
sorry and follow up with anybody not
just the parent
i
would presume but i can find out from
the from the
from the experts i will ask thank you
seeing no further questions thank you
thank you this ends the hearing on house
bill
1345 before we start the next one in
about a minute
a few announcements that have come out
of the meeting this morning of the
committee chairs
and i realize not everybody is is here
so take notes for those who aren't
our next house session
will be sometime during the week of
february 15th
at a location to be determined
someday during that week
don't ask
early bills those are bills that have to
go to a second committee
usually if there's a fiscal note but not
always
early bills now the deadline is thursday
february 10th at noon
which means committees with either a lot
of bills
or controversial bills that the hearings
of which may last quite a while
or both
are really going to have to push it
i know that many bills will come out of
here now 11 to 10 such is the nature of
things but whenever possible
if we can put it on consent in other
words if somebody was well i'm not too
sure i like it and you make it 20 to 1.
i understand that you certainly have the
right to do so but the more bills we get
on consent
the more we will be able to get our work
done by the deadlines that we have in
front of us again don't ask
substitutes can participate in the
debate and in the vote
but they cannot make a motion or write a
report i think we all know that we need
to be reminded that some time
although our present policy is still no
zoom meetings
for committee hearings
you can always
text someone who is in the room to ask a
question
representative canuck and i have some
stories about how we worked around that
last time
if we have an open spot in the schedule
that is to say as
the ranking member told me from her many
years of experience you are convinced
a bill will take a half an hour in a
hearing
and it's done in 12 minutes
or two hours it's not always easy to to
guess
but if we have some open spots coming up
i'd like to fill them with exec sessions
unless you want to come back yet an
extra day in the week
so therefore those of us from this
session today and from the last time
times we've met
where we say oh i think i want to bring
an amendment in that's a pretty good
bill but i'd like to bring an amendment
in please work on those as quickly as
you can
because if
every bill that
is pending has an amendment we're
waiting for
then we're going to burn that
free time
before the next bill is advertised so
get on it if you would if i would please
and
again a reminder that the replacement
policy
is four o'clock the night before if you
plan on
coming down with something do it before
4 pm the night before not the morning
thereof
i asked that was the answer
if one of us tests
positive for covid call the speaker's
office
we want to balance
the rights of everyone to know what went
on with the rights of privacy of the
individual and that's what they're
asking to do
okay
that's it
now we are trying to return
sir what yes
on the bill we just heard 1345 uh the uh
member from the hospital association
indicated a handout there was a handout
i haven't seen it
did everyone get a handout from
okay guys when when the group goes
around we've got to have the remainder
come back for those who didn't so uh
we got a stack here
oh that's gonna take a few minutes
oh
gosh see our office is way down the
corner it used to be easy when we were
outside our own office
everybody got a
paula minahan handout
okay
these are extras coming back
today
a card for this bill coming up from that
side okay
okay open the hearing on house bill 1139
relative to
ophthalmic i had a practice
prescription requirements representative
villier if you would present your bill
please
oh okay these are more
thank you okay thank you
hello everyone uh thank you mr chairman
and members of the committee uh for the
record my name is dan bailey i represent
hillsboro 22 which is amherst
i'm here to introduce hb 1139 which is a
bill that involves consumer empowerment
free market competition access to
medical devices and standard of care it
recognizes the reality of living in an
increasingly digital world
where consumers can
shop and retailers can compete on an
even playing field
i just want to start off saying that
our medical professionals including
optometrists
are part of a noble profession having
said that
my wife is a physician so i completely
understand that
and appreciate that there's a business
aspect to every medical practice
what we want to be cautious of
however is letting the business interest
become a detriment to the best interest
of the patient interfering with the
standard of care for example by unfairly
unnecessarily restricting competition
for corrective devices like eyeglasses
and contact lenses
it's understandable
that when a business model is under
threat that there would be efforts to
retain that business model
and protect
the
interest of the of the practice
um
before the committee before the hearing
i submitted a write-up in support of the
bill
not going to go over every point because
it would take way too long
but essentially this bill is about
encouraging competition in the retail
eyeglass industry while protecting the
standard of care for patients it simply
fixes a legal anachronism when the laws
that
state
the parameters required on prescriptions
were passed the internet was not yet a
thing
it could be reasonably assumed that most
dispensaries would be in person and
there would be somebody there to
fit and adjust glasses
correct devices as such
this legislation
uh corrects specifically the absence of
the pupillary distance from
prescriptions
um pupillary distance is simply the
distance between
your pupils
and there are usually three measurements
one is the full distance between the two
the two eyes
and then the measure from the center
line to each eye individually
it's usually taken by
a device
in your optometrist office or optician
by called the pupilometer
it's a little more accurate than
using
a ruler but it eventually serves the
same purpose
this measurement helps
place the focal point of the glasses on
the right point of the eye so you get
maximum benefit from from the corrective
lenses
um i think most of us in this room
probably are in the same club
either we've been wearing corrective
lenses for a long time or at some point
as we've gotten older usually our arms
stop being long enough to
see the fine print
in most cases we've all found it
necessary to at least explore
corrective lenses sometimes it meant
going to our
eye care provider and getting a
prescription to
take care of whatever our problem was or
sometimes it just a trip down to the
corner drug store to get a a pair of
readers
if you've
shopped
the
offerings at your optometrist office you
probably found that the frames are
really expensive uh experiences some
serious sticker shock
if you're wondering why they're so
expensive it's because according to
a website called ecpu which is eye care
provider university who offer advice and
do research on behalf of icare providers
it's it has to do with the business side
of
an optometry
practice
practices that specialize in higher end
frames and high performance lenses tend
to be far more profitable so there's
very little incentive to
offer generic brands or you know glasses
like you can get at that
rite aid for 25
the more
in fact up to 90 maybe even more i think
that's probably a conservative estimate
optometrists
sell eyeglasses within their office and
it can account for 50 or more of their
income
um
one of the things one of the other
things they do is they limit the number
of offerings a number of styles
um and brands
and they try to do things that are uh
offer things that aren't not necessarily
offered online or in other retailers
so they specialize and try to capture
our business and it's understandable to
do that i think it's acceptable in most
cases
um
but if you know there are less expensive
options online and maybe styles that
might suit your taste and
and face shape better you may want to
explore the options of going online but
when you try to order
you realize you don't have the pupillary
distance
which as as i already explained it's a
measurement that they're going to need
when they make your glasses
in new hampshire if you're an adult and
you've had your eyes measured before you
probably don't have to have them
measured again
and
rsa 332-1 colon 1 already requires that
all medical information contained in the
medical records in the possession of any
health care provider
shall be deemed to be the property of a
patient the patient shall be entitled to
a copy of such records upon request
the definition of a health care provider
includes an optometrist pharmacist
podiatrist mental health professional et
cetera et cetera
any officer employee or agent or such
provider acting in course of scope and
employment or agency to or supportive of
health care services
if you consider that an optometrist and
an optician are usually separate
professions in separate occupied parts
of the building
the optician obviously works on behalf
of the optometrist and would be included
in this definition of healthcare
professionals so if they've measured
europe pd before
you should have access to it according
to the law
if they're being denied you've been
denied this information
then they're in violation of the law
for children it's really important that
their pdb
measured regularly because it will
change considerably as they grow
up until at least age 18.
however if the pd is included on the
prescription the fdc already requires
under the spectacle prescription release
rule that the prescription
be given to the patient whether or not
they ask for it
i know from personal experience that
this does not always happen um
that
the ftc decided to pass this rule
because patients were having trouble
getting copies of their prescriptions so
they could shop around
for better prices and better styles
um
so it really troubled me when a
constituent contacted me about a problem
they had trying to get their son's pd
um
i don't know if they were violating the
state law or if they give out an
existing pd or the optometrist or
optician we're just
refusing to do it for whatever whatever
their their personal reasons were i
don't understand
but um
it seems like uh
the main
reason to to withhold it would be to
just as a protectionist
practice to try to keep the business
within house
it shouldn't be any any more
problematic to give the pd than it is to
provide the other parameters like
refractive power access cylinder and
prism which are all required by law to
be on the prescription
i know
when
when i had to buy glasses for my
four-year-old daughter
my wife and i discussed what we were
going to do because the cheapest glasses
we could find in our optometry office
was
300 to 350 and that didn't include the
lenses
so
so we decided you know well we don't
know anything about glasses we don't
know if they're going to be you know we
heard about zenni optical which was just
starting out at the time this was about
10 years ago
so we we said well let's get
a primary pair from from the optometry
office and then we'll go to zenni and
we'll get some backups because we know
there's margin of error kids always wear
you know they break glasses and they
have to wear an old pair that was an old
prescription it's not going to hurt them
if they have to go a few days or
whatever and so my daughter got to play
on the playground with with these
glasses and and for the most part they
were good quality they lasted um she
beat the heck out of them and and you
know they kept on ticking
so
um
we were very supportive of it but when i
went online to buy them i realized i
didn't have the pd
but i was
you know aware enough to read the
directions and i had a ruler and you
know trying to get a four-year-old to
sit still long enough to measure it you
know and i got something i hope was
reasonable
um
so
it just
when i started hearing about
you know optometrists and opticians
refusing to to give out the
the pd it just didn't make sense because
you know one of the arguments is that oh
it's going to be um
it's the optician's job
well the optician in 90 of the cases or
more works for the optometrist so why
can't the optician measure it just like
a nurse would measure the blood pressure
you know if the optometrist isn't
comfortable measuring it you know
it doesn't matter who measures it the
law
is written in such a way that anybody
any trained optician can can revise that
particular parameter not the others but
that one um and then i started thinking
um
about
things like uh the safety risk you know
you know one of our concerns when we got
our daughter's glasses was
when we're going to hurt our eyes and
that's just not the case and in most
cases like i said there's there's quite
a
a range of of limit before it even
becomes uncomfortable let alone doing
damage in fact um
the province of british columbia and
canada has completely deregulated
eyeglass
prescriptions you don't need a
prescription you don't even need a prior
exam
they've they've
they did that in 2010 and it was
predicted that there would be a lot of
pushback later on because there'll be
all kinds of eye damage and problems and
people would really want the law put
back the way it was and that hasn't
happened
um but i do want to put in a little
disclaimer that you know here
having said that
you know british columbia is deregulated
i want to make sure that everybody
understands that it's important to see
your eye care professional they can
recognize diseases and other problems
that may not have to do with the eyes
that are affecting your vision uh way
ahead of time and it's important if
you're having vision problems to go
ahead and
see an eye care professional
that we don't want to take away or
diminish the value of that service
but if a patient wants to
you know obviously
i
think it it goes with that argument that
a real optician a licensed professional
is going to fit the glasses properly
they're going to they're going to fit
right on your face they're going to look
right they can be comfortable they're
not going to slide down your nose
but if if a patient wants to forego that
part of the process and they're willing
to put up with a little margin of error
that's really a consumer choice
it should matter to no more to the
physician or i mean the ikf professional
whether it's an optician or an
ophthalmologist
where a patient gets their glasses
any more than it matters where what
pharmacy a patient uses to fill their
their medical prescription or whether
they choose a brand name drug or a
generic
um
in the 10 years since my daughter got
her first set of glasses online a lot of
other companies have cropped up and they
do offer
pretty hefty and respectable warranty
policies and satisfaction
policies that allow you to return the
glasses and maybe even try on several
pairs ahead of time
it also has to do with
not only our
eyewear retailers
pressuring patients to
stay in-house but also
there's i don't know anybody's heard of
the company called luxottica
they own about 40 of the nation's
retailers including lens crafters and
pearl vision and target vision
and they control about 40 of the actual
retail market
and in addition they also are the top
manufacturer of almost every
designer brand of glasses made so
whether you go to your own optician or
to a third party chances are unless
you're chopping from like zeni or warby
or any of the others that have their own
proprietary designs and they make their
own you're buying from lux auto and
they're they're propping up the prices
as well they're they're a very big
worldwide monopoly
one of the things that i want to make
sure is
that this is about deregulation this is
giving the consumer the choice to to go
off uh it's not the full kind of
deregulation like british columbia but
it gives customers a little more of a
choice
um give them a little more freedom by
putting this on the on the prescription
there are other parameters that could go
on a prescription as well if you have
bifocals if you have trifocals
yeah there are probably other things but
this is this is a pretty benign
measurement and it's not going to do any
damage to you or
your children if it's off by a little
bit
you know even even your optometrist and
optician
they're going to make mistakes too
one of the arguments that i've heard is
that online companies make a large
number of errors but what they don't do
is compare it to the number of errors
that actually
happen with in-person services as well
we're all they're all human and they all
make mistakes whether it's the optician
the optometrist or the technician who
actually builds your glasses they all
make mistakes and
you know maybe the errors are higher on
online but
that's the consumer's choice
representative i'm going to ask you to
bring it to a close we've got some other
people who are going to testify okay um
i do have a quick statement warby parker
their government affairs rep wanted to
be here today but he has coveted and
decided not to come
uh if i can i'll read a quick statement
from him i know he submitted
written testimony as well it says warrie
parker an online brick and mortar
glasses retailer supports house bill
1139 because it tries to strike the
right balance between empowering
patients to have choices in where they
purchase glasses while ensuring the
opticians
in retail stores can still make
adjustments to interpupillary distance
as necessary to best serve the patients
the balance makes
for good public policy and warby parker
requests a favorable report from the
committee
i also have an amendment that corrects a
typographical area there were a couple
of commas that were omitted that make a
difference in the
handout you wish to send around i don't
i i submitted the the written testimony
online okay that's cool and it was
supposed to be part of the packet i was
told thank you
thank you any questions for the
representative
all right thank you so much thank you
the chair recognizes dr perak parikh and
again apologies if i've got the name
pronounced wrong
hello my name is barack parikh i'm a
community ophthalmologist in nashua
and i also proudly serve as the
president of the new hampshire society
of eye physicians and surgeons thank you
mr chairman and the remainder of the
community committee for uh listening to
what i hope will be concise as i know
we're running a bit behind schedule but
i i wanted to
um
i completely agree with the
uh motivation for this bill to allow for
free market and to allow for competition
in the retail eyewear space
the concern that i have is that it will
be at the detriment of patient care i
strongly believe and the reason for that
is because
the pupillary distance is not a
measurement that we take as eye care
providers at the time a glass of script
is written
because it is not sufficient to
translate into a satisfactory pair of
glasses for most patients and by
including that measurement on there it
would imply that all you need is the
power of the glasses and the pupillary
distance and you should be fine
it is not as if we take this measurement
and we withhold it from the patient
because we want the patient to
have their glasses purchased from a
specific place it is simply because
there's more to a satisfactory pair of
glasses than just the distance between
the pupils
the the way frames sit on the face they
might be a little bit higher and folks
with a prominent nasal bridge like
myself they might be lower and folks
with a more eloquent shaped nose than me
they might come a little lower and the
where the pupils are vertically is very
important all of our ears are in
slightly different places so the tilt of
the lenses is important the distance
from the surface of the eye to the lens
is also important and the pupillary
distance does not account for these
subtleties
by
having just the pupillary distance used
to fit glasses to a patient's face it is
cutting a lot of corners and i agree
that if patients want to
accept that small amount of error that
representative value mentioned that is
that is okay but the problem is if it is
on the prescription even with the most
perfect
pupillary distance measurement the
patient is at a high likelihood of
disliking their glasses and immediately
assuming that the prescription is
incorrect
and
as healthcare providers whether we're
eye providers ophthalmologists
optometrists whatever we are
our goal is to constantly try to improve
patient care improve patient outcomes
result in uh delivering better patient
care and i think that this would
unfortunately be a step in the wrong
direction
thank you
i'd like to ask a question my
eye care professional is in
massachusetts
and he has an office right next to his
that sells
glasses and he owns that facility and so
i asked him one day
obviously it is an advantage for me to
take about five steps over there to get
my glasses
but if i chose to go to a company
elsewhere in town
and the person
service serving me
had a question
to make sure that it was done exactly
right
just as his person five steps away would
ask
would that be okay
and he said yes it would i would answer
their questions from another store just
as i would from the one i own
i have heard that some people have not
been given such a gracious answer as my
guy gave to me
and
this is trying to become a question um
how would you respond to that
yeah you know i can only speak
personally rather than the specific
circumstances but we have patients all
the time you know where i write a
prescription and they're dissatisfied
with their glasses and they typically
what happens is they call the office and
the first thing that we do is they
confirm that the script written makes
sense based on the medical chart that's
available and if that's the case we have
the patient come in for a no-charge
visit regardless of where they got
received the glasses
and it's a no-charge visit and we make
sure the script that was written matches
up with what's in the lenses and then we
check for these other things you know if
the center of the lens is where we
expect it to be if the tilt is properly
accounting for the patient's astigmatism
and all these kind of optical things
that is going to bore you to death but
we we do do a good job of making sure
that the script that was written matches
the lenses perfectly i i can just say
that you know we are
we're community ophthalmologists we're
in the business of making sure our
patients are happy you know the business
model was mentioned but the worst
business model you can have is uh first
time you meet a patient to upset them
and they never come back
um you know so we're not really in the
business of having patients be upset
with the care that they've received and
we're the boots on the ground we're
proud to be there for our patients thank
you any
anyone else have a question for the
doctor
thank you sir thank you
the next the chair recognizes julie
smiley from amherst
hi firstly i want to thank all of you
for your service um and i also
especially want to thank our
representative danveyu
for considering his constituents and uh
sponsoring this bill and i'll try and
keep this short and sweet i know things
are running late so
um i do implore you to vote in favor of
this bill vision is one of our five
senses and vital to optimal functioning
for adults and children
making glasses more affordable will
support well-being for new hampshire's
residents
i've been reliant on glasses since i was
11 years old
as i've aged my vision has deteriorated
and consequently glasses have become
more and more expensive
the last pair of glasses i brought at
the eye doctors cost me over 600
and those were not designer frames they
were simply um regular frames
with progressive lenses that would allow
me to now see both near and far
um the average low end cost for glasses
at the optometrist is about 350 dollars
online services offer glasses for as
little as fifty dollars
however access to your pupillary
distance or pd is necessary to place an
online order and that measurement is
very very difficult to obtain here in
new hampshire
i wanted to share my experience to help
you understand how important passing
this bill is
for the constituents and the consumers
i need glasses 100 of the time
so after purchasing the 600
pair of progressive lenses from my
optometrist i decided i needed to update
my prescription sunglasses so i could
see in the sun
and having successfully purchased many
pairs of glasses online and received
this prescription and gotten glasses
that work fine i decided to go the
online route for my sunglasses it was
then i realized my pd was missing from
my prescription i contacted my eye
doctor who simply refused to include my
pd on that prescription and i'd recently
moved from a state with a pd disclosure
law so they were required to give you
your pupillary distance with your
eyeglass prescription
and
i had never had a problem ordering
glasses online
rarely spending more than a hundred
dollars versus a three to four hundred
dollar cost at my opticians
it now felt like i was being held
hostage and coerced into buying
overpriced glasses from my optometrist
it meant i'd need to pay need to pay for
another eye exam now not covered by
insurance take the risk of measuring my
own pd or use the measurement that was
now a few few years old i decided to
order my sunglasses online using the pd
i'd received a few years before
those glasses fit me just fine and cost
me over just about a hundred dollars
versus the
and fifty dollars i was quoted for the
same glasses at the eye doctor
um
i would have felt far more comfortable
using the pd the optician clearly had
just taken to fit my new progressive
black glasses
yet refused to disclose
again i wear purchased online can cost
as little as fifty dollars
i've been wearing glasses i've ordered
online for years never had a problem
with vision or fit and frankly given the
savings i'm more than willing to take
the very small risk
that they may be slightly inaccurate and
i can order multiple pairs online at
still far less cost than just one pair
of glasses from the optometrist
while it is possible it's not easy to
find an eye doctor willing to share that
measure the pd measurement in new
hampshire
one i did find had me sign a waiver that
i would not hold them responsible for
the fit of the glasses if i purchase
them elsewhere that felt perfectly
acceptable to me
and as a housing advocate in nashua i
work with people on low income it is my
experience that many people simply
cannot afford to pay the inflated
inflated prices of glasses through their
opticians
that they and or their children often go
without the proper eyewear because they
don't believe they have another option
than spending the hundreds of dollars of
glasses at their eye doctor
and that cost is particularly prohibited
for children's glasses which are more
frequently lost or broken
we already sell reading glasses without
any prescription at all and studies have
shown that people can tolerate a minimal
imbalance in their eyewear with no
discomfort
this bill will help make vision more
affordable and more accessible to new
hampshire adults and children and as a
state that values individual freedoms
and minimal government involvement i
think our citizens deserve the freedom
of choice on where to purchase their
eyewear and at what cost
again i implore you to pass this bill
and i just wanted to add that i
understand the rep from warby parker was
unable to be here today because of covid
and i do hope his written testimony will
be given the credence that it deserves
so thank you for your time thank you so
much
sorry
no questions
i don't see any
chair recognizes dr deirdre cullen from
belmont new hampshire representing
new hampshire optometric association hi
i'm actually um
a doctor at concord eye center okay
right now to change your pink card right
down the street oh sure
ahead so um so thank you mr chairman and
members of the committee um thank you
for your service to our state and the
citizens of new hampshire and i thank
you for your time to speak with us today
um like i said i'm dr deidre cullen and
i'm here to just share my perspective in
opposition to this bill
uh my optometric colleagues and i
understand the position of this bill's
prime sponsor representative veyu and we
do support a free market competition and
the freedom of all patients to purchase
their eyeglasses wherever they choose
however mandating the inclusion of a
pupillary distance measurement on every
eyeglass prescription thus shifting a
responsibility from the ophthalmic
dispenser to the prescriber is
ultimately a degradation of the existing
ophthalmic dispensing statute
doing such would do a disservice to the
patient that is reducing the quality of
care
additionally it is an added burden to
the prescriber prescribing provider and
an attempt to reduce or eliminate the
valuable role of the ophthalmic
dispenser and when we talk about quality
of care what i'm really concerned about
is the kids that are getting glasses
i've had several patients bring their
child's prescription in that they
got online and it's not just the
pupillary distance that i'm concerned
about but the actual prescription was
made wrong i had one patient whose right
eye was made in their left eye and their
left eye prescription was made in the
right eye and if you're a child you
might not be able to say something's
wrong they might just think that's the
way the world's supposed to look and
that really concerns me
prescription eyeglasses are a custom
made medical device not simply a retail
product i get shopping online i'm 36 my
generation has been shopping online
since our early 20s so i get it and i
get a free market but this is not the
next nike shoe this is eyeglass
prescription and this is something that
people need to be able to see clearly
with and operate
vehicles with um and navigate their
world and learn in school
an optometrist or ophthalmologist
determines the essential aspects of an
eyeglass prescription the eyeglasses are
fit fabricated delivered and adjusted to
the patient through an ophthalmic
dispenser and they play a critical role
in the ultimate visual outcome for the
patient
while many online vendors have entered
the market in the sale and fabrication
of prescription eyewear most of them are
not providing complete ophthalmic
dispensing services particularly in
regard to the fitting measuring and
adjusting of glasses and instead they
are just shifting that responsibility to
other parties or eliminating that
component altogether
as you will note in roman numeral one of
the existing statute 327-8
one
the definition of ophthalmic dispensing
specifically includes the taking of
measurements to determine the size shape
and specifications of the spectacle
lenses frames or lens forms best suited
to the wearer's needs
many optometrists and ophthalmologists
do not routinely measure pupillary
distance as part of an eye examination
however if the pupillary distance has
been measured at the time during the eye
examination then it is part of the
medical record and it is property of the
patient and it is the prescriber's
responsibility to release that
information and i understand that that
should be the way that it is the bill
sponsor appears to believe that the
prescribing optometrist or
ophthalmologist is intentionally
omitting or withholding information
however in the vast majority of cases it
is simply that the measurement has just
not been done because it's not part of a
medical exam
if there are cases where the information
is available and being withheld it
should be brought to the attention of
the state board not addressed with a
legislative change that would have a far
greater impact
when asked during an examination for a
public distance if it has not yet been
done some providers are comfortable with
performing the measurement themselves as
as i've done myself for from time to
time for patients that say look if you
give that to me or not i'm going to go
online get my glasses i'll say okay let
me just get this measurement if you know
i'd rather you have the measurement than
not
however many optometrists and
ophthalmologists prefer that these
measurements be taken by the ophthalmic
dispenser
that will be fitting and manufacturing
the lenses not because the prescriber
does not know how to do it or because
they are trying to preserve an eyeglass
sail
but simply because the trained and
registered ophthalmic dispenser does a
better job of it because it is
literally their job
their training is focused specifically
on the fitting and measuring of glasses
they often have equipment that is far
more accurate than what a doctor might
use in his exam room to measure
pupillary distance and they take a wide
variety of important measurements
including optical centers the vertical
positioning of the prescription in the
frame
the segment height the specific the
specification of where distance and near
prescription should be located in a
multi-focal or a progressive lens
the vertex distance the distance between
the glasses and the surface of the eyes
and more
ophthalmic dispensing is not
insignificant the state of new hampshire
requires that all ophthalmic dispensers
be registered with the state and they
are required to complete annual
continuing education
if a patient chooses to obtain glasses
via an online or virtual authoric
dispenser then they are accepting the
virtual dispensing process with both its
benefits and its limitations
the online retailer is able to reduce
their prices because they are cutting
out portions of the ophthalmic
dispensing and saving on the cost of
employed trained professionals
i'm going to skip a little bit through
because i know you have this testimony
and i just want to save a little bit of
time for everybody we agree that every
patient should walk out of their exam
with their eyeglass prescription without
having to request it which is already
federally mandated by the ftc eyeglass
rule
and that the patient should be free of
any feeling of pressure or intimidation
to purchase glasses from their
prescriber however we also firmly
believe in the value
and the role of the ophthalmic dispenser
requiring every optometrist and every
ophthalmologist to add the measurement
and documentation of pupillary distance
to every eye examination every
prescription is an unnecessary burden on
eye care providers costing time money
resources
however more importantly is that
this bill
proposes to reduce the role of
ophthalmic dispensing and thus reduces a
valuable service to patients that
results in lower quality of patient care
i thank you for your time and for your
consideration in this matter and i hope
that you will join me in my optometric
and ophthalmologic colleagues throughout
the state of new hampshire in the
opposition of house bill 1139
thank you so much does any
representative have a question for the
doctor representative representative
merchant
thank you chair and thank you for taking
my question
you spoke to the registration of a
optician
you spoke to the training how long was
the training process for an optician
um
that's a question that i don't know the
answer to
um
i don't know if
um i don't know the answer to that
question i
i don't want to guess anything um but
they have to be certified in the state
of new hampshire that's all i can tell
you
follow-up
thank you mr chair and also thank you
for the follow-up
in regards to the
optician
is there any reason why the optician
would not be required to give the pd to
patients so requested before they left
the office
um
i think that's up to right now business
to business and
um and i think that some
opticians will do that um just based on
where they work and others will not do
that
another one
what i heard before is 90 of the
opticians offices are owned by the
optometrist or the ophthalmologist
so therefore if the
optician wants the correct pd because it
seems to be concerned about that
why not have the patient go to the
optician which is owned by the office to
get the pd that's what i that's what i
do
when a patient um
will ask for it um and we know that
they're gonna go you know somewhere else
or you know maybe online but we have to
just educate them we really don't want
you to do that but i will send them out
to the opticians and i will have them do
that it just takes extra time
for the opticians
representative cushman
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question
would you believe that i was a patient
at concord eye center and i had asked
for my prescription
four years ago and
was handed a prescription that had
missing information on it and i had to
call and go back and i had to
pretty pretty much fight to get the
information that i needed to order
lenses online
so the information that you were missing
was a
pd
i can't recall since it was four years
ago um but there were no additional
measurements that needed to be taken
someone was just withholding it and
wrote it down when i came and gave me
the rest of the information
um i
can't speak to that case specifically um
but
i do know that you have to have a recent
exam within two years to get your
prescription
and was it within two years that you
were asking for the prescription
yes ma'am it was that day i asked for
the prescription after my exam and then
walked out with an incomplete
prescription
um so i i mean i don't know what
happened in that situation um i don't
think
i was the doctor situation
um but you know the only thing that we
don't include is the pupillary distance
at this point but all of the other
numbers should be there so i'm not sure
what happened in that specific situation
i'm sorry
any further question yes yes hello
representative delemus welcome to the
best committee in the house
microphone please
no additional charge for that
welcome
push it in any order and when you get
louder that's what you do
can you hear me now much better okay
thank you
i had the same experience with an
ophthalmologist's office in somersworth
new hampshire
and
i had had my exam
i had researched the
silhouettes that i wanted
and
i didn't have the pupillary distance i
went back to my ophthalmologist and i
called them like that the next day
and said i don't have my pd
and they refused to give it to me they
weren't going to measure it i just had
my eyes exam examined
and fortunately i had a personal friend
who was in the dispensing questions
please
would you believe okay that that person
said that
that person actually just as a friend
had done the pd for me and that was how
i was able to get my glasses but i have
a
400 savings
from what it would have cost me in a in
an office as opposed to going online
would you believe that
um yes
i would believe that
but again i would just say that my
concern is when prescriptions are not
made correctly and especially when it's
a child
um so you know you might be able to tell
that your prescription wasn't made
correctly if it wasn't made correctly
but a child might not be able to
verbalize that
um
and you know just in general
prescriptions not being made correctly
because there's not as many checks and
balances with online companies as there
are with you know brick and mortar um
shop um so my concern is really just for
you know the safety of patients um so
thank you any further questions
representative mckay
i don't think is this working
wonderfully good thank you
would you believe that i also
am a patient of concrete eye center
in fact about two weeks ago
and that every single time and i go once
a year
i always get a prescription
and i've always been extremely happy and
it's only
recently that
they
have a
somebody in that office
that deals with adjustments for the
glasses
so contrary to some others on the
committee i've had an excellent
relationship with that particular office
for years okay thank you
anyone else
thank you doctor thank you
and uh did you turn in your testimony to
the clerk
he did she did he said yeah okay good
thank you
um the chair recognizes julie smith
thank you committee
i was actually here to speak about the
uh hearing after this
but but no now
i'm glad i walked in on this one because
i am a former optician i was licensed to
massachusetts
from about 1994 until i let my license
expire
approximately two thousand
um i started off working at lens
crafters learning how to make glasses um
and then learning all the parts of the
business
and i also knew what the markup was
so i see this bill requiring the pd on
an eyeglass prescription as about um
consumer choice and in the free market
um
i was young
i didn't i was plano at the time and
i knew someday i would need glasses to
read and i knew that i would go
drugstore glasses because i knew what
the markup was it
was typically about three times what the
um
the dispensary
is paying in their businesses expenses
and so these online businesses such as
any uh or even
another brick-and-mortar business that's
discount
they're being edged out by a doctor
that's refusing to give a pd you know if
someone can't if you had your own
business and someone came in and let's
say they broke their glasses at
at the bridge and they weren't there
and they wanted to
call in an order
you know without the pd
it it it's a roadblock to commerce you
know you've got a a new customer and
they should not be forced to have to
spend money on on an eye exam
or do business with that particular
doctor who owns the
dispensary uh just because of that and
what it what it's doing when you see
like zeni they'll give you the ruler
with the little notch on it and that's
all fine if you're like plus one
but stephen king
you know that wouldn't work for him um
obviously he has has has the money to
pay top dollar but a regular consumer
let's say they're minus 10 or whatnot
if they make a mistake taking their pd
they get unwanted prism they're going to
either see double have headache um and
what about a progressive lens where
progressive lens wear usually has a
monocular pd
and i'm sure many people in this room
wear a progressive lens and i'm sure are
not on their first pair of progressive
lens
so
i'm sure many people in this room are
familiar with you know problems as a
first time where the seg height the the
pd and you know sometimes monocular or
let's say if you um had a nose injury
earlier in life
and and you have a monocular pd
so if you've got people that have to
resort to do it yourself on the pd
that that that creates error and which
which
leads to customer dissatisfaction and
now you're dealing with you know
pursuing a refund or having to uh
replace it
so i i definitely support this bill i
could go on and on and on and i'd be
glad to take questions
seeing none thank you and see you in the
next hearing
and the last card i have and is from
representative rosemary wrong now
yeah and on her uh way up there has been
uh handouts from her an amendment she's
going to be proposing does everyone have
one
representative wrong hills 21 it says on
the top no
no okay we only have like a
handful of them
they i thought they gave like oh thank
you
um they may have
uh upstairs they they said they gave me
23.
okay there's but there's also another
amendment uh representative value
alluded to an amendment to correct some
punctuation error is that right original
possession of that yeah it's his
amendment is being passed now
and if you don't have enough of of my
amendment which is uh zero one three
three okay we're not going to execute
today um
but we just want to make sure everybody
has it so when they go home think about
it also there was a handout chopped off
on oh yes i'll explain from the federal
trade commission does people have
something that looks like this okay
okay
well thank you very much uh for your
time uh committee um i suggest you hold
off for a minute because we're trying to
get the paperwork sorted out and i don't
want anybody to miss what you have to do
okay thank you
plus we're all having to catch up
okay let's take a few minutes and make
sure the right number is one per person
um
yeah that's mine
would you like an amendment
oh i don't have a billiard i'll swap you
a rung for a billion
no okay
you see i'm about the only liberal arts
guy on this committee and i just sit
here in awe of all these people are
scientific and technical and logistic
and sequential and everything else and
it really does me great to watch this
breakdown like this
we're almost there
oh wonderful wow you are so good i think
i'll keep
and now back to our program oh thank you
very much mr chairman and thank you uh
committee for hearing my testimony today
for the record my name is rosemarie rung
and i'm a representative for
hillsborough 21 which encompasses the
town of merrimack
last fall after the lsr filing period
had lapsed a constituent raised a
complaint to me about filling a contact
lens prescription
i searched through the hundreds of lsr
titles and lucky me i found one that was
germane to his concern
representative value's bill on
ophthalmic prescription requirements
so i come to you today with an amendment
to hb 1139
to strengthen consumer opportunities for
not just eyeglass wears but also for
contact lens wearers as well
as background per rsa 327 colon 25a
roman numeral five contact lens
prescriptions include the power size
curvature color
and material composition of the contact
lenses
other parameters or instructions include
but not are not limited to lens
manufacturer prescription expiration
date and number of permitted refills
additionally a statement prohibiting
substitutions may be included at the
prescriber's professional discretion
but anything on the prescription must be
honored in filling that prescription
the eye care center that provided my
constituent his eye exam and
prescription also sells contact lenses
under their own private label
under current new hampshire law when
they list private label on the contact
lens prescription the prescription can
only be filled for the private label
lens no substitutions are allowed unless
the manufacturer's own brand is included
and substitutions are allowed
this forced my constituent to purchase
the contacts from the eye care center at
a much higher cost than he could get for
identical contacts from other sellers
being forced to fill a contact lens
prescription when the prescriber for a
private label product
for a
when identical lenses are available in
the open market is not fair to the
consumer
in fact and you'll see this on the
handout i gave you of the updated rules
from the federal trade commission
in uh that they announced on june 23
2020 the quote the final rule also
clarifies that the only permissible
substitution
involves private label lenses
private label and brand name
lenses can be substituted for each other
when they are identical lenses made by
the same manufacturer
so
therefore i offer this amendment
amendment 0133h
2rsa 327 colon 25-a
roman numeral five
which makes three changes
includes the manufacturer's brand name
to the prescription
prescribers can forbid substitutions
only for health reasons
and include the statement found in the
ftc contact lens final rule
which is on the opposite page of the
press release
quote private label and brand name
lenses can be substituted for each other
when they are identical lenses made by
the same manufacturer end quote
thank you for your time and i'll be
happy to take any of your questions
representative merchant
thank you mr chairman and also thank you
for taking my question
my background is in pharmacy i'm a
pharmacist and when we look at generic
products
the fda controls the production of the
generics so therefore one generic is
basically comfortable with another
generic
brand name
help me understand why does the contact
lens have to be made by the same
manufacturer when another manufacturer
could actually make the contact lens
comparable to the other one
um i couldn't get all your question but
the uh in fact i have my contact lens
prescription right here
and it has
air optics night day
so if i went to an eye care center they
might re-brand this the exact same
contact lens under
um merrimack ice center contact lens day
night
even though it's exactly the identical
lens
so
what my amendment would do is to allow
those substitutions if they're an
identical
lens made by the same manufacturer
follow-up
thank you mr try to be clear
why does a
lens have to be made by the same
manufacturer in the world of drugs
if the manufacturer makes a generic drug
comparable to any other drug it meets
all the specifications
the pharmacist can use that generic
regardless of the manufacturer why does
a contact lens have to be come from the
same manufacturer as long as the specs
on that contact lens
satisfy the requirements of the eye
doctor
i understand your question now thank you
for it um i i think i'm open to that the
only thing is there's just so many
contact lens manufacturers and they are
very highly regulated and inspected um
and but many of them offer private label
contacts
so it's it
i and that you know i think i would
rather err on the side of caution about
using an identical
um an identical lens because
um it is having contact with the eye
tissue
and it's
not as there's
medical
uh consequences sometimes of using a
contact lens that's different from the
one that was prescribed even though it
may appear to be the same
it could be there could have been some
material that's used in the manufacture
of the
brand two contact
which may not be consistent with the
person's body or maybe allergic reaction
or something like that but
um
any any contact lens
can be put on the prescription it it
doesn't
what's the limiting factor is when they
don't specify the manufacturer of the
private label lens
and or they have the statement no
substitutions are allowed that's why in
my
the other change i made in that
amendment the second one
only
it limits prescribers
that they can only um
require substitutions if there's a
health reason
so there's a statement there that says
uh
included that the prescriber's
professional discretion for health
reasons only
so they can't demand a sub uh or forbid
a substitution let's say for a business
reason
um only requiring them to buy a brand
that
they're one of the few that sell
i hope they answer your question
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking the question would you believe
that when i was an analyst covering
johnson johnson i was involved with both
drug approvals and contact lens
approvals and the process for
for
devices in general and including contact
lenses
is very different and each of those has
a very specific approval where they're
not easily transferable one for one so
it's not actually a good one for one
comparison to the generic market but the
private label is thank you for that that
is a very good clarification and one
that's very necessary so thank you for
this amendment well thank you i
appreciate it
representative
thank you very much for taking my
question i just have a question
if we have an ftc rule
do we need to put it in statute in the
state or does the ftc rules already
supersede or already guide what we have
to do
i i was going to provide thank you for
that question dr knark i was going to
provide the ftc rule but i would have
had to cut down a forest to give
everyone a copy
um
but when i was reading through the
contact lens rule
many many times and even particularly
with expiration date it's um they defer
to the state law
so it's it's it's not a really a strong
uh compelling requirement when it's in
their rule
thank you
any further questions for the
representative
okay thank you very much thank you and
just point out to the committee
especially those in your first term when
there's multiple amendments and we
already have two
be careful how they're crafted
because if you have an amendment
that says replace the bill with
and then there's another amendment that
says replace the bill with
the one you do first is going to die
it's going to be replaced by the second
one
but
the two amendments we have here
representative runs is insert this
between and representative villier is
replace that so they don't clash but if
you're thinking of bringing an amendment
to this bill just make sure that
that initial wording doesn't have
unintended consequences
with that close the hearing on 11 39 and
uh
i'd like to take a breath
for about five minutes
my clerk would like to take a breath for
about three hours but
so we got five minutes we'll be back and
move on this one ought to go quick i
don't see anything
controversial about ivermecton do you
oh gosh yeah
uh no
no these are leftovers in case
somebody's missing one i'm putting them
all out there no i mean these oh no
those are the past ones no i made
dumplings all numbered so i know which
bill they go to and they're numbered i
may dump a few builds until there's
sheets here
oh here's some more 10-22
it has i tell ya
there have been
handouts flying left and right today
and it's hard to pass out amen our
handouts and take notes at the same time
i just thought i'd let you know that
oh oh you've
1466 was heard on a different day i
guess
um that was the off
[Music]
i'm trying to make sure i have two
copies of everything and some things
people just handed me one copy and i
don't even have the copies for everyone
else yet
so some of them were sent by email
i sent mine in my email but i have
another copy there okay
okay okay so this was i see yes and i
think someone already made those
perfect
this is good
yeah that's okay i'm figuring that out
there's several of the ones yeah
yeah i'm trying to lay out all the
extras here
what's that
oh it's yeah
so the clerk doesn't quit
she's coming close to it
um
uh
[Music]
um
christina
but those are the things
um
oh
all the speakers
because
he comes back
[Music]
i can
so maybe just amend it to say if it's
done it has to be given
yeah
right
and i still have the same
um
these are the extras
and i found
he took on the london medical
establishment that said pogba was miasma
and he traced it to the pump on broad
street
and thereby
what did he invent dr sauna
an epidemic no
[Music]
it was on public broadcasting how could
that possibly be
by the way
what another reason to be proud
now if it were based out they would have
been brought
i lost i lost one cavalier
see that's one reason
to go back
is
in the halls of parliament there's only
two two breeds of dogs that can enter
them
corgis
stewart
well
i'm going to try to do another round of
physical therapy not sure
i've noticed this
how are you
i don't know what it is
is
we're talking another eight-hour day to
get all of this recorded
anyway
he in
oh
low-grade pharmaceuticals
oh yeah
okay
is
victories
next week
[Music]
please
nope
i have a favorite television show that's
on at eight o'clock tonight
okay techy people
i introduce house bill 1022
which is
permitting pharmacists to dispense the
drug ivermectin by means of a standing
order
now we're measuring the pink cards up
here by running feet
which means we go to a protocol
and the protocol that i use is we start
off by
a person
opposed
and a person in favor of
and they get several minutes
there are sort of champions
and then everybody else has three
minutes
you can tell a story in three minutes
you can weigh in one way or the other
with good reasons in three minutes
and at that point my vice chair has
some kind of a device
that gives you a countdown
and at three minutes it admits a
horrible noise or something
okay we can find a terrible noise we're
very resourceful
[Music]
that's not terrible it's not terrible
enough but thank you
representative cushman please introduce
your bill
thank you mr chairman
my name is leah cushman and i represent
hillsborough county district 2 where
endearing
and i thank you committee members
for hearing my introduction to this bill
so
i bring you this bill as an attempt to
make new hampshire the first state in
this country to make ivermectin easily
available without a prescription
ivermectin is a nobel prize winning drug
that has been registered for human use
since 1987 and in 1988
a massive campaign was implemented in
africa to deliver ivermectin to millions
of people to combat river blindness
ivermectin was shown over the next 33
years to be extremely effective and well
tolerated it has been shown to be useful
in treatment of a variety of parasites
and also to have broad application as an
antiviral
it has demonstrated inhibitory effects
against hiv at least two dengue fever
viruses influenza simian virus sv40 and
a number of others
ivermectin is safe it has been
administered to humans globally for more
than 30 years with an estimated 6
billion doses given with very few
adverse effects
davis's drug guide lists more adverse
effects in severity and number from
tylenol and ivermectin
it is available over the counter in many
countries and is often administered by
non-medical personnel with very little
training due to its safe drug profile
ivermectin improves covet 19 outcomes at
least 60 controlled studies and 32
randomized controlled trials show that
it improves co
outcomes in mortality ventilation
viral clearance and case reduction
over 20 countries have adopted
ivermectin for treatment against covert
19.
multiple meta meta-analyses have shown
that iremectin helps in all stages of
illness but it is most effective when
started soon after symptom onset or as a
prophylactic after exposure the indian
state of uttar pradesh i'm sure many of
you are aware has managed to keep cases
low and prevented overwhelm of its
medical system due to its widespread use
of hypermectin as prophylactic and early
treatment
knowing that it's safe and that many
studies are showing its benefit and
knowing that it's used in other
countries as a first-line treatment why
would we restrict access to this
medication
there have been efforts to categorize
this off-label treatment and other
repurposed drugs as dangerous and not
recommended
although the bureaucratic organizations
of government and professional
authorities rage against it ask doctors
and nurses what they think and many have
a different professional opinion
they've looked at the evidence and they
see the opportunity to help people
unfortunately the campaign to demonize
this out-of-patent drug is dangerous as
dangerous horse paste has had a chilling
effect on the medical community's
willingness to utilize it
most doctors work for large hospital
systems which have policies that forbid
treating with ivermectin and so they
can't prescribe it even if they want to
how far the practice of medicine has
fallen when doctors cannot use their
knowledge of medications and physiology
and repurpose drugs to help improve
health of their patients more than 20
percent of prescriptions given are for
off-label use
these same hospital systems strongly
advocate for vaccination with vaccines
that have the highest number of reported
adverse events
of all vaccines in the last 40 years
combined
30 years combined with known safety
issues and low efficacy that wanes
within months and no long-term safety
studies
they also offer emergency use authorized
treatments such as remdevier which also
has not been studied long term and
carries a high rate of kidney damage and
a poor success rate
they're beginning to offer recently eua
authorized pexlovid which has had no
long-term safety studies and utilizes
only one mechanism of action against
covid ivermectin on the other hand has
been used safely for decades and has
more than 10 documented mechanisms of
action that inhibit covet 19's ability
to make people very sick
the hospitals advocate that people stay
home until they have complications such
as blood clots or hypoxia offering no
early treatment then with the staff
shortages from moral distress and
vaccine mandates leading to fewer open
beds combined with rising cases and no
early treatment susceptible patients
fill up the few available icu beds and
bring the hospital system close to
collapse
if there is a safe drug available that
could help reduce the burden on the
hospital systems and save lives why
would the hospitals and professional
organizations rally against
this drug like no other off-label drug
in history
ivermectin is inexpensive it can be
compounded locally
it's been out of patent for years and is
not a money-making drug it's
demonstrably safe and increasingly
proven effective the nih coveted 19
treatment guidelines panel changed its
guidelines on ivermectin from
recommending against its use to stating
it has insufficient data to recommend
either for or against the use of
hybermectin for the treatment of covet
19.
are more studies needed yes larger
studies are needed but researchers have
already used meta-analyses to combine
smaller studies and make sense of their
data as a whole and multiple
meta-analyses have shown positive
effects from ivermectin
standing orders are specific and can be
written essentially in algorithm form
with dosage instructions based on
patient weight and indication
whether for prophylaxis or treatment
they could be written according to the
flcc protocol
flccc protocol which was created by
frontline critical care providers who
have been studying treatment
effectiveness for cova 19 patients since
the beginning of the pandemic
not all pharmacies especially large
corporate pharmacies and hospital
pharmacies will be willing to take
standing orders for ivermectin but some
will
not all doctors will be willing to risk
persecution and potential disciplinary
action for writing a standing order but
some brave souls will
even if one pharmacy receives a standing
order from one physician in new
hampshire it would be better than none
it could greatly reduce suffering the
burden on hospitals and it could save
lives i hope you will listen to the
testimony here today with an open mind
and heart and give people access to an
option for early treatment for coven 19.
thank you
would the representative take questions
yes
seeing none thank you
now i'm going to call on a proponent
and an opponent
and give you
more latitude say seven to eight minutes
each to present the case then we will
start working on the stack of pink cards
the chair calls paul morick i hope i
have that right from norfolk virginia
somebody finally south of my district
thank you mr chairman and the committee
so you were right uh chairman that this
is not controversial
if you look at the science
if you look at the science this is not a
controversial issue it's been made
controversial
by politics and special interests so i'm
an intensivist i'm board certified in
critical care medicine intensive care
medicine neurocritical care nutrition
support i've been practicing critical
care for 35 years i have been looking
after covert patients since march the
24th last year i've looked after
hundreds and hundreds of cobot patients
i've published over 600 peer-reviewed
papers and i'm the second most published
person in my specialty ever so i think i
do have some credibility so i will talk
about ivamectin but i'm prepared to
answer any question on covert or any
related issue
so as we heard excellent presentation
after
penicillin this is the second most
important drug ever produced it has
saved hundreds of thousands of lives
across this planet in poor underserved
countries
so we're just going to talk about either
mechan william campbell and satoshi
omori i hope you have a handout were
awarded the nobel prize in 200 2015 for
their 1975 discovery of ivamekton it's
notable this is the only
pharmaceutical
anti-infective drug ever to receive the
nobel prize it was first used in humans
in 1987. it is on the who's list of
essential medicines it's an essential
medicine according to the who 3.7
billion doses have been dispensed to
humans
to human beings not horses
3.7 billion doses have been dispensed to
human beings this is a remarkable drug
it has broad-spectrum anti-parasitic
effective against a whole bunch of
parasites and as we heard it's very
effective against rna viruses hiv virus
zika virus influenza virus source cov2
in addition what makes this a truly
astonishing drug and there's no other
drug like it it is a potent
anti-inflammatory drug and if anybody
knows how about covert covert goes
through stages a viral replicative phase
to a profound inflammatory phase that's
why ivamectin is unique in that it
treats across the spectrum of size kovi
2.
it's safe and well tolerated the regular
dose is 200 mics per kilo they've done
dosing studies giving 10 times the
recommended dose with minor side effects
which include pureitis fever rash and
arthralgia
the second page is from the nobel prize
lecture of satoshi omuri you can see
that 1.4 billion doses have been given
for onco-psychiatrists this is river
blindness this is a disabling disease in
africa
ivamectin has changed the face of this
disease
1.2 billion doses for lymphatic
filariasis
so in terms of its mode of action as dr
cushman said that she she did a really
good job so either make acts on a number
of different pathways to inhibit viral
replication this is not theoretical this
is shown in the lab and this is shown in
patients a study done in israel a
randomized placebo control study where
they gave ivamectin not only did they
look actually cultured the virus it
kills the virus so any assumption that
it doesn't is false propaganda
so in terms of the studies this is one
of the most studied drugs for covert as
we see 71 trials with 50 000 patients 31
of these are randomized controlled
trials you'll see an 83 percent
improvement in prophylaxis trials 66
improvement in early trials 34
improvement in late trials a 52
reduction in mortality it reduces
mortality by half so the critics will
say these are done in um
i won't use the bad word
poor countries that can't do good trials
that's xenophobic
that's xenophobic these countries and
these investigators are sincere and
honest and not bribed by pharmaceutical
companies
then we have the fda we all know about
this you're not a horse you're not a cow
seriously you will stop it you should
not use ivermectin to treat or prevent
covet 19 using the drug ivamectin which
can be dangerous and even lethal so that
is an outright lie it's dishonest and
it's an outrage as we'll see this is a
highly effective drug and either mectin
has never killed a single person it is
one of the safest drugs on this planet
so then we have the data from the cdc
which are equally as dishonest a myth is
born how the cdc the fda and media wove
a web of either mectin lies that
outlived the truth so in new mexico they
claimed that ivamekton killed two people
actually these two people
died of covert and then in mississippi
there was a call that
either to poison centers that there had
been an increase of 70 percent of calls
to poison control centers that is a lie
there were three calls
three calls of alleged side effects
involving two animal formulations so
again the cdc and the fda are
perpetuating falsehoods
and lies to scare the american people
what is really interesting is ivan
mekden is safe in 79 countries in the
world let me say that again it is
approved in 79 countries so somehow
japanese people indian people brazilian
people can tolerate it safely but it's
toxic in americans you have to be
kidding
let's look at the toxicity so this is
from the who itself the world health
organization this is their visual vigi
access database which is an
international drug monitoring database
for the last 40 years
if we see since 1992
ivamectin is associated with so-called
20 deaths and 5 000 adverse events we
think all of these 20 deaths were due to
an allergic reaction to the death of the
parasite let's look at covert 19
vaccines in one year 14 000 deaths
and over 2 million serious adverse
events this does not include the 20 000
deaths in the vars database which is
probably a tenth of all deaths due to
the vaccine this is their data so
somehow the source cov2 vaccines are
safe and effective
yet ivamectin is a dangerous horse
deworming medicine
that's an absolute outright lie and the
data speaks for itself this is not my
data this is from the who and anybody
who wants to validate this data can go
to vg access and access this data itself
as you see more people have died from
tylenol
more people have died from tylenol which
is an over-the-counter medicine than
ivamekton as i said it is one of the
safest medications
on this planet
so
if we actually go to the veggie access
database and look what the side effects
are
pyrexia which is fever fatigue pain face
swelling malaise chest pain these are
minor side effects these are the side
effects reported with ivamectin which
are
minor
this is a study 25-year clinical
experience with iva mechton an overview
of the safety if you have a collie dog
you do not want to give ivamectin to a
collie dog because there's impaired
blood brain barrier negligible effects
in humans not a single death directly
related to ivamectin a robust safety
profile
most of the side effects are an allergic
reaction to the death of microfilaria
it's not recommended in pregnancy or
lactation
so there was a caution in the use of in
children less than 15 kilograms because
of a
immature blood-brain barrier they
thought it wasn't safe a recent study as
you can see published just last year
looked at over a thousand kids and found
1.4 percent adverse events which were
all mild and self-limiting so even in
children under the age of 15 this is a
safe disease
with mild and
self-limiting
side effects so let's compare rem
deservier to iva mektin the cost of rem
deserve 30 30 000
sorry three thousand dollars a shot
either mack and pennies has either as
rem destiny have been shown to reduce
the risk of death the answer is
definitively and categorically no rem
deserver increases the risk of dying by
four percent let me say that again this
is used throughout the entire country as
first line therapy for hospitalized
patients it increases the risk of death
by four percent and what is now most
outrageous is the federal government
gives hospitals a 20
bonus on the entire hospital bill for
medicare patients if they prescribe rem
deserve that's the truth
ibmecton reduces the risk by 50 percent
can you use rendezvous at home no
ivamectin yes causes organ damage yes
rim deserve is nephrotoxic studies which
were required to approve rem deserve
one
study which was scientific misconduct i
haven't met in over 60 studies and
cannot be considered major conflicts of
interest yes and no
support by the fda and falci yes and no
so this is a little handout from the who
the world health organization in their
promotion of ivamectin for the
eradication of parasitic diseases the
2-2-2-2 rule 200 mics per kilogram per
day two tabs per day of six milligrams
you take it for two days and the price
to the who
two cents
that's what it costs them
so you know that is my brief overview
this is a cheap drug
it's exceedingly safe
it's exceedingly effective
and patient should be offered the right
to use this drug we're not telling
doctors what to do but this should be an
option and if either magnet had been
promoted at the beginning of this
pandemic
we would not be sitting here today
thank you and i'll take any questions
any questions for dr merrick
representative shapiro
yes thank you mr chair and thank you for
taking the question
um
many people have contacted me
about
about wanting the opportunity to use
hypervectin
and they frequently refer to
trying to stay near the microphone and
see you at the same time
and they frequently refer to that a
patient and a doctor should be able to
work together to make a
a reasonable choice
however the mechanism in this bill by
which iverbectin would become available
is really
precluding the doctor's involvement
because this would be a standing order
to pharmacies
and therefore the doctor would have no
real contact with the patients
so i understand you're a proponent of
hyperbactin that came across very
clearly but is this the way to do it
with really like
reducing the doctor's involvement in the
prescription of
hypervectin that's a good question i
think there should always be a
discussion between the doctor and the
patient but i think the problem is there
are many doctors who will not prescribe
it because of all the misinformation and
the threats against them
recently a doctor in maine i think had
her license suspended and she was sent
for neuropsychiatric testing because she
prescribed ivamectin so i think this is
a way around this i agree with you is
that there needs to be open dialogue we
need to have open dialogue on everything
to do with covet we need to have open
discussions science is based on
questions so i agree with you i think
that there should be a discussion with a
physician but i think patients should
also be given the option to control
their own life and what they think so i
think in terms of you know i think it's
the way you position this is we
recommend early treatment early
treatment is absolutely critical to keep
people outside of the hospital
what the nih says is there's no
treatment you stay at home until you go
blue when you go blue come to the icu
that's obviously ridiculous so i think
early treatment is absolutely critical
it prevents transmission of the disease
it prevents transmission to the family
and it takes
it controls the disease so obviously i
think there need to be some kind of
controls in its use but i think it's an
option
thank you thank you representative
merchant
thank you chair hopefully you can hear
me doctor yes sir
i notice in the bill
that there's a requirement for a
protocol for the pharmacist to follow so
basically they're not just giving it out
willy-nilly they're having to go through
some sort of an assessment based upon
the protocol yes sir so even though it's
not a discussion with the prescriber the
doctor that is basically following a
discussion the doctor would probably
outline via the protocol
now in 79 other countries throughout
this world
i know i can walk into mexico
and buy drugs that are not available
here
without following any protocol all i
have to do is put my cash on the
counter and i can buy it yes do you feel
comfortable that with the insertion of a
protocol written by the prescriber for
the pharmacist to follow
is that sufficiently safe for the
patient
yes absolutely i think there's a
standard dosing the pharmacist can then
look for drug interactions because there
are some drugs which interact so clearly
if the pharmacist is given a protocol he
knows how to dose it the number of days
and he knows their significant drug
interactions and he follows a protocol
because to tell you the truth
unfortunately in this country most
doctors follow protocols they have lost
the ability of any cognitive thought
process they just blindly follow
protocols so a doctor following blindly
a protocol or a pharmacist who may be
more informed in terms of drug
interactions
maybe a safer way to go so you are
correct there are some drug interactions
which most doctors aren't even aware of
that a pharmacist should be aware of and
then he will be able to judge is this
the right dose do i need to adjust the
dose and is the safe for example patient
may be on coumadin which is a blood
thinner as you know if they aren't
coumadin then they need to adjust the
dose and most doctors won't know this so
you absolutely correct i think a good
protocol and a pharmacist that is
diligent
is very is a very safe way to go
representative
thank you mr chairman doctor thank you
for coming thank you for taking my
question i hope that we have saved you
from the terrible snowstorms of virginia
yeah thank you it's the weather here is
wonderful thank you
doctor can you tell me who has sponsored
your trip here today
um that's a good question
because i paid most of it i paid out of
my own pocket some of it i may be
reimbursed by the flcc which is the
organization that we started which is a
non-for-profit
organization thank you thank you
any further questions for the doctor
before we let him go dr woods
uh thank you mr chair and uh thank you
doctor for taking my question question
and i'll have a follow-up uh just i'm
trying to get a sense of balance of the
use of ivermectin which is
at least portrayed as this miracle that
would have saved the world
uh how would you
put that in balance if everyone in the
country would have
taken the
recommendation for masking
and distancing
had say done that protocol
on a relative scale to taking
yes hypermectin
you ask an interesting question
which is very political
so
um i actually reviewed the science on
wearing a mask
actually the likelihood is mass increase
the risk of complications when you wear
a mask it increases your dead space it
increases respiratory resistance so it
causes your blood oxygen levels to go
down
there's very little data
that except an n95 an n95 is a different
story but using these cloth and surgical
masks actually
likely provide no protection and
obviously have lots of deleterious side
effects social distancing obviously is
important to some degree
but is not going to eliminate this
disease what i should also say is that
there's no magic bullet for covet
there's no magic bullet it's a
multi-pronged approach and they're
multiple things people can do to reduce
their risk of getting covert the most
important is vitamin d if you have a
vitamin d level over 50 your chances of
dying of covert
are close to zero and since you're up
here now the north pole you don't see a
lot of sun it's absolutely essential
that everyone in the state takes vitamin
d it's not even controversial anymore
then there's oropharyngeal hygiene
there's vitamin c so there are a whole
host of things that people can do to
empower themselves empower themselves
not to get covered and then when you get
covert it's a multi-pronged approach
it's not just ivermectin so as dr
kushman i'm going to call her dr cushman
said in uttar pradesh they have a covert
kit it's a covet kit that is eliminated
covered they use a kit that has vitamin
d
tylenol ivamectin
and uttar pradesh as of yesterday it's a
province of 220 million people had one
death
one death in the whole province of uttar
pradesh which has a vaccination rate of
about 30 percent so it's a multi-pronged
approach and unfortunately i think the
federal response to covet has been an
absolute failure
and things have to change because
despite all the mandates and everything
else that's going on i mean people got
to look what's happening omicron is all
over the place and it shouldn't be
and we know that 80 of people who
vaccinated get omicron so something has
failed omicron is out of control so
there has been a massive failure of the
system and it has to be multifaceted
sorry there was a long answer to your
question but
you asked the question
i just want to note dr paul that um
every nurse i've ever known
was thrilled when she or he were called
doctor
yes thank you for the promotion you did
such an outstanding job
representative folsom
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question
would you
find it a much better situation if our
pharmacists were able to have a standing
order and people went to our pharmacist
rather than trying to find the drug in a
plethora of other places you absolutely
correct people will do what they have to
do you know when people are desperate as
you know they have a loved one who's
sick and dying they will do whatever
they can do and they're going to use
veterinary grade other mechan which we
don't recommend but you know what when
your back's against the wall and you
have no options people will do this so
that's why you put your point is
absolutely correct it's much safer to do
it under a supervised setting than
people going to you know horse stores
and and and hardware stores and buying
veterinary grade ivormectin because we
don't know the quality we don't know the
grade they don't know the dosing so your
question is absolutely correct and there
are hundreds of thousands of people who
have used veterinary grade ivermectin
what they even do
i can tell you a story of a two-year-old
little girl in in a highly sophisticated
icu the parents rubbed on ivermectin
because ivamectin is absorbed
transcutaneously
they thought this child was going to die
they told the parents your child is
going to die unbeknownst to them the
parents rubbed either magden on the
child's chest the child made a
miraculous recovery which they didn't
understand we've had priests who come
into the hospital and anoint their
patients with ivamectin
so you know what why why do we have to
go to these extreme and ridiculous
measures just so this is an fda approved
drug forty percent of drugs used in the
hospital are fda off label the fda until
two years ago promoted the use of
off-label drugs they said these drugs
can be prescribed by the physician at
their clinical judgment
what's happening now is the federal
government the states and hospitals are
telling doctors how to practice medicine
they're telling doctors how to practice
medicine let doctors be doctors let
doctors do what they train to do and
that doctor can decide for themselves
what they want to do but we should not
have the state
or the federal government or hospitals
dictating how doctors practice medicine
that's not the hippocratic way and it's
not the way medicine is practiced so
absolutely i agree with you 100 thank
you
dr woods
uh thank you again
for letting me take the question mr
chair and thank you for taking another
question should i just if you could help
me drill down
uh on your you know it's not numbered um
the world health organization fda merc
sheet about deaths
um it's highlighted there's 14
774.
um
could you expand on where that data
comes from and how it was collected
yes so this is an international
collaborative drug monitoring service so
run by the who so what happens is they
collect or they have partnerships with
countries across the world and who have
pharmacovigilance and this data is sent
to them
and then the data the
the documents get screened and then put
in this database so this is likely an
underestimate of the true number of
deaths
so it is 14 774 as of last week if we
look at the vars database which is
vaccine associated adverse events in the
u.s currently it's 20 000. so this is 20
000 deaths in the u.s the erect the
assessment is that is probably one-tenth
of the actual deaths so that's 200 000
deaths directly due to the vaccine so
that's in the vas database anybody can
go and look this is in the vg access
database so this raises serious
questions about
it's being safe and effective because
even using the wh own
data or using the cdc's own data there
are significant number of deaths related
to the vaccines and you know that's a
different question and this wasn't about
the vaccines this was about ivamectin
but i think it shows the hypocrisy in
that ivormectin is considered dangerous
deworming horse medicine whereas the
vaccines are considered safe and
effective and the data does not support
that narrative
other questions
yes representative delemus
microphone
it can be brought closer to you
there you go how's that wonderful
okay
are you aware doctor that here in new
hampshire doctors are prescribing
ivermectin but there is only one
pharmacy in the entire state in salem
new hampshire that is a privately owned
apothecary and they are dispensing
ivermectin but no other pharmacies in
the entire state are uh are dispensing
ivermectin at the request and
prescription of the doctors
yes so we know this is an issue that
pharmacists are practicing medicine
they're looking at icd-9 codes to see
what the indication is that's illegal
pharmacists are not permitted to
act as doctors what they can do is they
can look for drug interactions and they
have a legal obligation to fulfill the
script unless there's some outrageous
reason not to fill it but many
pharmacists because of pressurized
to not fulfill the script so we've
actually spoken to the ceos of these
companies and it is not their policy so
theoretically if you go to a pharmacy
and the pharmacist refuses what the ceos
of these companies are saying is take
down his name
the pharmacy number and report him to
head office because this is illegal it
is illegal for pharmacists to practice
medicine they do not have a medical
license they do not need to know what
the icd-9 code is when you get a
prescription for
a beta blocker the pharmacist doesn't
ask you what's the indication why you're
taking it he gives you the medication he
may look to see if there are any drug
interactions so this is an attempt by
the pharmacies to practice medicine
because they feel they pressurized by
the fda
and by the way because of this
outrageous
public relations stint by the fda they
have actually reversed this statement
about the horse
and you're not a cow so if you go to
their website you'll see they've
actually changed this saying that it's
actually permissible to use medical
grade hypermectin but that's obviously
not published because nobody wants to
know about it
any other questions
representative merchant
thank you mr chair
in regards to the same thing about the
supply of the medication and being sure
that the patient has a safe supply of
medication
many times patients in this country
will obtain product
internationally
and a lot of times it gets through the
process of the fda and border controls
and so forth there's only so much they
can do to screen the thousands and
millions of packages coming in
in your opinion
would it be better for the patient from
a safety point of view to obtain
domestic product regulated by the fda
than to have them go internationally to
possibly buy medication from other
countries that don't have the same
regulatory oversight thank you sir
that's an absolutely outstanding
question because as i said
patients will do what they need to do
they'll either use veterinary grade or
they will go through canadian pharmacies
and get ivamectin from india of which
we're not sure what they're getting so
both compounding pharmacies and and
manufacturing pharmacies in this country
are controlled by both state and the fda
to ensure that the standards of
manufacturer manufacture are correct so
that's a very good point because
if they can get it in the u.s then at
least we know there's some kind of
quality control so they know what
they're getting yes very good point
thank you very much doctor thank you
and as i said we would start with
two individuals who would be given quite
a bit of time sort of the champions the
battle of the yes and the no here
dr nick i can't quite read
your last name but dr nick please tell
me your last name so i'll pronounce it
correctly
yeah like it says okay you see that now
okay sorry pretty phonetic thank you
thank you for allowing me to speak
um
last week i believe
you folks were able to maybe not hear
but read a testimony submitted by my
colleague dr randy hayes
and it was about bill 1466 and i think
14 66 and
10 22 are very similar in that they talk
about
what docs can do and what docs can't do
basically and i'm a physician i'm not an
expert in infectious disease
i'm learning a lot about hypermechtum
right now being here for the last hour
i'm a general surgeon i've practiced in
concord for a long time i i'm retired
but i still teach medical students at
from dartmouth
three days a week
um
anyway uh what i'm about to talk about
briefly and cut me off at three minutes
please not gonna do it you're gonna okay
equal time
anyway uh
i think the main reason i was asked to
be here today was uh my experience
my experience basically uh being a
member of the new hampshire medical
society
but also being a
participant in the board of medicine for
over 17 years i had various physicians
there on the board vice president of the
board medical review subcommittee in the
last
several years the last five years i was
the physician investigator of the board
of medicine
and
all i can do is tell you a little bit
about what in reading this bill and i i
i read the bill thinking
a lot of this makes sense a lot of it i
don't understand and uh in my written
testimony what am i talking about well
in the bill it said specifically
the bill shall
specify a protocol allowing the
pharmacist to dispense ivermectin
and she'll specify a mechanism to
document screening performed and the
prescription in the patient's medical
record including a plan for evaluating
and treating adverse events so it sounds
like there's some kind of thing here
other than just writing a prescription
and
going to a pharmacist and if that
wording means in my mind uh the patient
will sign a consent
uh that's maybe in the chart hopefully
and make it clear that they understand
what off label means because whether we
like it or not it sounds like a lot of
folks here don't like it it's still
listed as off label if you're going to
use it for covid
and
they need to understand that and that
signed consent needs to be in the
patient record and the licensee will be
monitored the outcomes will be monitored
for any reverse effects
and if that's the case and this
doc gets complained about or there's a
suit or a claim
or a complaint
and the board of medicine at least in my
17 years there if the doc's doing all
those things there's not going to be an
issue now
having been around a long time not
i can't remember uh off label ever being
a big issue at the board of medicine 17
back in the 70s way before i even moved
to new hampshire
there was a case with leotrill i don't
know if anybody's here old enough to
remember that
right so you folks know more than i do
and i won't go on to it but it was past
and then
say that
again yeah okay it was it was it and i
don't think it ever became fda approved
so whether that was label or off-label i
don't know but
the legislature felt that it ought to be
available and a couple years later they
changed their mind so that bill did
disappear
i was very involved with the off-label
use of antibiotics that is antibiotics
for prolonged use for lyme syndrome and
that was back in my written testimonies
little off it said 2013 it was actually
2011.
and
before all that got passed and even
since then i mean i went off the board
two years ago but there was never a
complaint
or a lawsuit or a claim i mean we've had
this law
but i wondered what it really meant i
mean it was
telling docs that you can't do anything
if you're going to order antibiotics
long term off label for lyme disease
this seems different i mean i'd like to
think that we're not going to get
complaints or lawsuits
but i think you mentioned just six days
ago in maine uh doc and ellsworth maine
got uh
um
you know
suspended and i think she's gonna have
to go through psychiatric evaluation it
wasn't just
it was multiple covert related issues
that created the complaint so i i
anticipate this time around the board
will get with covet complaints lawsuits
and claims
it's happened in there's been discipline
in over 20 states according to the
federation of medical boards that's an
organization that sort of
your all the medical boards of all 50
states report to so it's real and uh
i guess in my mind what the board of
medicine always is struggling with when
we meet every month whether it's the
medical review subcommittee or the board
is what is the standard of care and
that's that's a
tough subject it's not
uh it's not a written protocol for
everything
but when we do a complaint lawsuit or
claim we we debate what is the standard
of care
amongst us here in new hampshire and
amongst the peers
and i'd like to believe the standard of
care in new hampshire is that a patient
certainly could have iramectin
prescribed off label as long as
that patient ideally gets put into some
clinical trial whether it's a whether
it's a drug company or whether it's a
academic institution like dartmouth
those trials do exist and they still
exist
and and if that were the case and all
those other things were in order if i
was signing a consent and so forth uh i
don't think there'd be an issue
but without that without any
responsibility as to what happens when
ordering an off-label drug i think
there's a problem
and the board
i think is the right place to look that
because that's where the standard of
care issues are discussed and decided
so i am opposed to this bill as it's
written now but if it gets rewritten a
little clearer about all those other
issues particularly with god consent and
and if you're not going to put the
patient on a clinical trial you create
something where you're keeping records
that seem similar to that
if you're doing that i don't think the
board of medicine would go after you my
last comment is basically is this all
kind of antiquated as far as ivermectin
and
uh the doctor here mentioned that the
drug paxlovit is out and uh the data on
that and its fda approved i believe on
an emergency basis like the vaccines
were
you know if you had a patient that you
wanted to write ivermectin on it would
be nice that that same patient could be
in a protocol where that ivermectin's
response could be compared to paxlovit
to now it's been those studies that you
mentioned that are all over the world
and there have been many studies looking
at
on covet they're pretty much looking at
it the control is basically
placebo there isn't another drug you're
comparing it to but now that we have
at least in this country other drugs
that that might be work wouldn't it be
nice if you wanted to order ivamectin to
get that patient on a trial
i think that's the way to do it
and um and that's all i really have to
say
thank you doctor would you take
questions
that again
would you take questions sure
i've changed over to a nine i changed
over to the 19 mask as
having to be articulate
representative acton
all right thank you mr chair
thank you sir for taking my question uh
my question is related to treatment
protocols here we are two years later
i've had a number of complaints from
physicians in my area saying that the
the treatment protocols just never
developed they didn't come out
from from early on
the it seemed as though the the best
treatment was
people were told to go to the emergency
room told go home wait till you're
really sick and then come back and i
even heard people still getting that
advice
this fall
in your opinion why
have there been has there been such a
slow pace of rolling out treatment
protocols here in new hampshire
hopefully it's not just laziness of
physicians
i you know i you would hope that all
physicians who are treating patients are
trying to find these protocols that i'm
that i that i believe are out there
again i'm not an expert in this
um
sometimes it's easier just to say
something that isn't correct and to do
the hard work in finding the protocol
i i don't have a direct answer to that
but i'm fearful that that might be one
of the answers
representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you
doctor for taking the questions
hopefully i could ask two quick
questions um the first is in regards to
paloxide i'm not sure are you aware that
several drugs for sinus rhythm for
patients with atrial fibrillation are
highly contraindicated so especially
anybody on amiodarone can't take it
no i don't okay i'm not aware then again
as a journalist again i'm a retired
general surgeon yes thank you
and the other question is when are
looking to collect data i don't know who
would pay for a large pharmaceutical
style study or an academic one
especially with the one-to-one overhead
from places like dartmouth
what a registry
where where the information was just
collected
sort of a very lightweight swedish model
be sufficient to find any large signals
of risk or benefit and then generate a
hypothesis for a true clinical trial
later
i totally agree that patients shouldn't
be involved paying out of pocket to be
in a clinical trial that that to me is
unethical because you're making the
effort to
share your information what's happened
to you
um
yeah i think a registry would be better
than nothing
and
but i'd like to believe there aren't
that many obstacles that get into a
trial i may be wrong
any further questions for the doctor
thank you very much sir
thank you
now we are going into our three minutes
have you found a nasty three-minute
buzzer yet
i believe i have let me give it to you
is uh two seconds
well no you're going to take the blame
for it you hold it in your hand
that is nasty enough for our purposes
thank you representative herschel nunes
come on up thank you for coming
[Music]
thank you mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee
um i'm here today um my name's herschel
nunez for the record herschel nunes
representative hillsborough district 37
towns of hudson in pelham i live in
pelham and i'm here today to tell you
about a personal story
about ivermectin and about my health
um i'm going to actually read a little
bit here i'm going to get through it
real quick i don't want to leave
anything out that's why i'm going to
read
um i am not a doctor and am i no way i
want to present myself as a professional
in the health or medical industry i am
however a licensed minister if that
helps in any way
i'm also the political director of new
hampshire liberty alliance but i'm not
here representing them today i'm here
representing myself although my views
line 100 with that organization
i want to tell you my personal story
about covid knight my covet 19 journey
twice
and how i believe ivermectin actually
saved me in the beginning of november i
was notified that i had been exposed to
uh the cyrus cov2 virus i began watching
for symptoms and very soon after that i
tested positive through a pcr test from
my doctor
i was given instruction to go home
i was quarantined for at least 10 days
and that if my symptoms became
threatening to go to the emergency room
do not show up at the office
i was also not offered any type of
prescription no type of treatment
whatsoever from the doctor
not of any kind nor was was i given any
type of instruction of any type of
over-the-counter medicine that i could
assist that could assist me with the
infection although i thought it was
really bad that my doctor would not help
me in because i was sick
that evening i became very ill and after
two days of being home with me
quarantining my partner also became very
ill
on the night of day two i was running a
fever of 103.6
i had horrendous body aches and i needed
assistance just to walk to the
facilities
that was a rough night and the next day
was no better but fortunately there was
a knock on my door
from someone that i knew who i now
consider an angel
that friend placed an envelope on my
doorstep and inside was a note
describing where i could do a telehealth
appointment
uh to have iber ivremechten prescribed
and immediately with the assistance from
my partner i went online and went
through the telehealth process and a
doctor prescribed me the ivormectin and
it was shipped to me overnight arrived
the next morning about 11 am
now at this point both my partner and i
were extremely sick
so sick that we had talked about going
to the hospital but we decided we'd
rather take our chances at home we
literally made our peace with each other
and our creator and asked that he watch
over us
we both took the ivermectin and
amazingly about three hours later for
both of us our fever broke
our body aches left completely but we
were still very sick
we continued the ivermectin use as
prescribed by our doctor which was also
following the flccc guidelines
uh for ivermectin use for the covet 19
patients
each day we got better and better we
still experienced many of the same
symptoms as other patients would
experience but i believe the ivramecten
was the saving grace or medication
in our illnesses
because we were so sick and i knew there
could be a chance of contracting the
disease again
i acquired another prescription of
ivermectin for us to have on hand a
larger one
we both tested negative 12 days after
infection however we still dealt with
the residual effects of the disease
i had researched the flccc protocols
for post covenant infections and
continued at a reduced dosage as
instructed
during the holidays we decided to travel
to our vacation home in the us virgin
islands
we tested negative and we traveled a
week prior to travel we increased our
dosage of ivermectin
for protection and during our stay we
took iv we took ivermectin daily
omicron was beginning to move rampant
through the island at this point there
were 127 cases on the island when we
arrived 10 days later there were 1300
cases
we were
around hundreds of people
on island in the airports and on the
plane
when we came home we stopped our ivory
meccan protocol
and five days later i was exposed to the
omicron variant and i became ill and
tested positive once again
uh why didn't i just keep taking the po
po the post uh coveted protocol i don't
know i just i had just stopped
um i'm happy i had the ivermectin on
hand i only had two and a half days of
fever one tough day and then the virus
presented itself as a nasty cold i
tested negative day on day six seven and
eight now i'm here testifying before you
that was very recent i am negative i
tested negative this morning
i truly believe uh had i not been
following the ivermectin protocol the
illness in both respects would have
would have and could have been much
worse
our doctors would not prescribe us
anything we were left to our own
defenses we ordered all of the vitamin
supplements that our research determined
we should use d3k2 sequest and bromelain
zinc copper it was a pill fest every
morning
you do what you have to do to stay well
we took that along with our dose of
ivermecnus prescribed following the
flccc guidelines
my partner
by the way i will be visiting my local
doctor regularly for lung checks and
blood work
my partner and i both have autoimmune
diseases
30 seconds autoimmune diseases that will
not allow us to take the vaccine
therefore we must be allowed to and be
involved with a post-covet protocol to
keep ourselves safe
from the virus during the duration of
this pandemic and we both believe that
ivormectin is the protocol we choose to
follow i'm a firm believer that
thyrobectin is a drug that can assist
with the weakening of the virus allowing
the patient to be able to work through
the disease and infection much much
easier i have provided my testimony to
you in writing i've also provided to you
the flccc guidelines for avermectin used
for covet 19 along with the report i
gave you the link as well and i also
gave you a report from the miracle
journal of therapeutics where they've
reviewed the emerging of evidence
demonstrating the efficacy of ivermectin
and the prophylaxis and treatment of
cover 19. you have that report from me
and the link to that as well
i also want to say one last statement
that i do not believe the state has any
right to step between a doctor and a
patient where their um where prescribing
medicine is is concerned uh and i also
think that because this this uh medicine
is is
well known all over the world and is
sold over the counter in many countries
it should be also sold over the counter
here thank you very much thank you
representative
and to balance
another representative
our own doctor jerry kanerk who has 25
copies of
something
has he passed them out yes yes i've
already passed them out that's what that
is okay i see it and thank you
may i ask for maybe just a little bit
more than three minutes because i was
asked by some people to uh to explain
the protocols of three minutes plus the
overrun
i'll do my best i'll i'll motor mouth
and i've already cut a bunch of stuff um
so anyway yes for the record jerry caner
carroll county district three
um we're really not here to discuss
whether or not ivermectin is good or bad
we're here to discuss its use in covid
the decision to use in medicine or
surgical intervention is based upon an
analysis of the risks and the benefits
of the proposed procedure
or intervention to treat a specific
clinical diagnosis using the best
available evidence if there's clear
benefit with a low risk profile then it
sounds like a good intervention
now you've all received a bunch of
emails and we just heard a couple of
testimonials about how
people took some covet and they got
better
but those are anecdotes they're not data
they mean nothing since actually most
people who get coveted will recover
so determining the risks and benefits
require really well-designed studies
analyzed by investigators free of
conflict of interest and that
analysis requires a very high level of
study and knowledge of study design i'm
sorry i'm trying to read too fast many
studies look compelling upon further
analysis have design flaws don't apply
have study groups too small don't reach
significance or not reproducible
bottom line ivermectin does have clear
benefit for certain indications such as
treating parasitic worms and even some
external parasites the risk for a file
is indeed rather small with appropriate
doses and that's already been covered
the rationale for using ivermectin and
covet is based on its ability to inhibit
these uh saris covalent virus ii in cell
cultures but that doesn't necessarily
predict success in a clinical setting
because that's a whole different thing
numerous clinical studies has been
published with conflicting results but
most ivermectin studies published so far
and this has been well
analyzed by a number of different groups
the cochrane collaboration the fda a
number of different groups have looked
at it most are limited by two smaller
sample sizes non-blinding the use of
concomitant medications that confound
the assessment
or poorly defined study groups and
outcome measures even the well-designed
studies have
quite marked limitations such that
definitive conclusions regarding the
clinical efficacy of ivermectin in the
treatment of covid cannot yet be reached
so as an example as representative nunus
mentioned he distributed a meta-analysis
by bryant
if you look on page e442 that
demonstrates the quality of endpoint
quality of evidence for the various
endpoints so again that's in your emails
and you'll find that the quality of
evidence was very low for seven of the
endpoints low for four and moderate for
one
that's not a really compelling set of
data
and the one that was moderate was uh
based substantially on the paper from
egypt by al-gazar which was later
retracted when it was found to be
fraudulent
if we look at the paper that was just
distributed to us this morning that's
this one here by kerr it really doesn't
take very long to actually realize that
this is also not a great paper because
as you look at either the beginning of
the second paragraph or in the study
procedures and data collection on the
third page
it talks about the fact that this is an
optional voluntary prophylactic use of
ivermectin offered to patients during
medical visits in other words it's not
randomized
that's not a good way to do a drug study
so you know you can read through all of
it it looks really impressive but it's
not got good data
so currently the best i will it's not
too much longer currently the best
available evidence doesn't show that
ivermectin is effective against covet 19
and there are numerous ongoing clinical
trials the infectious disease society of
america does recommend the use of
ivermectin only in the context of
clinical trials until we have better
data
the point is a standing order with a
pharmacist should never be used for
medications being used for indications
that are not clearly supported by the
best available medical evidence
ivermectin doesn't reach this level as a
result the bill should be voted itl or
if it goes forward the standing order
should include a disclosure that the
best available evidence does not support
its use for covid
i do want to take a moment though just
to reflect on some of the things that
were stated
by
dr merrick
he commented about the vares reports and
the 20 000 people died
those of you been around here for a
while know that the vares is a reporting
system
of any adverse effect
you are required to report any death
regardless of whether it is causal so if
i get in a vaccine and i get run over by
a car two days later and somebody knows
about it that must be reported
if you look at the disclaimer on this on
the cdc site it says very clearly that a
report in varus does not indicate that
it is causally related
coincidentally related not causally
they do look at this data that's how we
found out about the blood clots and some
of the other things that had to do with
the j and j
but that is a misrepresentation and the
reflection on masks
made a comment about the dead space and
and so on i'm sorry i'm a surgeon i
spent my whole time wearing masks
other than maybe being short and turning
out to be a democrat it didn't have any
ill effects on me so the bottom line
yes the bottom line is that if you look
at the masks the area underneath this
the dead space is about 5 ml the
anatomic dead space in my pharynx and
trachea and bronchioles is about 150 ml
so it's an increase of only three
percent
many of us have gone snorkeling put a
snorkel in your mouth you had a dead
space that's about 150 mils it doesn't
kill you
so the comment that masking
causes problems
with co2 has not been demonstrated
um i would just simply take those couple
of thoughts
and
as you think about those thoughts
when we look at the testimony that we
heard earlier and i'm sorry to have to
say that but those were really not
correct
thank you thank you representative
representative delemus
having to use a microphone is kind of
not something that happens to me
okay
so
i'm i'm just looking at this copic 19
safety of ivermectin um
flccc alliance report
are you are you saying
that the ivermectin for covet 19 that
the 71 trials the 675 scientists the fif
the 50 180 patients the 31 ram
randomized control trials with 83
improvement in 16 prophylactics trials
the 66 percent improvement the 34
improvement 32 improvement all of that
is false is is that is that what i'm
hearing you say i don't like to use the
word false but is it in error do you
think it's error i would not necessarily
use that but is it valid data i just
went through for example taking this one
and showing where it's not really a
well-designed study i talked about the
one that was sent by bryant which shows
that it's really very low evidence
i actually put a lot of my stock in the
work that was done by the cochran group
the cochrane group has been around for
decades doing uh meta-analyses of any
number of things and they are quite
independent so we don't have to worry
about its political with the fda or the
cdc or nih or anything like that
and they did go through all those and
many of these studies are small they're
poorly controlled they have uh end
points that are not well defined
and those things simply make them not
good data you have to remember that
there was a giant push to publish a lot
of stuff a lot of stuff got published
that was not necessary i hate to use the
word false that would imply deception
though there are a few that have been
found to be truly fraudulent with uh
manufactured data but some of them are
just simply not studies that are very
valid it takes a lot of sophistication
to understand levels of evidence it
takes a lot of training and that's
that's what the concord collaboration
does and that's also what the cdc did
and so on
follow up thank you sir
uh so 50
180 patients is small
is that small well actually i don't have
that in front of me right now but i'd
have to look again
you can't just well that's just a simple
question
but it depends on this depends on the
how the study was done
i mean the other their study here which
is
a large study with uh
223 000 citizens
but it's not randomized in drug trials
there's not a lot of reason to accept
non-randomized data
so numbers alone don't make it matter
study design is a very important issue
in understanding anything
in science
so that's what i mean there's a level of
sophistication that comes in to
understand
how the study is designed what the
control groups are how it's validated
what's how's the randomization done i
mean because just saying we'll take the
first 150 people in this group the next
150 that's not valid it needs to be a
randomization so there's a lot of things
that take a high level of skill to
analyze
one more follow-up i'm sorry thank you
mr chairman
um well right here it says over the past
three decades approximately 3.7 billion
doses of ivermectin have been
distributed and they've proven to be
anti-parasitic as well as antiviral is
that a small group
i think you'd have to think about the
fact that that's over a period of time
long long time before covet it's being
used for perfectly appropriate
indications of treating parasites so
it's isn't hasn't been around forever
no
that's why i'm discussing the fact
that's why i'm discussing the fact that
it has to do with the indications for
sorry the data for a specific indication
nobody says ivermectin's a bad drug it's
a great drug for the right indication
thank you representative merchant
thank you mr chair
mr chairman and also representative
think of my question
first and foremost i am not a physician
i'd end up becoming a democrat but it
wasn't because my height
could have been part of it
but in saying that
i'm not here to debate the efficacy of
the drug on an indication
but i would like us to consider
with this information which i have not
had a chance to validate
on the bidgy access
that in fact if the data in here is able
to be substantiated
and we look at the number of deaths that
occurred from ibmectin
compared to some of the over counter
drugs we have in this country
is this possibly a safer drug in some of
the other over-the-counter drugs that we
have
and therefore if it is my question would
be
what's the downside if a patient takes
it if it doesn't work
well that's that's a wonderful question
and we know that for example even just
uh anti-inflammatories cholera people
with bleeding
so if you've used an anti-inflammatory
for it as a you know usual indication of
treating somebody as arthritis that
would probably be good but if you're
using the anti-inflammatory to treat
something where there's absolutely no
data it helps then that benefit risk
benefit analysis isn't favorable um one
might even argue that the
anti-inflammatory for arthritis that
risk benefit analysis may be a little
bit funny too but the bottom line is we
sometimes have very toxic drugs we use
with people but it's for incredibly good
effect and then we have ones that have a
fairly low risk profile
but that doesn't mean that it's
effective as far as
what might happen if a person takes a
drug for which there is no indication
they also may not seek appropriate care
and that can be a bit of a problem and
that was when the issues with laetrile
is that people go and get treated with
laetrile for something rather than
getting appropriate care that actually
had better evidence
follow-up
thank you mr chairman and also thank you
for taking the poll
again getting away from the efficacy
side of the equation and i'd understand
it with somebody taking leotil
postponing other therapy but many times
people took leah trill also took the
same regimens they just augmented the
regiment that we normally would have
with the hopes it would actually provide
some additional benefit
the same thing with the mectin if the
drug is actually safe okay isn't it
really up to the patient to determine
whether they want medical advice or not
at that point in time as long as the
drug that we're allowing them to have
access to
is not going to be detrimental to their
health it may not help them because of
the efforts they were talking about but
the downside to it is really not there
i do agree though again that i said the
risk profile is inappropriate doses
rather low it's really a pretty safe
drug
um my concern is more people not seeking
appropriate care and perhaps being
treated by something that's really not
working that's more my concern for that
thank you
co-sponsors of the bill may not ask
questions
however representative canuck and i
developed a workaround on that didn't we
we used to write the questions for the
other one to ask so move next to
somebody and
i will do
for you what representative webber did
for me when she was in the chair that's
by the way you're right jerry that's why
they say that's why they don't let us
sit together anymore anymore yeah
uh representative acton
thank you mr chair
um
india thank you for taking my question
doctor
in in your knowledge has there ever been
a um a precedent like this set where a
the pharmacy would not allow
the pers
the prescription to be filled when a
doctor writes the prescription
that's really not what we're talking
about that was the previous bill this
this is asking about a standing order
and that's why i said that explicitly
that i don't think this bill should be
passed because it establishes a standing
order for something where the data is
not that clear and a stating order is
something that we've used before like on
oral contraceptives something that has a
very long standing track record and is
highly effective and that's why we were
comfortable going ahead and passing that
but
because this is about a standing order
and i think that it is
again i would love it if iver mechton
worked i don't have any i don't have any
negative feelings about evermakton i
just simply would like to see the data
real data and i think that until we have
that real data a standing order is not a
good option
one follow-up
um i'm not exactly sure what a standing
order is can you take a step back and
fill me in i just i don't know exactly
what it is according to this bill would
be any uh aprn or uh physician i think
if i remember right those of the two
groups can write an order which then
goes to the pharmacist where it's on
record and then if a person comes in and
says that they wish to have that drug
the pharmacist can do a short screen and
some counseling uh although again if any
of it's been in a pharmacy you know
they're rather busy they don't have a
lot of time to spend on all that and
they don't have your medical record and
then they will fill the order based upon
that standing order so you don't go see
your this had to do with i think a
comment that was asked earlier about
cutting out the physician and the
counseling because you're not going to
the physician or or aprn and being
counseled about it and then getting a
prescription then going to get it filled
instead what you're doing is you are
going straight to the pharmacist to get
that
prescription filled based on a protocol
okay thank you sure
representative snow
very naive question
right now we have instructions
that came from somewhere
to doctors not to write prescriptions
for either whatever the medicine
but instead we're going to have standing
orders placed with drug stores to let
them give it out to anybody that walks
in and asked for it right
what would be wrong with just changing
this bill to say that doctors
could not be prohibited
from writing prescriptions
for ivermectin
wasn't that accomplish the same thing
then it's the doctor's decision along
with the pharmacist but who gets what
that that is basically the
the
contents of the previous bill we heard
that had to do with off-label
prescribing which is but there has been
no guidance given i uh that i i mean i
get all the health alert network things
nobody has said you can't write for
ivermecton we know that there may be
certain uh
health care places that might do
something like that but there's been
nothing that's come down from
not saying not to do it if you look at
the cdc it says there is no evidence it
can be used but it should be used in a
clinical trial
but are we not correct haven't we heard
testimony that people walk into drug
stores
with a prescription from a doctor
and they're told that they cannot
do they cannot fill those prescriptions
is that not a fact
all right am i wrong again that is the
that is uh related to a different bill
not to this bill so we probably
shouldn't spend too much time on it um i
do not know whether pharmacists have
been uh forbidden to fill that or not
perhaps uh representative merchant would
know just a smidge more about that than
i
i have a great idea
let's ask a pharmacist
that's why he's here
thank you mr chairman
in regards to the issue with pharmacies
first of all it's a pharmacist that
dispenses if not a pharmacy i want to
make that clear
number two a lot of times it comes down
to is the employer because of the
political
policy polarization of this process must
be political
a lot of corporations have elected not
to stock the drug in the pharmacy so
even if the pharmacist wanted to
dispense it to a patient
which is a professional preview on a
valid prescription from a physician
because the owner of the pharmacy
refuses the stock the product in the
pharmacy
that takes it out of the hand of the
pharmacist because it's not available
obviously you can't dispense it
thank you for answering for me
that's what we do here
yes representative leon
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question um
when you're discussing the quality of
evidence there's there's definitely some
important points to notice um obviously
i understand why you have concern about
the efficacy data when you're when
you're doing a meta-analysis of so many
small studies
however
in my experience evaluating clinical
trials
i have never seen a problem before where
if there's a signa
significant safety signal that this type
of
vast data
would not show a safety signal
so when you have no safety signal and
we're looking at a model
that is based off of oral contraceptives
that have a strong safety signal they
can be lethal to some women
i guess i'm trying to understand
why
we'd want to prohibit patients trying a
therapy when they're only now told to go
home and wait until you can't breathe
when
we can debate the efficacy based on the
quality of clinical data
but
there's nothing i don't see much to
debate on the safety so i'm trying to
understand why why you're against this
choice uh well as i said i i don't have
there is not a strong safety signal i
agree with that 100
this is a relatively benign drug the
issue is is it is it to have benefit the
risks are small but you still want to
have a decent benefit to justify the use
of any medication
if i could follow up follow up um and
then my follow-up is right now the
treatment alternative is either for some
people pavloxid but people with atrial
fibrillation have strong
contraindications it takes a month to
get amiodarone out of the cardigan
tissue so they can't switch over um
there's the if they're going to die
they'll be dead before then and then
other people look at the safety signal
and when they're looking at staying home
watching netflix and hoping they can
keep breathing
and going to an overloaded hospital full
of people that had nothing except for
rest as therapy
i'm trying to understand why people
should be denied
a clear path to a therapeutic that shows
a signal of efficacy
very little safety risk
and could benefit overall health by
reducing the burden on our hospitals
which are overloaded for a couple
different reasons
um
you know i mean
i guess
the the difficulty i've got here is just
simply
that
what i said earlier i think that may
well okay i'll be a little more blunt
some people seem to be relying on this
as an option rather than for example
getting vaccinated that does have
a good evidence that it's helpful and i
would think that that would probably be
a more reasonable option and likewise
they may not seek other treatment which
may be a problem there there are other
treatments that are now available they
weren't there before i agree
sorry last follow-up um we're seeing
that there's still a large risk of
contracting covid even with the vaccine
80 percent of people are catching
omicron and the relative risk of death
from vaccinated to the unvaccinated
before they ended the trial early was it
cut the risk of death in half
you can run the numbers whichever way
you want but when it's two versus one it
cuts the risk in half
i guess i'm trying to understand why
those aren't complementary for those
people who are going to make whichever
choice they want
nobody's being forced to take the
ivormectin and i don't think people
choosing that are really basing their
vaccine choice off of whether or not
they can get a valid prescription for
iberomectin
representative folsom
thank you and we're actually starting to
testify something yeah yeah yeah i know
i was wondering if that was a question
but
but representative land always makes
excellent points so
um
thank you for taking my question um and
i'll make it a question
should people who
are advised by their physicians
not to get
the
vaccine shots of whichever company
and that it would be contra it would
just be a really bad situation based on
their medical
files
and conditions and
would it be
best if that doctor then could say
you know we can't give you the vaccine
but
why don't you try ivermectin
i think that's an interesting question
because we don't you know the person
doesn't have
sorry i'm following up sorry because the
person doesn't have the option of taking
the the vaccine
we're buddies now um and so
our options are limited and i'm gonna
people who do that want to go get
everything they possibly can
i think that would be a wonderful study
and i think that should be done in a
study protocol i would i would firmly
support that
what if that person what if that person
contracts covid before the study's done
always a risk i'm not quite sure the how
to answer that for you
but i think i've taken much more time
than i should so i want to thank you and
in terms of your comments earlier about
what chronic mask wearing
did to you
i just want you to know that many of my
good friends are
short
right
and actually i didn't start wearing a
mask until i had supposedly finished my
longitudinal growth which actually i
don't think ever occurred so
thank you
that was just an attempt at some humor
it's getting late we needed something it
is
okay humor is always allowed in this
committee
i'd like to call on the honorable linda
ray camarata to come on up and uh
chairman i just want to let you know
that i haven't seen one person wipe
microphone down after each use
and i'm not going to start
sorry it's late we're getting tired my
name is linda ray camarata i'm a
registered nurse actually one person did
but go ahead oh all right i stand
corrected um i did send to you the
committee thank you committee members
for your time and service
i did send my testimony and i'm
i know that i'm being timed so
um thank you for allowing me to testify
i'm familiar with standing orders and
believe pharmacists
are as well a physician or an advanced
practice registered nurse must write the
prescription for the standing order
before a patient has
access
to the medication our current state of
affairs has interfered with the honored
patient physician relationship
in that doctors are pressured with
disciplinary action if certain drugs
are prescribed never in my nursing
career and it's i've been around
have i witnessed such censorship of
free-flowing discussion and debate on
appropriate treatments as i have seen
with
the 2020 covid19 arrival
the closest degree of censorship
that i've witnessed was during the 1980s
hiv epidemic so it brings that back to
mind to me
american sense something is amiss real
scientific research demands open debate
by many credentialed scientists and
physicians but this has not but this has
been
severely curtailed in america and
worldwide why
over time it may be revealed that there
are underlying stakeholders whose
interests are not in the best interests
of society
never was i so disappointed and i might
have mentioned this to you last week
in the medical establishment as when i
visited my wonderful physician last fall
i point blank asked him
if a prescription for the fda approved
drug ivermectin would be prescribed off
label if he would do that if i were to
become ill with covet 19
after an awkward moment of silence and
it was a pretty long moment
my trusted physician shared that
disciplinary action was threatened by
the physicians association board
the physician declined due to the threat
of losing his license to practice
medicine as a former girl scout i always
have to prepare for the unexpected there
is a worldwide network of scientists and
physicians who are courageous enough
we saw one or two today
to help people reduce their risk of
serious complications from cobit 19
by sharing early treatment protocols one
element of that early treatment one
is
ivermectin
i had to go outside in new hampshire to
secure a legal ivermectin prescription
and fill the prescription at a local
pharmacy
last october i became ill with coven i
had already taken vitamin c d3 and zinc
i added the short-term ivermectin to my
early treatment program and avoided
serious illness
and hospitalization isn't that our goal
please vote ought to pass on this bill
thank you
i will take questions if there are any
thank you thank you representative the
chair calls courtney tanner from
dartmouth hitchcock
thank you chairman pearson and members
of the committee my name is courtney
tanner i'm the director of government
relations at dartmouth-hitchcock
and passing around coming around right
now is a letter of in opposition to
house bill 1022
it's co-authored by
dr michael calderwood our chief quality
officer at dartmouth hitchcock medical
center
and stacy herman who's our chief
pharmacy officer of dartmouth hitchcock
health
first i'd like to just note that the cdc
fda nih and idsa do not recommend using
ibermectin for the treatment of cobit
outside of clinical trials
fortunately right now the fda has
granted emergency use authorization for
two
anti-viral medications
but ivermectin is not one of them
we have some questions when it comes to
the bill
first there's a question of necessity
when it comes to this bill
if a provider can write forever mectin
right now
is this uh billness
is there a necessity for this bill
a couple of logistics questions
um who would write for the standing
order
is it the state's chief medical officer
or a chief medical officer of a hospital
or healthcare system that's just not
answered in the bill
finally
the purpose of a standing order is to
increase access to care for patients
and we have a couple of standing orders
as has been noted in the state right now
and those
medications are to benefit the general
public
and if ivermectin is not a standing
order right now um we believe that it's
it isn't in the best interest of the of
the public to um
to
to establish a standing order for this
medication
so that concludes my testimony uh
charlemagne pearson i'm happy to any
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
coming to testify and waiting so long
with our long bill
my question is about the availability of
prescribers to to write prescriptions
for ivermectin
is dartmouth-hitchcock allowing
providers to write those prescriptions
and is there any guidelines or any other
encouragement or discouragement
happening
i have not seen uh internal policies
relative to ivermecton i can certainly
get the answer to that representative
glenn and get back to you i'd be happy
to do that thank you and if i can have
one follower um and are you aware that
without an fda approval for an
indication nobody can make a positive
recommendation for the use of a
therapeutic so a neutral response such
as the nih going from do not use to a no
position is as positive a recommendation
as any of these societies can have
i am not a clinician i'm an attorney by
training so i i'm i can't speak to that
thank you i have a question um i'm just
a liberal arts guy so humor me and help
me here but um
it seems that the vaccines
were and this is not a dirty word
rushed
warped speeded sped
because we got a pandemic on
and the leisure of allowing long trials
we just didn't have
and so
if there's not the usual depth of study
in order to get the vaccines why now
suddenly
is it wrong
to have ivermectin
uh so i can't again i can't speak to
that i'm not a clinician um at the cdc
it's my understanding that the cdc uh
would
believes that it would be permissible to
use ivermectin within a clinical trial
um but not outside of a clinical trial
well the vaccines and boosters that i've
gotten i don't think were clinical
trials i think it was fast and dirty
and i looked at the odds and that's what
i chose to do but it was fast and dirty
and
we don't know if down the road there's
going to be contra indications of
something that's new but we do know
ivermectin does not seem to be
as
troublesome so i i just don't i it looks
like there's two different standards
could you could you help this liberal
arts guy work through it
i i again i'm not a clinician so i can't
um i can't speak to the the uh clinical
trial process what i can say is that
there certainly are a lot of questions
when it comes to coping 19 and um it's
there are risk factors that we're all
juggling i have a two-year-old that's
not yet vaccine eligible and so um
certainly certainly juggling a lot of
risks right now thank you thank you so
much
treya recognizes our old not old in the
sense of elderly but our dear that's it
our dear friend upon a minute paula
minihan
who's not old
but dear
i think
the number is now two because czech say
it did that too
i have plenty
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee for the record paula
minihan senior vice president state
government relations for the new
hampshire hospital association
the hospital association is opposed to
house bill 2 10 22
and we have consulted with all our
hospital pharmacy directors as well and
they are all expressing strong
opposition to this
allowing this drug to be used in this
manner and the chief medical officers at
our hospitals and clinical leaders have
expressed similar concerns
i will not reiterate what has been
stated and was
i think done very effectively by dr um
kanerk but
again the cdc the fda
nih as well as other federal agencies do
not believe that ivmectin is recommended
or they indicated that it is not
recommended to treat cope at 19.
um and again it it requires clinical
trials um they are currently assessing
ivamectin tablets for the prevention or
treatment of covid is ongoing i have
attached some documentation from the cdc
i think there are again some issues with
um
the bill that have been stated by others
relative to we don't understand exactly
how the standing order would work
and i believe that there are many new
hampshire health care professionals some
that will be testifying today and others
that had to submit their testimony
in opposition to this bill
besides like i said we do have questions
about the standing order we are opposed
to this and on behalf of our hospitals
we urge you to find
house bill 1022 in expedient to
legislate thank you would you take some
questions yes of course
thank you mr chairman i used to be an
analyst i'm full of questions
thank you for taking the question
um right now we're at a very interesting
point where where there's more debate
about science than we've ever had in the
past which is good
unfortunately there's some growing
distrust
i was curious if you could tell us if
there's any any extra financial bonuses
or any extra
payment that comes to our hospital
systems for certain treatments or
certain indications during this pandemic
i'm not sure i completely understand
your question but we have been asked
this um different ways
what um is cor is accurate um there's
been some mis understanding i think
relative to um payments for medicare
they provide a um add-on
payment
if um the individual has a coveted
diagnosis and with the understanding
that that is intended it does not cover
but it intended to cover
some of the additional costs associated
with treating covid patients including
all the ppe etc that is required
to safely care for them so
that is medicare only it is a small
amount it is nothing that has been
that is anywhere near covering the cost
because coveted patients unfortunately
some
are in the hospital for a very long
length of stay when they are
diagnosed and then they're trying to
recover
so they continue to be in the hospital i
did want to also say for the record
that neil meehan the chief physician
executive
for exeter hospital is going to be
submitting information to the
committee
they just did not have an opportunity to
submit it um before the hearing but that
will be coming um he is opposed as well
to the to the bill
would you like to follow up yes please
mr chairman
thank you and then my follow-up is just
are the hospitals still being overrun
with patients and would it be helpful to
have more options to divert them before
they need hospitalization
the hospitals are
overwhelmed by
many patients not just covet patients um
i don't have the i do have the number
today um i think it's 400 hold on i had
it earlier sorry um
there are as of last night 409 patients
with covid in the hospital another 147
recovering as i indicated
after you after i think 21 days they now
are considered cover recovering if they
are still in the hospital because they
don't technically have coveted but
they're still very sick
sixteen are in the emergency rooms
waiting to be admitted
um and another statistic that i think is
important for the record of those there
are um
unvaccinated um admissions 43.5
fully vaccinated 22 percent partially
vaccinated 20
unknown 13.9 percent
and um i just thought that was important
for the record because i think that was
another um misstatement that was um
stated recently representative merchant
thank you mr chairman paulus good to see
you nice to see you
in regards to the hospital emissions the
409 are those patients active with covet
or once they become no longer active in
their recovery
they move off to 409 so therefore the
409 is only the ones with active covet
not those who've been admitted to the
hospital still there because they had a
coveted infection
they are active admissions right now 409
the 147 are the recovered yep so you've
got to add those two together plus the
16 waiting to be admitted thank you
at the hospital yes to answer
representative leon's question the
hospitals are overwhelmed with patients
but um covered and and non-covet
patients that unfortunately um due to
some of the issues that uh we had to
reduce the number the
elective surgeries last year that
unfortunately patients were had delayed
their care and now they are much sicker
and now in the hospital so
but
they are our healthcare heroes and they
are working
tirelessly to take care of patients
the chair recognizes the moving closer
to the microphone representative delemus
for one question with no follow-up thank
you mr chairman
thank you for taking my time
apparently according to vigil access
which is tm the world health
organization the fda and merck
ivermectin um since 1992 adverse events
5840 coveted
vaccines 2878
362.
so
my question is
why would there be this
adversity
uh for people trying taking ivermectin
since it seems to be less dangerous than
taking aspirin as opposed to
vaccines and i'm not saying people
shouldn't take vaccines that should be
completely up to a person but my
question is
why would such an extremely
small number i mean 20 deaths as opposed
to 14
774 deaths with vaccines why would there
be any pushback on people being able to
get ivermectin i think um dr kenorick
answered it better but also i think the
denominator is very important i don't
know how many people have
taken ivermectin but a lot more people i
suspect have received the covet 19
vaccine worldwide
and again
if it's not efficacious then it it does
not make sense for a doctor to prescribe
it because they are trying to help their
patients so that's the problem is it is
not recommended for for treatment of
covid and that is
that's until the clinical trials are
completed
um that is
the
the recommendation and the guidance from
the federal um
the federal agencies thank you sure
thank you very much miss minihan now
here's the deal yes it's ten past five
we're closing at 5 30 or we'll be locked
in for the night and you'll be subject
to 14 hours of politics
no
you cannot have your teddy bear and
you'll miss your tv shows and there's no
food
so
all the um representatives who have
signed up have spoken all but one of we
could call representatives from agencies
or call them lobbyists all but one have
spoken
all doctors have spoken
i do very much one in the 20 minutes
that are left to hear from as many of
the population the folks us you guys as
we possibly can
so i'm going to ask you to come up and
talk for two minutes and i mean two
minutes you can tell us what you're
about no long stories
we've got to get this finished but i
want to hear from you folks
so first folk up is aaron fallon from
wolfeboro
thank you everyone for staying and being
here um
just a side note
my colleague is genetically tested so he
can safely take over back to for
heartworm
regarding this whole process
i remember in 2010 and 2011 being here
talking to the people that were setting
our guidelines for lime treatment
making lime treatment safe
for people to heal in new hampshire
we're back to the same principle
making possibilities safe for people to
heal in new hampshire
i can tell you antidotal stories that
don't amount to jack squat
i can tell you that we do
want people to heal and we want them to
have opportunities to heal and we've
heard today that there's a very very low
risk profile and a high
profile
of
improvement with ivermectin to keep
people out of the hospital i'm here with
my knee brace because my knee surgery
has been canceled three times so far
and my life is being limited
i would like myself and everyone else
who's looking for appropriate medical
care that our hospital systems
should be offering to sustain life and
to create vitality to be available to
every citizen of new hampshire thank you
thank you so much any questions
next up is theresa grinnell
and in the on deck circle is david
dewitt
teresa
she's gone
david dewitt
with ed groves in the on deck circle
mr chairman and committee
i'm going to read what i submitted to
you
i'm 75 years old and relatively good
health and fully vaccinated with modern
at two shots plus modernity booster i'm
not a non-vaxxer
i've been following the imas plus home
treatment protocol provided by flccc
since the beginning of january 2022
i have
i've i'm having no problem following the
immune the immune fortifying supportive
therapy portion of the protocol since
all five of the medications which are
mostly vitamins and so forth that dr
merrick mentioned are over the counter
and relatively inexpensive
if i begin to
experience symptoms i want to be able to
add in my wife by the way i want to be
able to add the antiviral portion using
ivermectin my physician in my hospital
only offer monoclonal antibody treatment
to hopefully prevent hospitalization
however i prefer to use ivermectin in
the hopes of beating the virus in the
first five to seven days and not
requiring antibody treatment or
hospitalization
i also checked with my pharmacy and was
advised that they will not fill a
doctor's prescription for ivermectin
as part of a covit 19 treatment protocol
i'm assuming the reason why ivormecne is
being withheld due to the cdc advisory
which other people have talked about and
i gave you a copy with my
presentation
i've attached a copy of this oh yeah i'm
not qualified to comment medically or
scientifically on that advisory
others who are qualified find the
advisory to be premature ill-advised and
misleading in the light of a pandemic
which is killing many americans every
day
like today
while proven home treatments are ignored
delayed or otherwise presented from use
in a recent new book and this is a new
new book
i'd advise everybody to take a look at
it if you can get one
it's called overcoming the cove of
darkness how two doctors successfully
treated seven thousand patients it was
written by doctors brian tyson and
george fareed and i want to mention that
george fareed testified to the united
states senate
the and this is well i'm going to skip
that because you can read it you've got
30 more seconds sir okay the treatments
used by these two heroic physicians
included either hydroxychloroquine or
ivermectin doctors tyson and fareed
stand together with many other doctors
and health professionals around the
world saving lives and similar treatment
protocols the fda cdc dr fauci and
president biden's covet task force will
not give these life-saving examples of
pre-treatment the light of day
these examples are being carried out by
highly experienced physicians and
scientists the fact that these
procedures have been ignored withheld
and vilified defies long-established
scientific problem-solving methods
common sense and any semblance of
compassion for the patients and their
doctors thank you sir thank you so much
mr dewitt
ed groves
thank you sir and thank you all for
allowing me to speak here
um i'm not a doctor but i have been
following this for two years since this
whole
pandemic started
and
people have mentioned treatments no
treatments what's going on you get
covert go home sit around for 14 days
and i hope you feel better and then if
you don't you get thrown in the hospital
we got to follow
there's a reason why ivermectin is not
being used here
and it's i'm surprised it has been
brought up once yet but it's just follow
the money
you know doctor from virginia mentioned
that it's two three cents a pill
it's cheap it's a third world country
drug that has done so much good since
1987. it's fda approved
the minister here used it i used it i'm
one of the nut jobs that hangs out in
front of the state house on saturdays on
new year's day we had a big rally
next day i was tested positive for cobit
i start my my uh
hydroxychloroquine
my ivermectin vitamin d zinc i don't
know the exact milligrams i think the
zinc was 40 milligrams my vitamin d
and my tumeric
uh sunday night so that was like the
second i spiked the temp of 103 felt
like crap body aches i'm 58 years old
went to bed got up monday didn't feel so
good either kept kept the same regimen
going tuesday uh
three in the morning sweat woke up felt
miserable went back to sleep got up and
here i was everything gone
ivormectin works it it's
they mentioned the um
little state little 220 million person
state u-t-t-a-r-p-r-a-d-e-s-h
is the india indian state that has been
using this stuff
for over a year on september 17th
india that state declared that they have
basically eliminated this disease look
that up look up doctors
peter mcculloch and doctors robert
malone 30 seconds
please i can't tell you everything that
dr cushman up there she mentioned that
that look that up look these doctors up
there's so much you guys can be heroes
okay i'm assuming the people wearing the
masks are the ones that don't want this
approved
nobody that spoke up against this gave
any other really solid reasons this is
this is safe
okay and the last thing i want to say is
i'm getting tired of every single day
this president of the united states
begging us to get vaccinated and telling
us how safe it is thank you mr grover
appreciate your
coming to speak to us ken
erin is it e-y
ken had to leave next
heather
mullen marlins yeah
thank you so much i was hoping you'd get
me in here
okay so i'm actually an investigative
reporter and i work for a national
network so i've actually been very
fortunate to have been able to spend a
considerable amount of time into
investigating the pandemic interviewing
doctors patients you name it over the
last
two years
one thing i want to talk about that
hasn't been brought up is the censorship
of this information
so several people that have got up here
have made you know some assertions that
the data is not there i can assure you
the data is there but there are groups
that are trying to keep you
from accessing the data on ivermectin
um and i can take it back to 2020 when i
actually had kovid before there ever was
a vaccine there was actually a group on
facebook that had hundreds of thousands
of people who had
been considered coveted survivors and
they were all in this group sharing
treatment specifically
hydroxychloroquine
that group one day when it reached just
about a million people was instantly
removed by facebook
a little background for you
facebook in uh february of 2020 when
this pandemic kicked off started having
this sort of fact check program right uh
many people don't know that uh thompson
reuters is one of the biggest fact
checkers for facebook that go and censor
medical misinformation well the ceo and
founder of uh
thompson reuters is also on the board
for pfizer so there's a little bit of a
conflict of interest when you have
the
board of director for pfizer censoring
medical information specifically stories
pertaining to hydroxychloroquine and
ivermectin so that data is not being
allowed to circulate on social media
platforms as well as media networks how
often do you turn on good morning
america and it said this segment is
brought to you by pfizer there's another
conflict of interest so you have these
big organizations and big pharma
companies keeping you guys from the
actual information that you should see
um regarding ivermectin and
hydroxychloroquine um there have been
studies and i'm more than happy to send
you this but i actually just found out
about this hearing yesterday night i got
in at like two in the morning and i was
like this is so important because i want
to thank each and every one of you
because regardless of your political
affiliation this medicine can save you
and your family members and i cannot
stress that enough thank you so much you
guys need to you know thank you so much
diligence and research thank you so much
and please send us that stuff
i would like that you're like a point of
contact where i can get one email if you
can sort of like
yep yep check with somebody thank you
clara symbolisti did i say it right yes
you did wow
but i did provide you with the planet
you oh
okay my name is claris and listi thank
you for letting me speak i live in
rochester i'm here speaking in support
of the bill just last week project
veritas released important documents
revealing the truth about how this
mysterious virus came into being among
those documents was a significant report
by major joseph p murphy who as a darpa
fellow was able to collect and analyze
documents can mean conveniently hidden
from site his analysis noted the
important role of ivermectin in the
treatment of covid19
now that was all about you can actually
read the echo health
alliance proposal that darpa rejected
because it involved gain of function
it involved not looking at any of the
ethical type of things involved
there was a whole host of things that it
did not do that darpa said no
but tony
uh fauci
niaid in the nih approved it and went
forward with it you can read the entire
thing so you know what's going on
anyway you and
the virus actually was a vaccine
produced for bats that was the intention
it was aerolocized on purpose so that
they could spray it into bat caves
anyway here is
what um
major murphy had ma had to say
the team meaning the the proposal the
alliance the team selected sarsar kovis
that were most monoclonal antibody and
vaccine resistant
it is not practical to inoculate bats
directly with shots nor can bats get
respiratory infections from droplets so
the team developed an aerosol to deliver
the inoculations directly to the caves
to ensure it worked well they developed
the aerosol against
masks civets
the proposal
notes that interferon rem desevere and
chloroquine phosphate inhibits sars cov
viral replication so the proposal by
echo health noted that those things are
effective 30 seconds because it is now
known
nature
that the sars-kobe's illness is readily
resolved with early treatments that
inhibit the viral replication that
spreads the spike proteins around the
body which induce a harmful overactive
immune response as the body tries to
clear the spikes from the ac2 receptors
many of the early treatment protocols
ignored by the authorities work because
they inhibit viral replication
or modulate the immune response to the
spike proteins which makes sense within
the context of what echo health was
creating thank you so much for your
testimony i really appreciate it we now
have karen sweeting
thank you mr chairman thank you all the
members of the committee
i'm here representing myself and my
husband we live up in the lakes region i
also have been a
consultant with pharmaceutical companies
and with calling on hematologists and
oncologists for 18 years
so as far as this potential
bill being put forward i support it i
think it's very important for
i would say one website that you could
go to is
covid.daystar.com that has multiple
interviews with multiple experts
including including peter mccullough
and
you know the gentleman from district 3
talked about conflict of interest and
you know i feel for for um i thank you
all for your service and i know everyone
is wanting to do the right thing whether
you're a pharmacist or a physician
but i think we really need the truth is
what sets us free right we live with the
model here live free or die and that's
all i can hope is that truth comes to
the surface
dr fauci actually has royalties and
investments with the moderna patent so
when you talk about conflict of interest
for rem desevier to be the protocol and
for physicians to be penalized for
writing a prescription for a medication
that could potentially help patients
beat this for early treatment it's just
it's mind-blowing to me what's happening
in our country
and we don't want any of our family or
friends to pass from this disease but we
also want to make sure that we help them
get the protocols that are necessary
for them to not face this disgusting
disease so i'm in support of this bill
thank you time i appreciate you're
welcome thank you for your time i have a
card from i think it's pam d
napoli
do i have it right from
manchester ash street
all right
okay the next card i have is i was just
handed one from dr nicole schnell from
stratham is that you
it's not stratum
okay and you're a doctor
okay i must have missed the last name
chertoff
that was not even close thank you
um
this is on then okay
thank you everybody um i was just it's
been a long day i appreciate your
attention just for two more minutes
um i'm dr nicole chartel i've been a
licensed naturopathic medical doctor in
new hampshire for over a decade
i'm a unh alumni
and i later earned my doctorate from the
southwest college of naturopathic
medicine where i was trained to provide
integrative primary care
which is within the scope in arizona in
new hampshire we're considered
specialists
i'm a program director for two
accredited postgraduate resident
training programs from within my private
medical practice and our group practice
has four nds a nurse practitioner and
two registered nurses um our approach is
always to treat things naturally and as
safely as possible and um
when covet happened
my patients turned to me
um
to to look for some other solution
because the cdc's
website titled what to do if you get
sick offers the following home treatment
protocol recommendations
quarantine rest hydrate take
acetaminophen as needed and call a
doctor if you have trouble breathing
that's it
when the pandemic hit my patients
drove me to begin researching heavily
and i wanted to understand not just
um
medications and supplements that might
work on prior
viruses similar to this but also um
how the virus worked the pathology and
um without getting into any more i do
believe in ivermectin i'll leave it at
that okay
this conversation has been very
enlightening i really have enjoyed being
here and hearing both sides
i don't think it comes down to a debate
about like
whether we're going to get this fda
approved right now right i think that
what we have to look at is is it safe
it sounds like it's going to be safe as
long as um
sorry distracted it will be safe i've
heard
um as long as there's absolutely
um
as long as we can't show that there's
absolutely no benefit that's what i
heard today
if i was clear it's safe as long as we
can show that there's
no risk no harm no harm
um
we've all been here for six hours on low
blood sugar right now
um so
if if
the research
shows that there's absolutely no benefit
then the doctors here aren't in favor
of you've got 15 seconds okay of having
ivermectin
being used in the state here
let's just agree now there is some
evidence that shows that it it can work
to some degree
if i'm on my deathbed and you tell me
that i can take ivermectin and maybe
have a 10
chance of living
more give it to me
i don't have time to wait for a research
study to get approved it's safe it's fda
approved already
this medication that just got approved
tax libid
530 unless the government pays for it
right so okay
thank you that's it thank you dr soloway
you have a question uh yes thank you mr
chairman dr chartel thank you so much
for your patience in being here it's
clear that you have ample training and i
suspect you have a fair amount of
scientific training as well in fact i'm
quite positive of that
um
do you trust
the recommendations and the data that
are coming out of the fda
um
well i
i think that there is a
uh there's a large group of doctors
right now that have written to the fda
and ask them to clarify if they've
actually looked at all the research
and how well they've analyzed it so i
don't feel confident that
they have
they can prove that there's no benefit
okay
thank you dr schutel and thank you so
much for coming today
okay thank you to those who have not
been called upon
please send us
your testimony through email
we'd like to read it we apologize that
you weren't heard today i would ask the
committee to give me two minutes at the
end for a necessary procedure
with this i bring to the close the
hearing on house bill 1022
i open the hearing on house bill 1045
and it will be postponed to a later date
and i close that hearing
i open the hearing on house bill 1369
and it will be postponed to a later date
i now close that hearing we are now
finished for the day thank you
and you know i have to fill out a
hearing report for every single i know